Hello, everybody.
Oh, your Fugi's also in front of me.
I forgot to get rid of the Fugi.
Do I have one?
Yeah, you have like a little, like the spinning Fugi.
And like, she's literally right in front of you.
And she's just, it's like a little baby.
Like a little baby spinning in front of you right now.
Yay!
Let me get rid of her.
Sorry, guys.
We're gonna kill off Mini Doobie.
She's gone now.
She's gone.
We put her in the farm.
Oh, it's like you're gonna say fire.
Yes, the most horrific death you can do.
The most painful one.
Cast her into the pits of fire.
Hello, everybody.
Yes, hello, everyone.
Today, Doobie is gonna be teaching me a CS.
My worst genre when it comes to shooters.
Oh, have you played before?
Apparently, I'm private rank 4.
So, I... technically, I have.
But it was when... not CS2.
I don't think I've touched CS2.
I've touched CSGO.
And...
Yeah.
But, so, I don't know how...
Does it like transfer over?
Like your previous stuff?
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, it's pretty much...
It's like how Overwatch got rid of Overwatch 1.
Yeah.
And Overwatch 2.
Oh, yeah.
And then you keep your rank and everything.
Oh, okay.
That makes sense.
And everything.
It's actually...
They're pretty similar.
Yeah, because like I heard like...
That's why people were opening so many knives back then for CS...
CSGO.
Because it was like the knife stock market.
So, everybody thought that knife prices were gonna go up and stuff when CS2.
When CS2, so...
Yeah, so, it's sort of like a stock market for me.
Like...
Yeah.
Yeah, some people will play and get their two cases.
And then from that, some cases go for like...
$17 now, so...
Jesus.
Oh, my God.
I remember I asked you how much you spent on cases alone.
I...
No, because I have cases.
Like a bunch of cases saved up over the years.
So, I haven't spent too much.
Oh, you haven't spent...
Oh, wait.
But how much have you spent?
Also, you're...
The...
The chroma mask is not working very well...
Because your tongue is transparent.
Let me fix that.
Sorry.
That's a weird color, too.
Okay, I fixed it.
Yeah, I forgot you picked red.
I have green.
I have blue.
It's typical.
Oh, it's the keys?
Oh, I forgot.
Like...
For CS2, you have to buy keys.
Not cases.
Yeah, yeah.
Keys and cases.
You have to buy both.
Yeah, I don't really follow...
I think, like...
I remember when CS was super...
CSGO was super duper popular back then.
And, like, everybody was just doing case openings.
And, like...
Like, it was just an entire...
Like, VOD just dedicated it to opening cases and stuff.
Because, like, knives can go for, like, thousands of dollars.
Wait.
What's your most expensive knife, Doobie?
Oh, I only have one knife.
So, that's my most expensive knife.
Oh.
Yes.
Wait.
How expensive is it?
It's probably, like, maybe...
80 bucks.
Is it because it's, like...
It's really low.
Is it because it's, like, super...
I know, like, they have, like, grade and stuff with the knives.
Like, when it's, like, super worn.
Or, like, super used or something.
Is that...
Yeah.
It's also just the pattern.
Because it's just the safari mesh.
Oh.
So, yeah.
It's pretty ugly.
But it's...
Oh, okay.
It's 200 bucks.
That's pretty good.
Oh, I mean.
That's better than 80.
Yeah.
But, yes.
Doobie's gonna teach me all about CS in general.
Like, UTIL, NAE, lineups.
The...
What was it?
Like, when you crouch next to the other person.
The other person jumps on you.
And then you push them up towards high ground.
And that's the only thing I can remember.
Oh, yeah.
The boosting.
Yeah, the boosting.
Yeah, yeah.
I remember when CSGO was, like, the peak of CSGO.
And, like, everybody was streaming on that on Twitch back then.
Um, that was the one thing I, like, picked up on.
The boost.
If you boost, I feel like most of the time you just end up dying.
Wait, really?
Then what the fuck's the point?
Like, it just looks cool, I guess.
It works sometimes.
Yeah.
It just looks cool.
It does.
Yeah, but, yeah, I'm looking forward to Doobie teaching me, uh, CS2.
And then, like, when we both get too tilted, we can play Overwatch later.
Yeah, that'll cure us.
Yeah, yeah.
We go from one poison to the next.
It's, like, you go from, from smoking to drinking.
Like, we were playing...
Wait, no, we're playing something specific in Overwatch, though, right?
Yeah, Stadium.
That's better.
It's a little, it's a little better.
So, it's, like, from, uh, smoking to maybe caffeine, I guess.
Oh, okay.
Wait, so, wait, what is Stadium?
I guess I've never, I've never played it.
Yeah, okay, so you never played, uh, Stadium.
Okay, Stadium, you know, it's basically, like, what if they made Overwatch a MOBA?
But, like, without, like, the top-downs.
It's still a hero shooter, but, like, so, like, you're sent into, like, mini fights, like, mini battles, but it's still the same map.
It's just, like, miniaturized it.
And then, like, each...
And there's, like, you have to win, I think, like, four rounds.
But each round, you get to upgrade your character.
So, there's some, like, inc...
Oh, it's just paladins.
Apparently, it's just paladins.
I forgot.
Like, I've only played paladins.
I like paladins at once.
Yeah.
Yeah, I forgot about paladins.
But it's basically paladins, and there's some really fucking crazy builds you can do.
So, Mora could, like, throw, like, three orbs at once.
And then, like, Reinhardt could do a thing where he fire strikes and then leaves, like, a pool of lava behind the fire strike.
That'll damage you.
Like, it's, like, there's, like, lots of crazy shit you can do.
And then...
Trail trail?
Okay, got it.
Yeah, and then there was one where Ash can send out, like, a fucking tiny baby bob.
Like, it's, like, a tiny miniature-sized baby bob.
So, like, the hitbox is smaller.
But there's, like, so much crazy stuff.
Like, it's actually really, really fun.
And the rounds are, like, really short.
So, it's not like you're being held hostage in general.
And even when you're losing, you can still turn it around because it depends on what you're building type deal.
So, you could just, you know, just lose to far more points to build a better character.
So...
Okay.
Yeah, so I think you'll have a lot of fun because, like, it's actually so much fun, more fun than, like, regular Overwatch, which is, like, an accomplishment.
No, it does...
Because, yeah, the combination of different stuff sounds cool.
Yeah, like, just, like...
I'm excited!
Yeah, me too!
Alright, so...
I think you have to just add me.
And, like, invite me to a...
I don't even know how...
I think this is, like, the first time I've ever booted a CS2.
Yeah, I'll send you an invite when you watch it.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, I'm already in.
Oh, do I have to be, like, appear online?
Like, mine's a...
You know, like, it hides my game status with what I'm doing?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Alright.
Yeah, I got it.
I got Green Sonic's invite.
Okay.
I think we can play...
Well, I'll show you, like, one map specifically.
And then we'll just...
Is it dust?
...on that...
Yeah.
It's...
It's always dust.
Yeah.
Alright, let me boost up Doobie's volume a little bit.
I hope everybody...
I hope Doobie...
Mic check.
One, two, three.
Choo-choo.
Alright, that was really loud.
Alright.
My game crashed.
Oh, yeah.
I was like, boy, she disappeared.
Why didn't...
What the heck?
Even the game was like...
I haven't had it crashed.
The game was like, just play Overwatch.
Not yet.
I was just playing, so it was fine.
I don't know.
You disappeared.
It's not Tuesday.
It's not Steam.
It's not Tuesday, ain't it?
Oh, the, uh...
Yeah, the Steam.
Is that the Steam maintenance day?
Yeah, the Steam maintenance day.
Oh, I know.
My whole computer is...
Wait.
Uh...
What?
Hold on, it's like frozen.
What the?
Oh, my God.
That's not good.
My computer just blue screened.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
Wait, it's Friday the 13th.
Fuck.
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck.
Oh, man.
Friday the 13th.
Hold on, it's restarting.
Okay.
Do you do a dual PC setup?
Yeah.
Oh, that's smart.
That's smart.
I put all my gambling on one.
No, I have one.
I put it all on one PC.
I know that's, like, really fucking stupid to do.
Like, I'm like...
But, I...
It's just...
It's easier.
It is easier, because it's, like, you know, with one...
It doesn't, like, lag as much, too.
Like, you don't put too much strain on your PC when it comes to streaming and gaming at the same time.
Like, I can feel, like, my room, my office is basically, like, a green room.
But, like...
Well, not even a green room.
It's, like, there's no...
It's the opposite of a green room.
There's no windows in my office.
So, like, I have to put the air conditioning, like, really, really cold.
Because if I don't, it's, like...
It's basically, like, a fucking sauna in my office.
Because there's no windows.
Yeah, I was gonna say, at least in the winter, you have a personal heater.
Yes.
No, in the winter, I have to turn on the...
I have to turn on air conditioning.
No, it's too hot.
Because it's a hot box.
Because I went from...
The only reason why I picked this room as my office is because...
Before I moved, my other office, my old office, was the greenhouse.
So, like...
But it had, like, three of the walls were just giant balcony windows.
Where it goes from, like, almost to the floor to the top of the ceiling.
So, then the sun was just shining right into my office every time I stream in the morning.
And then...
So, then I was, like, never again.
So, then I ended up choosing...
Yeah, it gets in your face, right?
Like, the sun.
Yeah, and it gets really fucking hot, too.
So, I was, like, never again.
And then I went from one extreme to the next.
And have no windows now.
Alright.
I'm in.
Yeah, you lock yourself in.
It's like a padded room.
Yeah.
Alright, that's two.
Force yourself to stream, you know?
Yeah, exactly.
Alright.
Good old...
Okay.
Vitamin D.
Alright.
I'm compiling shaders.
Okay.
Alright.
I guess I'll be counter-terrorist.
Oh, my God.
This crosshair sucks.
Okay, give me an idea of fixing my crosshair.
Oh.
There's, like, follow recoil.
Some people are, like...
What?
They really hate it.
But then other times, they're, like, oh, it's...
It's really good.
So, I don't know.
It's a preference, you know?
Follow recoil?
What does that do?
Oh, um...
It, like, bounces in response to how the gun is recoiling.
So, each gun has a specific spray pattern.
Oh, I see.
I noticed it.
So, it just does a little bounce.
I don't like that.
That throws me out.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait.
No, it still does the bounce.
Uh...
Oh.
Oh, I just did friendly...
Oh, I turn off friendly fire.
Or, like, turn...
Off the notification for it.
Okay, there you go.
What?
Why does it still bounce?
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Oh, it's because of my recoil.
I'm so scared.
I figured it out.
No, if you turn off recoil bounce, it shouldn't...
Like, the crosshair itself shouldn't move.
But your gun will...
Yeah, yeah.
It's my gun moving.
I'm so not used to this.
Oh, my God.
I'm so...
I'm just, like...
Oh, my God.
We did this collab because you were watching...
You were watching me play with, uh...
Remia, right?
Oh, yeah.
I was...
Because we...
We talked about it in our last collab.
Oh, you're teaching me CS.
But then, like...
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, yeah.
So, then...
And then, like...
Our skip...
Like, you know...
We've both been super duper busy.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
We were talking in chat.
Because you told about how you knew Adept.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
So...
Doobie and I...
I found out from...
From that last stream.
Um...
I also used to know Adept, too.
Oh.
And back in the Overwatch days...
Oh, wait.
I need to bring my game down a little bit first before I keep going.
Like, um...
And...
So, she...
Doobie was talking about...
Um...
How she tried to start a female Overwatch team.
And Adept was in it.
And the thing is...
I know about that Overwatch team.
Because...
Yeah, that's crazy.
We...
I...
Um...
Because...
I think...
It might have been you that approached me to join that team.
In the book for a time.
I got two DMs about this team.
And one of them was Adept.
So, I don't know if the other one was you.
Uh...
I don't...
I don't think so.
Because I was not, like, super social.
I just...
I don't know.
Yeah.
I don't think I directly approached people.
Like, they were the ones who were just kind of...
Took it over, in a sense.
Yeah.
Like, I just kind of started it.
So...
The thing is, like...
Um...
I got recruited to Doobie's team.
I said no.
So, we almost...
We almost played together.
I said no.
Because I...
I'm sorry, Doobie.
I did not want to join an all-female Overwatch team.
That's fine.
I wasn't even that serious about it.
I was just looking for something to do, you know?
And then I completely forgot about it.
Like, I didn't even...
Yeah.
Oh my god.
I didn't even think about it anymore after a while.
Like, I kind of just forgot about it, so...
That was crazy.
Like, when I heard about that, I was like, No way.
That team?
Because it was, like...
Sort of, like...
Not well infamous, I would say.
That's the word.
In the Overwatch Tier 2 scene.
Because it was the first all-female Tier 2 Overwatch team at that time.
Really?
Yeah, it was.
It was.
Because, like...
I know...
I knew all the girls that were in it.
And then...
But did you tell more, Laura, about that team?
Or am I allowed to tell them?
No.
No, I don't...
I honestly don't even remember because my brain went somewhere else after that.
So, that team was sort of infamous in the Overwatch Tier 2 scene.
Because I was also doing Tier 2 Overwatch at that point.
And I was actually...
You get your team trying to recruit me and my other friend for your team.
And the thing is that we were already in a team together.
But it was, like, a mixed team.
So, we're like, oh, yeah.
Like, we'd rather stay in our mixed team than join the all-female team.
And then I remember, because it was low-key drama at that time.
Because, you know, like, the Tier 2 scene was, like, a lot...
You know, like, in general, the Tier 2 competitive scene, there's always drama.
And I remember, like, three of your girls...
Like, one girl, like, left and then poached two other girls on your team to form a new team.
And I remember that.
Yeah, I don't even know.
I don't remember anything like that.
But I believe you.
Because that's why I remember that.
And then I remember that situation.
Because people were, like...
Because I remember, because, like...
I think it was either Banff or Adept that were complaining about it to other people.
So that's why I heard about it.
That is pretty crazy to think about, though.
Yeah.
We were so close to knowing each other for a long time.
Yeah, we almost knew each other then.
I thought it was crazy.
I was like, wait, what?
You were on that team?
I was like, holy shit.
When I realized you were watching that stream.
Because I was, like...
I think I used the wrong words for it.
We were comparing, like, Marvel Rivals and Counter-Strike.
Like, competitive.
Like, pro scene, I guess.
Yeah.
And I think there is really high-level Marvel Rivals play, obviously.
But I think I just worded it wrong.
And I was thinking...
I was like, shoot, Doki was watching that.
I didn't mean it like that.
It's just like...
For Marvel!
It's so cute.
It's like a lot of unpredictability, right?
With, like...
Oh, there is.
Because, like, Marvel Rivals rely more on, like, ability...
It's like Overwatch.
It relies more on, like, abilities and, like...
Yeah.
And, like, alt coordination.
And it's like whoever...
Yeah.
Whoever, like, does the better...
And, like...
Okay, the thing I don't like...
Not don't like about Marvel Rivals competitive...
But it's very different from Overwatch competitive...
Is that in Marvel Rivals, it's a rock-paper-scissors.
Because it's a banline.
Because Overwatch doesn't have a banline.
So, like, it's whichever team does the better banline...
That can fuck over the other team.
Because, you know...
Because, like...
It's all about counterpicking.
But there's also, like, rock-paper-scissors as well.
Because, like...
If they have a better bandline, then the other team is more fucked.
Because they might have a bandline where it makes them play worse compared to the usual.
Because their DPS players might be on characters that they're not the best at.
And stuff like that.
But I heard Overwatch has bandlines now too.
Because they're like, oh shit, it's working now.
They saw a rival...
Because Marvel Rivals is an Overwatch competitor now.
So they're now like trying...
They're both like copying each other on what to do.
To have a bigger player base.
Oh, yeah, yeah, that makes sense.
Yeah.
I was gonna say something, but I forgot.
Oh.
Alright, teach me.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Um...
Wait, let's wait until the next round.
Oh, okay.
Just make sure to buy smoke.
Make sure to buy smoke.
No, I deserve it.
I mean...
Yeah, we...
Well, it's faster.
Wait, then we can just kill each other now.
Okay.
I'll buy a smoke.
Buy a smoke and a M4.
M4?
The fuck is an M4?
Oh, well, you'll see it in the buy menu.
It's like, you've played Valorant before, right?
Barely.
I do not retain any information.
Oh.
You know how to open the buy menu, right?
Yeah, I know how to open the buy menu.
I bought the smoke.
I'm like, where the fuck is...
Which...
Isn't the rifles mid-tier?
Or...
Yeah.
Uh...
It should be the far right.
The far?
Oh.
Second row, I think.
Or something like that.
I didn't get it.
Oh, that's okay.
Here.
Oh, nice.
Take that.
Okay.
Well, first, we gotta do this kind of fast.
So, this is CT spawns.
Yeah.
So, you're a counter-terrorist.
And then, everybody spawns here.
And people split off.
So, there's like, five people.
So, this is mid-doors, right here.
Yeah.
So, you can see up...
Oh, like, if you back up a bit, people will hold right here.
And you can see up...
Up until the top of mid.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
And this is where the opera usually go.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
That's called suicide, because if you...
I'm sending an instant headshot.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
So, this is lower tons over here.
So, this goes over to B.
Okay.
And then, over here, this is called Xbox.
I'm not sure why it's called Xbox.
I guess this is green and it's a box.
This is called Xbox.
Oh, I guess so.
And you can do like a little jump and if you crouch...
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
And then, this is cat, but sometimes people call it short.
Uh-huh.
And...
Uh...
Yeah, I'm just teaching the call-outs because a lot of times...
Um...
People are just communicating like, oh, they're cat, they're short, they're long.
Yeah.
But...
Like, you don't really know.
But, uh...
It's pretty...
I feel like this map is pretty self-explanatory.
So, it's long.
Yeah, I mean, it basically is...
It doesn't...
It didn't change much from CSGO, right?
No, not really.
No, I don't think so.
And then, this is pit.
Oh.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh.
Okay, we don't have time here.
Kill me with your...
Okay.
With the AK.
No, with the AK.
Okay.
That works.
I can't...
I don't wanna waste my bullet.
Oh.
You'll get it back.
Okay.
Wait, there's a second page for a rifle?
What?
Oh, wait, no.
I see it.
Oh, I see it.
M4A1.
I just can't read.
I got it.
Alright, so come up mid and meet me in suicide.
Okay.
Alright, I'm here.
Alright, come all the way up here.
And then, uh...
Yeah?
Let me show you some smokes, I guess.
I'll show you a smoke.
Alright.
I only know one.
Oh, wait.
What?
What do you mean you don't need a one?
Okay, you know that...
There's no...
I mean, you can use your smoke.
Okay, I know two smokes, but...
Oh, yeah.
So, pretty much, um...
You're gonna stand in this corner.
Yeah?
And then, you're gonna line up your crosshair.
There's like a...
You see the shadow?
Which one?
There's like a shadow right, uh...
Right here.
What?
It's like a shadow on the building.
Oh, okay.
So, just like the...
The...
The indent between...
Yeah, but do it above.
So, like where I'm shooting.
So, like put your crosshair right up...
Up above.
Like at the corner?
On your crosshair's...
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Above the corner.
Above the corner, okay.
Yeah.
And then...
Jump and throw your smoke at the same time.
Okay.
Oh.
That's okay, that's okay.
Here, here, here.
Okay, okay.
That's a...
It's just...
Test run.
It's a test run.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
When you spawn on T spawn, you're going to want to throw that smoke pretty...
Somebody on the team will probably be able to do it, but this is just like an example.
Someone else will smoke for me.
I'm not the smoker.
Someone else can smoke.
It takes a while.
So now, like, say you're on T, there's somebody watching mid-doors, so you can go cat now.
Because it's smoked off, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, and then you can push.
Oh, so you smoke the off-road, I see.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then you can use smokes, like, anywhere pretty much.
Yeah.
We'll just quickly go to B.
This is, like, lower tons to upper tons.
Uh-huh.
And that's T spawn over there, and then...
Okay.
B site is here.
Wait, do you not bunny hop?
Oh, uh, I don't think so, maybe.
Not really.
They changed it, it used to be easier.
Oh, okay, I was gonna say.
I know, like, oh my...
I didn't know you played Cheetah's Cheetah, or Cheetah, the one where, like, you're a bunch of cheetahs, and then they all have aimbot, and aimbot, and hacking.
And then, like, so I had, like, a bunch of dragoons joining me for it.
And then there was, like, two people that knew how to B-hop, and, like, they were so fucking fast.
It's like, oh, it's so easy!
Joki, it's so, look at me!
Oh, it's called Cheetahs, because it's like...
Yeah, you're cheap.
Yeah.
Cheetah...
I haven't played it.
It's me!
Yeah, so, like, you could tell who played CS when we were playing that game.
I still have trauma from it.
What people do is they bind jump to, like, scroll wheel, and then...
Oh, that makes sense.
It's just, like, brrrrrr.
It's just, like, Apex.
That makes sense.
Oh, I forgot to buy it.
Oh, never mind.
I didn't buy a smoke.
It's okay.
All right, so, well, I'll show you a spray pattern.
Oh, wait.
Actually, it's the same spray pattern, really.
So, I'll just use this, like, we can sh...
Uh, hold on.
Don't shoot me.
Okay.
We'll stand here, and then just hold.
Is it a tap, though?
And don't... don't move the gun, like, while you're, uh...
Yeah.
So, just so you can see the spray pattern.
Jesus.
See how it goes?
Yeah.
Yeah, that's how you usually tap, right?
So, what people do is they go...
Yeah, you usually one-tap, or you, uh, pull down and to the left.
So, like, try pulling down and to the left.
Yeah, it's, like, a little bit more stable.
Yeah.
All right, so, let's do...
We'll do a target practice.
Uh, you...
Here, I'll...
Oh, I'll stand over here.
Okay.
And then, yeah, you can shoot me now.
No!
Yay!
I thought you were gonna practice the spray pattern.
Just one-tap, you need.
I...
My crosshair was just on your head.
Buy an...
Buy an AWP.
An AWP, okay.
Okay.
Do you know what?
You don't snipe?
Oh, man.
No, I'm so bad at sniping.
I'm really fucking bad at sniping.
Okay.
But, like, AWP is, like, supposedly very easy.
Because it's, like, one-shot.
Yeah.
It's, like, one-shot body-shot.
It is really easy.
Yeah.
Um, oh, so in this...
Okay, oh.
No, no, no, that works, right?
I actually were, like, when we tried sniping.
Oh, oh, so, uh, in this game, what people do is they run with their knife out.
You know that, right?
Yeah, yeah, you're fast, too.
I know that, yeah.
Yeah, but...
Does Valorant do that, too?
I think so.
I think it's, like, just a tactical shooter thing.
Also, sound guy boosted Doobie a bit up more.
So, let me know if she's more audible.
Okay.
All right, so what were you gonna say about the AWP?
Uh, no, I just wanted you to try using it.
Oh, okay, okay.
Yeah.
I'm learning.
Let's see, I'm trying to think what else can I show you.
Oh, uh, I'll let you backstab me.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, where's the smoke line?
I wanna try that again.
Oh, okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, this time.
There's another one you can try that's a little bit easier if you want.
Or, try that one.
Okay, I figured it out.
Oh, here in this corner?
Yeah.
I figured it out.
And then, slightly above the shadow, so, like, uh...
Um...
Is that...
Where did that go?
No.
Let's see, wait, wait, here, here, here.
Pick this up.
Yeah.
Where did it go?
I could show you another one.
Oh, yeah.
Try it.
This one's easier.
So...
Like, stand next to me.
Yeah.
Do you see this line that's right there?
Like, a line in the map?
Yeah.
Yeah, so, line up with that, like, your body.
And then, look at, uh...
There's a dot right there.
So, look at that.
And then...
Wait, where?
Um...
Oh, where I shot, like, right there?
Oh, right here.
Oh, okay.
There's so many holes.
I think just look at that and then jump and throw at the same time.
Okay.
All right.
Like that?
Nice.
Yeah.
Did that make it?
It's like, look...
Yeah, you kind of...
Yeah!
Yeah, I think it works.
Nice!
And I'll never do that in real game.
In real life.
This might not be good for, like, going cat, but...
It could still work.
Yeah, it could still work.
Yeah, yeah.
All right, kill me.
Okay.
Yeah!
I'll try to think what else is there I can show you.
Oh, uh, by a Zeus.
It's under the armor.
Oh, armor, okay.
Oh, is that the electrocuted one?
Uh-huh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
It looks like an electric...
Usually people always buy, um, like, the Kevlar and the helmet, too.
Yeah.
When they have enough money.
Oh my god, yeah, this is also why...
Usually...
It's also why I don't like tactical shooters, because I have to do math.
All right.
Yeah, kind of...
Well, kind of.
There...
Yeah, it's the economy.
You have to keep...
Yeah.
All right, so what do I do with a Zeus?
Oh, you have to be pretty close and see if you can get me.
Oh.
Oh, what the f...
Oh, what?
It was on you!
You have to be super, super close.
Oh, okay.
I get it.
Okay, I was like, okay.
My crosshair was definitely on you there.
All right, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna plant the bomb, so you can experience, um, defusing it.
Okay.
All right, are you gonna...
Oh.
Are you gonna rush B?
We should probably buy some other nades, like, just to get an idea.
Yeah?
No...
No.
Are you gonna rush B?
Oh!
No.
God fucking...
Okay.
Where are you?
Oh, where?
Oh.
Hi!
Wait, you get immunity from that?
No, no, no, I don't.
I don't.
You just missed.
Okay.
Wait, how do I defuse?
I don't remember how to defuse.
Oh, press E.
Oh, is it E?
Okay.
Oh my god, you whore.
So, usually you're supposed to buy, um, a defuse kit.
The defuse kit will make it so it's only five seconds.
So, quick, quick, come defuse.
I think you can...
Okay.
You should stop.
No!
Wait, did I make it?
I think you got it!
Did I make it?
Oh, I made it.
Nice.
Okay.
All right.
Nice.
I'll try to think what else is there to show you.
I guess, uh, we could try the...
Buy an MP4, I think it's called.
Okay.
MP4.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll test with the, uh, the, uh, submachine guns.
Oh, wait.
MP4?
Where is that one?
Wait, maybe it's not MP4.
MP5?
Yeah, I was gonna say, there's no four here.
There is.
I have a collection of guns right now.
All right.
Nice.
Yay!
Oh, yeah.
You seem pretty used to pressing crouch, like, while shooting, right?
That's because the...
It's from watching too many CSGO streams back then.
Oh, yeah.
So, I know, like...
I always see people crouch whenever they play CS.
Hmm.
Yeah, it does help, uh...
Actually, I...
I don't know what it does.
No, I think that's still saying.
Yeah, I was gonna say, I don't know what it does.
It's supposed to help, uh, like, with recoil a bit.
I'm pretty sure.
I see.
I don't know what it does.
I just saw people do it.
So, I was just like, okay.
If they do it, then that means they know what they...
That means it's good.
Oh, uh, try...
Try going around, uh, to A site.
A site, okay.
And then, yeah.
I'll try pushing long so you can get, uh...
A good idea of how it usually goes.
Oh, I should've bought a spoke.
Oh, well.
Oh, all right.
MP4 video, yeah.
All right.
So, usually they come out, like, long doors, and then they come into pit, and they're, like...
Oh my god, you shot me.
...hitting, sniping.
Oh my god.
And then, I forgot to smoke, but they'll always smoke, like, this area.
So, like, say you're rotating from me.
You can't really see, like, when they cross over, like this.
Yeah.
And then...
And then, what?
They tried to plant, like, here for long.
Yeah.
I didn't like it.
Oh, and then this is goose here, because, like, look over here.
Wait, why is it goose?
Oh, there's a goose.
Yeah, yeah.
So, this is, like, the call out, like, oh, goose, goose.
Yeah.
Oh, they're like, they're a goose, they're a goose.
This call out's really complicated over here.
This one's called car.
A car, yeah.
Is there only one car on this map?
Um, actually, no.
There's a car on B, too.
Oh, okay, it's like A car.
That one is also car.
I guess it'll be, like, A car.
You can, uh, you can defuse.
Oh, wait, try backstabbing me.
It's an instant kill, usually, I think.
Oh, nice.
Well, guess I'll die.
Goodbye.
If you, if you, uh, knife someone with mouse one, it's gonna take, like, two or three hits before you kill them.
Oh, so it's just, like, Valorant with the, the right click thing.
Mm, yeah.
Okay.
All right, now I'm a terrorist.
All right, so...
Yeah, well, uh, you can go plant.
I'll let you try planting.
Oh, okay.
Uh...
I got this.
I know what to do.
I believe in you.
I know what to do now.
I know what you're gonna do.
No, you don't.
Yeah, huh.
What am I gonna do?
You're gonna rush B, aren't you?
Haha, you think that.
Or maybe, maybe I am, or maybe I am rushing B right now, just to mess with you.
Maybe I am doing that.
Or maybe I'm mid.
Oh, I see.
Oh, wait, I flashed myself.
I thought...
You know what you think?
It goes higher than what it's supposed to.
That's me right now.
I thought it'd go higher.
Oh, and, um, do you know, like, you can shift walk?
Oh, yeah, yeah, the, uh, so you don't make noise.
Oh!
Yeah.
I'm playing.
Oh.
Okay, so, um...
Oh, so when you're falling down, you, uh, the momentum stops when you're throwing a name.
Is that it?
Oh.
I don't know.
So when my chat said that...
Actually, I'm not sure.
Yeah.
So I'm not sure either.
Yeah, you do have to throw it, like, right when you're at that apex of your jump.
Oh!
I guess, the top of your jump.
I see.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let me, let me try, I'll try throwing a smoke just to un...
Because I do it subconsciously, so I'm not really sure.
Let me try.
Who cares about economy?
So you, you can press mouse one with your nade out and just hold it out and then you jump and release.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, and then if you hold mouse one long enough, uh, it comes up with, like, a grenade crosshair.
It takes up the whole screen.
Uh-huh.
Oh, okay.
So it's both, you just, like, preempted, oh my god, fuck.
God, I hate you, Till.
I hate you, Till, so much.
I'm just using my ability that I bought that is in a can.
It's an ability in a can.
Okay, nice.
Oh, nice!
Yeah, I think you got it.
Really?
I'm a real CS player now.
Let's go!
Uh, so I wonder if we should try playing a game after this?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
And then I'll never use my util.
I think it takes a while to get used to using it.
Yeah, because it's, like, it's just, like, so much information when it comes to util.
And then making, like, smoke placements and shit like that.
I'm just, I just want to shoot things.
What do you mean?
Wait, what do you mean so much information?
Marvel has how many characters?
That's so much!
How many villains do you know?
I just put my, I just put my crosshair on someone and then they're dead.
It's different.
It's so different.
That's, that's exactly what this meme is.
That's what it comes down to.
There's no smoke.
There's no smoke in Marvel Rivals.
Really?
It's my one weakness.
I'm pretty sure Punisher has a smoke.
Yeah, it lasts, like, two seconds.
Yeah, it does, it does.
No, the smokes do last a crazy long time.
Yeah, they last looking forever.
Are you Goose again?
No.
Wouldn't you wanna know?
Oh, nice.
That's right.
Trying to get you with my scalp.
You said I was Goose and I walked away from Goose.
All right.
Oh, you should try using, do you have the Deagle equipped?
The Desert Eagle?
Oh yeah, I do.
Oh, 1v1 Desert Eagle?
What have you been working for?
Yeah.
Yeah, my brain...
I feel like, uh, you'll probably do better than me.
What?
No!
I suck with the Deagle.
Oh no, I suck at Pistol too, so don't worry.
Oh, I know where you are.
Wait, do I though?
Actually, I don't know.
I'm so bad at using numbers.
You know when you're swapping equipment?
I just use scroll wheel.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I mostly just use scroll wheel.
Yeah, me too.
I mostly use scroll wheel and then I have like a switch to primary weapon on like mouse 4.
Oh, that's smart.
Yeah, I do that for Apex, but for Marvel, I just use my scroll wheel because it's just two weapons.
Where are you?
I don't know, I think I'll let you win this one.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait wait, wait, wait.
Were you in the middle of throwing that?
You popped up and I had my grenade.
Okay, I don't know.
Did you actually waited?
Did I wait?
Did you wait when I said wait?
Oh, no, no, no.
I was all the way at long doors.
Okay.
I don't know how... Yeah, I don't know how I survived that.
All right.
Oh, shit!
Oh, man!
Damn it!
I knew you'd be too much Desert Eagle.
Yeah, you baited me.
I was like, holy fuck.
I don't know how I survived.
Now you'll think I'm gonna go B again.
But joke's on you.
That's definitely where I'm going next.
All right, I'll see you there.
Oh, my mouse 4 is voice chat.
That's weird.
Oh, where am I?
Doobie.
Where am I?
Not at B.
Where could I be?
Ho, ho, ho.
Dang it.
Where could I be, Doobie?
Ha, ha, ha.
Oh, my God!
How did you know?
Ha, ha, ha, ha!
Sorry.
I don't think you can jump up there.
No, I thought you were gonna go to the main door and I was gonna do, like, a sick air shot.
But it didn't work out.
It didn't work.
It wasn't as sick as I thought.
All right.
Wait, does this make it?
Let me try.
Ow.
Wait.
Oh, fuck.
I forgot about fall damage.
Oh, you should use flashes, too.
Like, whenever you're doing your first entry onto whatever point you're going on.
All right.
Okay.
I did.
Oh, did you smoke mid?
Oh.
Maybe.
I thought I heard a smoke.
Oh.
Which way would you go?
You gotta be sneaky.
I be sneaky when I can just shoot the head.
That's because you're, like, giving away information.
So, when you were jumping, I knew that you were in that corner.
Yeah.
Oh, that's smart.
All right.
I know what to do.
I learned this.
Oh, my God.
I think that hits.
I did it.
What'd you do?
When you want to know.
But then I went the wrong way.
I went the wrong way.
I...
What did you hit?
When you want to know.
What the fuck?
When did you go over here?
How did you get there?
I was, like, by a CT spawn.
When you go mid-door, like, pots to cat.
Oh, my God.
I didn't know you could do that.
I was so confused.
How did you get there so fast?
So, what did you do?
Did you throw, like, a smoke?
Yeah, I threw smoke through mid.
And I was, like, I did it.
Oh.
Yeah, I didn't see it.
Whoa.
I don't think you're smoke mid at all.
No, no.
I didn't under smoke in mid.
Did you see it?
It tricked me!
Yes!
That's messed up.
It worked.
It made me to look.
All right, all right.
Okay, you should see my POV.
The moment I said Ted, I just, you just peaked out.
My crosshair was right on you, too.
Yeah, it's the psychological warfare.
I made you look.
All right.
Now it's time for a real game.
It's time.
I don't think it's gonna work with the other real players.
Like, other people were like, did you see it?
So, we're gonna be...
Oh, true.
I'm gonna fix one of my settings.
Okay.
No problem.
Oh, man.
I'm gonna get absolutely shit on now.
No, you have good aim.
That's all this game comes down to.
Well, aim and movement, I guess.
Yeah, I don't know where cover is.
I was literally standing in the open.
Just crouch behind your teammate.
Oh, okay.
Can't follow you around.
Wait, me?
Do it to one of the other teammates.
But we're a duo.
D and D.
Can't have the D without...
Oh, yeah.
We can't have the D without the other D.
We're missing a D.
The double Ds.
Yeah, the double Ds.
That's how we like them.
Wait, actually.
Yeah, that's how we like them.
The double Ds.
Okay.
I guess it's pissed around.
Teammates?
Well, I'm sure you're used to talking with people online.
Like, in games and stuff.
Oh, yeah.
I was gonna say.
CS is a different one.
That's where the people get extra gamey.
Alright, let me...
How the fuck?
Yeah.
Where the fuck is the other player voice?
Okay, zero.
Yeah, I don't...
I don't want to risk it.
Unless they're Russian.
Okay.
And it's a little silly.
Yeah, they'll...
Oh, okay.
So...
I'm gonna pick up the bomb.
Because this guy dropped it.
Alright.
Oh, hey.
So, we got some picks on B.
So, we'll probably just go B, I think.
Okay.
Oh, our guy got another pick.
Let's go.
I'm right behind you.
Nice.
Oh, another one close.
Ah.
Where is he?
Oh, he's there.
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
Here, teammate.
He's like, car.
No, I turned it down.
I got scared.
Okay, I'll turn it.
I did it.
Oh, okay.
I keep mine, like, at 30%.
Oh, 30?
Yeah.
So, I can still kind of here.
Alright, I'll put it at 30%.
I was like, where is he?
Alright.
Oh, so, in the first round, usually people buy, like, the Kevlar vest.
And then, second round, we buy the Kevlar and helmet.
Okay.
And then, you could buy an AK, but a lot of times, people will just buy, like, Mac-10 and Rush.
With the armor and stuff.
Oh.
Are we blue or yellow?
Oh, no.
We're yellow.
We're yellow?
Oh, like the kill feed.
Yeah.
Yeah, we are yellow.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Teesside is always, uh, yellow.
Is always yellow?
Oh.
Ooh, we're terrorists.
Don't worry, I am...
Oh, wait.
Don't worry, I'm looking at car.
Okay, nice.
Oh, one's coming window.
So, this is window up there.
Uh-huh.
Oh, nice.
Oh, one's tunnels.
So, where I died, there's tunnels.
Okay.
There's no way he didn't know I'm here.
Yay!
No.
No, we're doing it!
Oh, my God, this game is easy.
Yeah, see?
Yeah, it is.
It is.
We just...
It's just aimed at the head.
That's all you gotta do.
I feel like the way you play, though, you probably like to go pretty fast, right?
Like, Apex has good movement.
Yeah, like, I think that was my issue with...
This is faster than Valorant, though.
Which is nice.
My issue with...
Really?
My issue...
Well, I guess because we're on quick play right now.
But, like, when I play Valorant quick play, people are just, like, lurking and shit all the time.
Or, like...
Oh.
They play so fucking slow.
But right now, everyone's playing super fast.
I just assume it's more so, like...
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Oh, we're both bad at screen.
The guy that did...
He wasn't looking at my screen.
And then we both whiffed.
Oh.
Reading chat, huh?
Yeah.
Tsk, tsk.
But it's more so, like...
You know how, like...
In Valorant, everybody plays so fucking slow.
And then they rotate a lot and stuff like that.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
This is, like, a lot fast-paced.
But I also assume it's fast-paced because it's quick play.
Oh.
Oh, we're playing comp right now.
Wait, this is comp?
Yeah.
Well, there's comp, which is kind of like quick play.
Then there's also premiere.
Which is, like, the actual ranks.
Yeah.
So you still get a rank on this, on comp, once you win.
Single maps, though.
So you could get a rank on Dust today if you wanted.
But I don't know if we'll go that far.
Wait, so, like...
It's rank per map and not rank overall?
Yeah, there is overall rank, but it's premiere.
But in competitive, there's rank per map.
And it's kind of is like quick play because there's only casual.
Which is, like, you have ten people on each side.
Which is different.
This is, like, a 5v5 normal competitive.
Oh, I see.
I smoked mid.
I don't know that'll help anybody.
No.
It was a good smoke.
It was a really good smoke.
This guy right around the corner.
Okay, I got one.
I think there might be another one to your left, but I'm not sure.
No!
He headshot me!
I don't even know.
You hit him a little bit, though.
How do I see how much damage I did on him?
Oh, you have to wait until the round is over.
And then it will show up, like, above.
So you can't be, like...
Yeah, it'll show up under their names.
Oh, I see.
There used to be a way that you could open up, like, the console command.
Uh-huh.
And see how much damage you did.
Yeah, because, like...
Yeah, they patched it out.
In Valorant, you'd be like, oh, like, 30 breach or some shit.
Like, or stuff like that.
So...
I thought it's CS and you see.
You just have to assume that you hopefully did damage until the round is over.
Yeah, oh...
I was gonna say.
Because, I mean, realistically, you wouldn't know if you shot them.
Yeah.
Like, if they're still moving.
Like, at the best, you could just hear the, like, gun sound.
Doki, Braid.
Oh, my God.
What a bug, Green.
Spray your prey.
Oh, no!
What?
I think he got, uh...
Headshot with the grenade.
Wait, how do you look at chat?
How do you type in chat?
Oh, um, T...
Oh, no, Y is for all chat, and then U is for team chat.
Oh, you don't have...
Wait, what?
It shows...
Oh, there you go.
Wait, I'm just talking to team.
Oh, I don't have a bug.
Where's my old chat?
Oh, there you go.
What about to be...
Alright,
I'm mid.
I'm doing it.
I know call-ups.
I'm gonna...
There you go.
I'm slowly walking in mid.
Oh!
Too slow.
He said she eyed.
Okay, I'll take it.
Yay!
I died, but yay!
All right.
Oh, I can't afford...
God, I can't spread it so...
We're gonna work on your...
Smoke mid.
All right.
Your mid-smoke.
Watch this.
Don't worry.
This time.
Watch this.
Are you gonna line it up?
There you go.
That's definitely...
I definitely smoked mid this time.
How are you doing that?
Are you...
I swear to God, it's definitely hit the ground, for sure.
I...
I don't know.
I swear to God, it hit the ground.
Oh, they're probably gonna push there, I think.
All right.
Oh my God, I'm scared.
Yeah, there's one over there.
You can handle them.
No.
Yeah, I think the last two people are on A, so we'll...
Or on B, so we'll just go A.
Yeah, I left.
I don't want to stand in front of them, I'm scared.
I'll get shot.
You can kill each other in this game.
Yeah, I feel like I'm gonna get friendly fired.
Let me make sure there's no lurkers.
Okay.
They're both here.
Oh, they're both here?
Yeah.
Don't worry, I'm coming over.
Get him, rush at them.
The P90, you can rush.
You can run at them.
I did it.
Oh, they got him.
I was...
My teammate took a bullet.
Thank you, teammate.
Oh my God, you're using the stand behind teammate.
Okay, this time.
This time, get the smoke.
Watch this.
Don't worry, guys.
You gotta hold...
Hold the mouse one with the smoke out.
Like, you're ready to throw it.
And then jump.
Okay.
Like, you're...
Press mouse one and then jump.
I did it.
No.
It's the same place!
No, no, no, I'm just saying.
Yeah, what...
Should I go on to the street?
What is she doing?
It's the same place, too.
I can't believe it.
I wonder...
Because there's a way to, like, do a half throw.
So I wonder if you're doing the half throw.
I could be.
Honestly, I don't know what I'm doing.
Oh, wait!
There's...
Oh, there's someone on the right.
Oh my God, pussy?
1v1 be like a real pro.
I think they came out of long doors, maybe.
Then we should put somebody there.
Yeah.
I can't believe it.
Oh, wait.
Chat says it's because...
You moved your mouse while throwing.
You have to keep your mouse, like, in the same spot.
Oh!
So there's, like, momentum shit?
Or, wait.
Actually, I don't know.
Is chat lying?
I'm not trying to explain it.
Hmm.
How do you...
Do you wiggle your mouse when you throw it?
I have no idea.
I...
I don't...
Think about what I'm actually doing in the moment.
Okay.
No, you're...
Yeah, yeah.
I think you can get in the next try.
I think the very first time I threw up a smoke during this round, I succeeded.
So I just need to do that again.
However it's done.
Okay.
Mm-hmm.
Alright.
It's all instinct, exactly, guys.
My instincts might be wrong, but, like, it's all instinct.
It's okay.
We...
You smell is carrying us.
Thank God.
Alright.
Thank you for the...
Thank you for the carry.
I feel like you...
You could probably be really good at this game if you learned it.
Yeah.
I...
Like, every time I try to learn Valorant, I just give up.
But, like...
That was more frustrating for me.
Because the rounds are...
Yeah, like...
Yeah, alright.
I got this.
Watch this.
Wait, wait, wait.
I didn't...
I swear to God, I didn't move.
Look, look, look.
I'm sorry, guys.
Okay, I'm looking.
Like, do you see how I have the grenade?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm looking.
Okay.
So I have it.
I'm ready to throw it.
Yeah.
And then I jump and I release.
Oh, so you jump and release.
And I guess I keep it lined up.
Yeah.
Okay, I get it.
But you press mouse one.
And then jump and then release.
Wait, guys, I swear to God, I'm not wiggling the mouse.
I swear to God.
My mouse is very still.
There's no way anybody's on B.
Y'all at A, right?
Probably not.
Oh my God, they're all dead.
They're all dead right now.
One's mid.
They're all dead.
Wait, are you going to go B?
Because I'm going to go A.
I'm at mid.
Okay, he's CT.
He's like underneath me.
That sounds weird.
Oh, don't worry.
I'm right behind him.
Okay, maybe worry a little bit.
Oh, no.
There's a guy right out there.
Wait, where is he?
I don't know comms.
He's up there to the left.
I don't know the comms.
Yeah, past there.
Yeah?
Oh, he's going to shoot.
To the right.
He could be up there.
Oh!
He lurked back there.
I should have taught you that call out.
That one's ramp.
It's, yeah.
It's like just a slanted hill thingy.
I see.
Okay, I got this.
Now I know how to smoke.
Oh, yeah.
I looked left when you said to the right.
Oh.
That's awesome.
Okay, this time.
No, no.
I think you looked to the...
I think you got it.
This time.
Okay.
Is that...
I don't have to say sad.
I don't know.
I don't know any...
Status report.
All right.
I'm not wasting money on smokes.
That's the status report.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
I'm not...
Who shot me?
I can't.
There were two of them.
Oh, there were two of them.
Oh, I'm supposed to not hold left button?
No.
You hold it, and then you jump, and then release while you...
Like, as you jump.
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna do it one more time, and then I'll tell you.
Okay, you do it first, and then...
Okay, okay.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm covering fire.
I'm covering fire on the roof.
There's no snipers on the roof.
Okay, so...
I guess I jump and release at pretty much the same time.
Okay.
There you go.
Oh, nice!
Oh, I did it!
I did it!
Wait, wait, I think I hit it!
I think I hit it!
It's not on the roof!
Oh, that's a bite gun.
It's not on the roof.
That's an old...
Oh, there's a guy pushing.
There's a guy pushing.
You didn't see me, right?
No.
But he might be watching the screen.
Oh, my God!
You see me!
Okay, I hit him.
I saw the blood splatter.
There was a blood splatter.
Yeah, so now you can see at the top, like, where you hit them.
Wait, where do you see that?
Like, does it say the damage at the top?
Uh, 61 in two.
It's like underneath their pictures.
Oh.
Okay, he shot me.
He shot five bullets, guys.
I shot two.
Well, you shot more than that.
No, no, no, I shot two.
Okay, I'll buy a flashbang.
Okay.
I guess we're gonna push, yeah, rush D.
Alright, I have a D go.
And a flashbang.
They're gonna push here.
Close, probably lower tens if you wanna watch it.
Alright, I'll watch lower tens.
Shoot from above.
Oh, they might have heard that.
Oh, shit!
Oh, nice.
Whoa, nice.
The one D.
Don't die!
He had an AWP!
He had no scope.
That's not fair!
Okay, that guy had...
Yeah, yeah, that's...
I don't even know which one was... was him.
Yeah.
Yeah, I was reloading.
I got out...
I think it's this guy.
Oh, my God!
Kill him and give me his AWP!
Oh, no, he's saving his AWP!
Usually they try to save.
Fuckin' that pussy!
Yeah, I...
I think he's probably in T spawn or something.
Oh, my God.
That's it.
I'm too broke to buy an AWP.
Wait, maybe?
Here, I can buy you one.
I can buy you one.
Please.
You can pick it up from the buy menu if you press...
Oh.
It should be at the bottom.
Yeah, I got it.
Alright.
Don't worry, guys.
I know how to smoke now.
I got it.
I got a success only one time.
And that's all I need.
Look at that!
I...
No, um...
Don't look at it.
Don't look at it!
Don't look.
Anybody in mid?
Or...
B-site?
Oh, we can do long, I think.
Oh, no, then.
So usually...
Wait, where are you?
Oh, I'm back here.
Oh, you smoked me.
Poked up above the top.
Anyone mid?
Oh, I did it!
Oh!
I didn't shoot my gun!
Yay!
I did it, guys!
I didn't shoot my gun!
I...
Alright, so here...
You can pretty much smoke, like, any of the entry points.
And that'll help a lot, because the smokes last...
Oh, okay.
Wait.
Yeah, so there's no...
There's no trick smokes, really, for here.
Didn't we win?
Why are we here?
Oh, we switched sides.
Oh!
I didn't even realize we didn't play the other side.
I didn't even notice that.
Yeah, it is kind of confusing.
Now you have to shoot, uh...
People who are your teammates.
Okay.
Like, on T-side.
Don't worry, I'm looking at mid.
Oh, their cat?
What?
Oh, I know where cat is.
Which means they're probably...
They're probably gonna go A.
There's still one more.
Oh, wait.
There's only one, so...
Wait, that guy had the bomb.
Yeah, if the bomb is...
Is on the floor, then we just stay by the bomb.
Yeah.
I think he...
Yeah, you know that from Valorant and stuff.
Yeah.
From tactical shooters.
Wait, where did he die?
On cat.
It's like lower cat.
Oh, here, I'll show you this way to get up to cat if you want.
Yeah?
Okay.
You can jump on these boxes.
Uh-huh.
Oh!
Oh shit, he's here.
Oh my god.
Get him!
That's right.
Oh.
That's not right.
That's not...
I didn't realize our teammates died.
Alright.
Follow me.
I'll show you.
Um...
I was like, wait a minute.
How did these guys push up mid?
We had two people there.
I was so confused.
Alright.
Did you...
Buy armor?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
So you just...
You can crouch jump or regular jump.
Yeah.
And then...
There you go.
And then you can...
Some people will like, stand here and hold.
Uh-huh.
Cause they're gonna push from mid into cat.
Uh, which they might do.
Alright.
Cause they gotta...
They just gotta pick mid.
But they might go B also.
Oh, they got two picks too.
They gotta pick B.
Yeah.
Okay.
Nice.
I had enough fun.
Oh no!
I didn't realize the second guy was there.
Oh, there was a guy.
Another guy?
Oh.
Yeah, there was two guys.
I'm catching up.
I was like, I had enough fun.
And then I walked away.
Yeah, usually...
Do you have a BGM playing or anything?
Oh, no.
No.
Okay, that's good.
Yeah, cause sometimes...
Like, you can hear their footsteps.
Yeah.
I have to...
I don't know the sounds as well.
It's pretty quiet.
As well, so like...
It's harder to hear, for instance, I can't...
You know like when you play a game so much, you can instantly...
Um...
Recognize the sounds.
But it's just by instinct and stuff.
So for me, I haven't...
Yeah, I know what you mean, yeah.
Yeah.
I haven't picked up on it yet.
Yeah, in this game, the CTs, like your teammates have pretty quiet footsteps.
Like whoever's your teammate.
Yeah.
And then the enemy team's...
It's gonna be way louder.
They're mid.
They pushed up mid.
They're mid?
Okay.
And then...
They're going B.
Okay.
Oh, they're planning.
You think I could just be here?
Oh!
I think they heard me.
Um...
I think...
Oh shoot.
We've died at the same time.
Yeah.
They definitely heard me.
Is there like quiet jumping or...
I don't think so.
Chat, is there quiet jumping?
No, I don't think so.
I just...
I fall...
Fall down and I wouldn't...
I go like...
Splat.
And then I was like, okay.
Thank you.
I mean...
Yeah.
I can't...
I can't be sneaky.
I don't know how to be sneaky, guys.
Yeah, I can't jump down...
Quietly.
I don't think there's anybody pushing...
Oh, one's pushing cat.
He's pushing you right now.
Don't worry.
I got this.
I didn't get this.
On.
Okay.
It's just one guy.
Thing.
Right?
Or was...
What the hell?
Where did he come from?
I didn't...
That's the guy that killed me.
It's him.
Alright, we won the round.
Yeah, we did it, guys.
Only the two of us died.
Yeah.
We're...
We're contributing, guys.
Oh.
It's not fair.
He's running while...
Yeah, without a sacrifice, they wouldn't have known the location.
Exactly.
We were...
We're tactical bait.
For our team.
That's it.
I'm running forward.
Mm-hmm.
That's it.
Oh.
I'm running.
You have an expensive gun, you better not lose it.
I'm gonna lose it.
You're gonna ruin our economy.
Pick up my gun...
Pick up my gun after I die.
Okay.
Alright, I'll do that.
Yeah, stand behind me.
One long.
There we go.
Oh, I have the bomb.
Oh, they're gonna...
They're gonna come up from...
Okay, I...
They're gonna come up from your left side.
There...
There's two of them.
I had two of them on me.
I did my job.
You...
For your crosshair...
If you see, like, any of our teammates' crosshairs...
Um...
You can always copy them.
They're so tiny.
Oh, yeah, okay.
Oh, so it's just like...
Yeah.
They're so tiny.
Look how tiny they're crosshairs.
Unless you like yours.
Yeah, you probably know how you like yours.
I don't know.
I just did a random crosshair.
Cute.
I got my one.
Yeah.
I, uh...
I recently copied mine.
And then when I'm in a lobby with other people...
Or, like, uh...
On a regular game...
Yeah.
People will copy my crosshair.
Cause it's...
It's like a T crosshair.
Uh-huh.
Uh, so...
It's missing, like, the fourth one at the very top.
Oh.
Cause, like, you can put...
You can put their heads on a platter.
And then shoot.
I see.
Okay.
I don't know.
Maybe it'd be weird.
Uh-huh.
Okay.
I'm just testing out the gun.
I have the MP5.
I don't know if that's a good gun.
Yeah.
People will really hate that gun.
Oh.
It's all I could afford.
No, cause they're like, That's the worst gun in the game.
Aww.
No, I like it though.
I like it.
Okay.
I'm gonna go die, I guess.
They're pushing mid, so you could probably push...
You can push Pat down.
Okay.
I hit him.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well, my excuse was that I didn't know I had one of the worst guns.
Oh, shit.
They're B, aren't they?
I believe in you.
Yeah, they are.
No.
I'm so lit.
It's so over.
It's okay.
I'm just gonna push this way.
Just nade yourself.
Yeah.
Nade myself?
Die on your own terms.
Yeah.
I should've done that.
Oh, wait.
I'm not bottom...
Oh, I am bottom frag.
Wait.
How am I higher?
Why am I not bottom frag?
Oh, um, so it goes by damage done.
Oh.
Instead of kills.
Oh, I see.
Yeah.
Okay, what gun...
You used to get points, like, if you could plant the bomb, so...
Yeah?
I wouldn't be getting kills, but I'd be planting the bomb.
Oh, okay.
So I'd be, like, towards the top.
Oh, that's...
Oh, yeah, they changed it.
Oh, the guy doesn't trust me on mid anymore.
That's a good idea.
That's a good choice.
Mr. Nova.
You shouldn't trust me.
Yeah, they smoked mid, so I think they're gonna go cat.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna use Nova as bait.
Oh.
Okay.
Nevermind.
Oh, shoot.
Are they pushing you there?
I don't know.
Oh, they're long.
They're long.
Behind you.
I got one of them.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I don't know this guy.
If you want to back up.
You don't have to peek him.
Okay.
Yeah, he might go around long on the other side since that's where he came from originally.
But yeah, you watch that and then the teammate, he's gonna watch the other side.
Okay.
There's also better guns on the floor.
There's an AWP and an AK.
Or just an AK.
Oh my god.
I'm scared.
I'm so...
He's here.
You got him.
I'm so scared to look behind.
One more.
This guy could come from tunnels, so orange might die, but...
Maybe not.
Oh my god!
No!
I quit!
Oh!
I didn't realize our guy was gonna die there!
No!
Yeah.
I trusted him!
You both had AWP and you were both watching like different angles.
Yeah.
Oh my god!
And he came from tunnels, I'm pretty sure.
So, it's like he left one side wide open.
I can't believe he was also AWPing.
I was like, don't worry, I got us.
I can't believe it.
There's one long.
Okay.
I'm looking at Kat.
Wait, mid.
Sorry.
Wait.
There's two pushing long.
It's bomb two.
Oh no, I'm scared.
There's someone in mid though.
Your teammate's in mid, so I think it should be okay.
That's unlucky.
That was a nice try though.
That was two people.
Not bottom frag!
Let's go!
Wait, is this?
Me too!
For now.
Is this T-sided?
People always say that most maps are T-sided.
So I think it is T-sided.
Yeah.
Oh.
It's easier to like, push with five people in one spot.
I see.
When CT's are all spread out.
Oh my god, that guy.
Oh nice!
That was a good head shot.
Don't die here.
Oh!
Lucky clutch!
Clutch or kick!
He clutched it!
Nice.
That was actually a good, good shot.
Wait, did we win?
Oh wait, no.
Ah!
Okay, you know what?
I've been transferred.
I...
I believe in the P-20.
Those guys were so good.
That guy was so good in P-20.
I think I can replicate it.
Grab your gear, let's go.
I can replicate it.
I'll be him.
Wait, wait.
Where are you gonna go with that?
You're gonna go cat?
Yeah, I'll be like him.
And now I just rush through, right?
Okay.
I just run?
With the P-20?
What?
Yeah, you just run with P-20.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll cover you, I'll cover you.
I have no HP.
That's right, I'm running.
Okay, we're both bad.
We're both bad.
Oh, yay!
Nice, you just need one more round to win.
And then we're...
I did...
83.
Okay, I did 83.
83 damage there.
Okay, it's just...
Alright.
I think I found my gun.
I...
I remember I used the P-20 in...
in T-T-T.
I...
T-T...
Yeah, in Trouble in Terroristown.
The P-P-90 was always my go-to gun.
It's just like T-T-T.
I like that one.
Pretty much.
Oh, I think they're going B.
I think they did a B-Rush.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'll walk all the way behind them.
You won't know.
No way!
There's one guy sitting car.
Oh.
Oh my god, I hope everybody lives.
Oh, you pull out your knife.
Uh...
Yeah, I'll go faster, but I'm scared too.
No!
It's a 1v1.
No.
I'll let you focus.
No way.
Yeah.
They didn't plan though.
I think they're bad too.
I hear them.
Wait, what?!
That's...
They were playing weird.
Is that the person who wanted you to shout them out?
No!
Yeah, it wasn't.
Wait, I...
Oh my god.
I hit 80?!
Awww!
Awww.
I have to aim higher.
Okay, maybe P90's not my gun.
But it's a...
It's really normal for...
for it to be like...
crosshair placement.
A lot of times for new players, it's like pretty bad.
You have to constantly try to keep your crosshair head level.
Awww.
Even for the P90?
Yeah.
Awww.
Okay, yeah.
It was just spring.
Every gun you wanna start out shooting at the head, and then...
they're all long.
Oh.
And then you drag down, usually, for the recoil.
Wait, is there no one cat?
There's two over here.
Goose.
There's one in Goose.
Oh!
Oh, I see.
I see.
Wait, people are saying I should try the...
to follow recoil.
Toots.
Oh my god.
Oh, yeah.
It's not terrible.
I...
I kind of like it.
Oh, yeah.
I'll try it.
Don't worry.
Oh, I don't...
I don't have P90.
I'm broke.
I've just been...
I have not been paying attention to my economy.
It happens.
Alright, I have the...
We have to win this one.
So, try not to peak like...
crazy angles.
Okay.
I'll play more safe.
Hello.
Grenade.
I don't know where to play.
They might be pushing mid.
They're pushing mid.
Oh.
Okay.
I got one.
Grenade out.
Alright, one's lit going up to B.
They're going B.
Oh.
Looks like.
Nobody here.
I want to see this guy.
Why would that guy?
Yeah, I think...
Oh, we have...
You have bomb.
It's underneath cat right now.
So...
Oh.
Where you are now, they might...
They might go that way.
But like, where the tunnel is...
Here?
Oh, we did it!
We did it!
Yay!
Woo!
Oh my god!
Wait!
What did I get?
Most time alive!
Let's go!
That's good!
Oh my god!
Let's go!
I've been alive for so long!
Not bottom frag!
Let's go!
You know, technically...
Wait a second.
I'm...
Shoot!
Yeah!
Like one kill away.
My KDA is so bad.
Yeah, mine too.
I have 19 deaths.
Here in this game, I think it's ADR?
ADR?
What does ADR stands for?
Assist, death, and...
What the fuck is R?
Assist, death, ratio maybe?
Assist...
Oh!
Okay, so it's just...
Assist and death.
Instead of like K, it kills and death.
Poor...
No, he has...
Oh!
Average damage per round.
Okay, that makes more sense.
Yay!
My average damage was not that bad.
Do you wanna play another one?
Let's do another one.
Do you wanna switch now?
Yeah, that was fun.
Let's do another one.
That was fun.
Yeah, it's kind of addictive.
Especially if you...
If you're like in a 1v1 and you get the clutch.
Yeah.
Yeah, the clutch or kick.
We also had...
Our top fragger had like 31 plus kills.
I think he carried us.
Sorry.
Yeah, yeah.
We did get carried a little bit.
But it's good.
It's nice.
Yeah, yeah.
Look, we're...
You know, it gives you some time to learn.
It's nice to get carried sometimes, guys.
I'm tired of trying to carry.
I wanna be in the backpack, guys.
I...
Sometimes I just wanna sit in a backpack and like chill.
And just be like, yippee.
Is...
Is your...
Is your mouse...
Like sensitivity okay in this game?
Oh, yeah.
Maybe it's too fast or anything like that?
No, I converted it.
I converted it.
Okay.
Oh.
Nice.
I think for me it's...
I think for me it's just...
I need to remember not to move when I'm shooting.
Cause like...
I'm a movement shooter.
But...
Not even.
So there is movement shooting in this.
But it's...
It's counter scraping.
Counter scraping.
Heard of that phrase but I don't know what it actually means.
I...
I think it's like...
If you...
If you're say moving right.
And you shoot.
Then you need to step left.
To like...
Counter.
Oh.
Okay.
The movement of you plus the gun.
Oh my god.
I'm pretty sure.
Check.
Correct me if...
I'm wrong.
I don't...
I don't do it cause uh...
I never really learned.
Oh nice.
Did I kill that guy?
Oh yeah.
It was me.
Oh they said it's like apex.
It is.
Do you counter strafe an apex?
Oh I do.
But it's like instinct.
I don't really like...
Think of like...
Oh.
I don't think about it.
I just know like...
My shots actually hit.
When I do it.
Oh.
Um...
It...
As I say.
If you're moving to the right.
Then hold the left.
For like a second while you shoot.
I guess.
Okay.
I just...
That's if you're moving though.
A lot of my time when I'm playing.
I don't really think how I play.
It's more so like just...
Clearly like muscle memory for me.
Yeah.
Cause like...
Okay.
I...
Watch your smoke.
One day I'll be...
I need to push lower tons.
One day I'll be able to do that.
Actually I just learned the smoke today.
So I could teach you.
Did you just let other people smoke for you?
Uh...
Yeah.
I usually use my smoke um...
On long.
If I'm pushing long.
Because uh...
Yeah.
That one's much easier.
Alright.
I'm going cat.
They saw the bomb.
Wait where?
They saw...
They saw us going A.
So they're probably...
You guys will be fine right?
Yeah.
We're going...
We're still going A.
Yeah.
I'm going to plant...
Oh you have the bomb.
Okay.
I was going to say who has the bomb.
Oh.
So he's in CT.
One's in CT.
Um...
You could just watch cat if you would stand here.
Oh my god.
I hit him.
I...
Oh shit.
He jumped.
He's going to push ramp.
He...
I didn't expect him to jump.
We did it.
Oh.
Woo.
I get your deagle.
Nice.
I didn't expect him to also jump.
I was like...
He's not going to do that.
There's no way.
Yeah.
I think with like the guns that you like...
Like the SMGs and stuff.
You can jump and shoot and kind of hit it.
Oh and shotguns.
Oh.
And shotguns.
With like other guns.
Yeah.
You can't really...
Alright.
I shouldn't...
Oh wait.
I should like use my knife.
More.
I'm too paranoid.
Freeze for a second.
I'm so paranoid.
Alright.
I'm going to go through cat.
I'm just going to run it.
Oh.
What?
What's that?
Um.
There's somebody behind uh...
In mid.
Oh.
Nice.
Oh shit.
Haha.
Don't worry.
I'm going to run and gun it.
I'm going to go on sight.
Haha.
Oh nice.
Okay.
I'm going to plant for real.
I'm looking at cat.
Oh, it's just the two of us.
Oh.
No, it's three.
Three.
Okay.
Where's the other two?
Um.
One's in CT spawn.
Oh, one's long.
Oh, okay.
So nobody's here.
Dammit.
No.
They're underneath and um...
That's right.
Pushing up onto A site right now from long.
Oh.
Okay.
I should come back.
Your teammate.
You're going to have to rush.
Oh shit.
They might try to defuse.
Oh my god.
I didn't...
I think they're defusing right now.
Oh no.
We're going to push him.
Uh oh.
You almost had it.
No.
It's okay.
I got the killer.
Nice try.
I didn't think we'd done that.
I was gonna do a long walk behind.
I'll be like, don't ever expect a long plank.
Alright.
I'm slowly walking up.
I don't think I can shoot past that.
Alright.
I believe in you.
You can... I'll use USB.
Okay.
Oh, never mind.
Anybody going mid?
No?
One's car.
Oh!
I didn't...
I didn't look right.
He's waiting for you!
I know!
That pussy!
It's okay.
All he got was a P90.
I didn't spend money.
Oh, shit.
That was a good flash.
He cheated.
I know.
He can't.
No.
Fight me like a real play.
Oh!
What?
What the fuck ass shot was that?
Huh?
You saw that?
He just like, randomly flicked.
Oh.
Maybe he is cheating then.
That was such a weird... Yeah, that...
...prefile was fucking weird.
Okay.
Yeah, that...
That's what...
I think with this game, if you don't have...
Prime?
Chat correct me if I'm wrong, but you need Prime to...
...not...
...get cued with cheaters as often.
Oh.
Which...
Yeah, because I think...
I don't know.
Is that a thing anymore?
I have no idea.
It used to be like...
Counter-Strike was free, and then...
...you could, uh...
...you could buy Prime.
Wait, what?
Oh, it's like, pay to win.
No, no, not really.
It's like, pay for a...
What is it called?
The Valorant has like, the...
...cheat thing?
It's like...
...cheat guard, riot guard.
Riot guard?
Yeah.
Don't worry, buddy.
I'm gonna use you to play.
Man, alright, this guy's good.
I'm following him.
Oh my god, he killed everybody.
Last guy is on A.
He's cat.
Oh, yeah.
He's still...
He's just sitting there.
I'll just wait until my team's here...
...and then use them as bait.
Yay!
Alright.
We should do a...
...a B rush.
A B rush?
Alright, I'm right behind you.
I'm there, all the way.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
I have an A spawn, so...
I'll make them think that we're going A, but then you guys go B.
Okay.
I'll wait for you.
Everyone's going A.
I don't think our teammates are going A.
I can't.
Okay, but when we both...
We baited them and baited our teammates.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But when we start going B...
We're gonna like...
Don't worry, I believe in us.
We'll walk, we'll be sneaky.
Alright, I'm right behind you.
I'm gonna wait for the smoke and tunnels.
And then we'll push.
So if you want to watch...
Well, I don't think in lower tunnels anybody's gonna push.
I'll wait, just in case.
I'll look.
There's one guy close here.
I'm looking at lower tunnels.
I got...
Oh!
Don't worry, he doesn't know I'm here.
They don't know, they don't know.
You don't know.
You have the bomb, so you should go with our teammates.
Oh wait, I have the bomb?
Oh shit!
Yeah.
I didn't know!
I thought I threw it away!
Clearly I didn't!
There's one guy, Cat, I think.
I thought I heard one.
You scared the shit out of me.
Oh my god, I'm down.
Okay, look.
I...
I did throw the bomb away.
I remember pressing 5 and G.
Yeah.
Maybe somebody else threw it to you.
Yeah, I think some...
I think someone threw it back to me.
Are these guys cleaning up?
It's okay.
We're gonna get carried.
I believe.
Okay, I...
I stopped believing.
I...
No, we're still really early in the round.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
I won.
Okay, I won't...
Alright.
Let's rush B.
Just us two.
I don't have the bomb, so I can't throw.
Okay.
Oh yeah, I wanted to ask you.
Your birthday's coming up soon.
Yeah!
Isn't it?
Is it?
Oh, I think it's because I shot him.
I got...
I got shanked.
I...
He stabbed you!
I did shoot him.
It's like...
Alright, so I have like 39 HP now, so...
Wait, what?
The fuck where did he get shot by?
There's a guy that pushed there in the doors.
In the doors?
Oh.
He's waiting for us.
Yeah.
Actually, he...
Wait?
He might have gone back.
Oh, okay.
Um, I'm gonna push...
I'm gonna flash him long, so this is like...
Long flash.
Okay.
Um...
I'm gonna walk up and die.
Do you want a gun?
Do you have a gun?
Yeah, I have a gun.
I have an AK, but I'm still...
I think I'm gonna die here.
Now you'll get him.
Where is he?
Which...
I almost yelled at chat.
Chat?
Why did you tell me?
There's one guy mid...
And then I...
Think there might be one guy on A.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Guys!
He was literally standing up there, crouched, looking down.
I was like, what are you doing down there?
Right here.
Nice.
You could've snuck up behind him and stabbed him.
That's so true.
I could've done that.
It was too far.
It was such a long walk.
We spawned.
Yeah.
We spawned right next to each other.
Yay!
Alright, now we rush B.
Oh, here, look.
Yeah?
Oh, look, look.
Jump on my head.
Oh my god, we're gonna do a boost.
And then you take me over to this box.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, okay.
I wanna be tall.
Oh, no, it doesn't work.
Oh, I don't think you can get up there, actually.
Oh, oh, our team's dead.
Nah, it's just one guy.
Yeah, that...
No, two guys, isn't it?
That guy didn't matter, anyway.
Uh, okay, now it's two guys.
He didn't matter.
I'm gonna push this, even though he just died.
Here.
I'll push the other way.
Sure, I'm not gonna get op'd, right?
Okay.
Oh, I'm in cat.
Oh!
Okay, I was in cat.
Alright, I guess it's up to me and orange.
I believe in you.
You got this.
Oh!
Okay, that was a good shot by him.
Oh, wait.
Oh, oh, that's his second kill.
He's got this.
Oh.
Ah!
It's okay.
I believe in the AWPer.
It's a 1v2.
Yeah.
Holy shit.
That's an interesting shot.
Oh!
It's alright.
It's...
You know, it's okay.
He was AWPing.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Well, the enemy team has an AWP now, so...
Oh.
I'm not going mid.
Yeah, don't peek yet.
Don't peek yet.
Or long.
I guess we could try going...
B.
Oh, I got a bye.
Oh, you forgot to battle.
Wait, who...
No, somebody gave me a gun.
Oh, nice.
I'll follow you.
Okay.
Alright, I got the bomb.
Okay, we're gonna try to...
Oh.
They're AWPing on B.
Um...
Do we...
I'm rotating.
I'm gonna rotate.
Wait, it's just us two.
Uh...
Okay, let's just die, I guess.
Where was he?
Oh, we had somebody disconnect.
Oh, he's us.
You're right.
I try.
That was...
That was the left.
Yeah.
Well, there were two guys.
There were two guys there.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
There were two guys.
It wasn't our fault.
Two was more than one.
I'm gonna do full save.
Oh.
I bought a gun.
Yeah.
Oh.
Yeah, somebody on our team left.
But I don't know.
Do we not get it?
I guess they're gone, gone.
So they can't...
I guess they're mad.
Come back.
Wait, no.
Aren't they back?
Oh, they're...
They're not.
Wait, that guy was our second best player.
Okay.
No.
I'm not sure.
Yeah, I believe.
Alright.
We got it.
We got this.
We can definitely...
Wait, who has the bomb?
Door and window.
Oh.
And surrender.
Wait, but we can't...
What'd you say?
Nothing.
Oh.
This happens a lot with games.
Like somebody will disconnect.
And then you're just stuck the whole time without...
Oh, cause it's just a...
An extra person.
I'm surprised they...
In the past they would put in a bot.
But I guess like people just...
Uh...
Abuse the...
Just farm the bot.
Right?
I'm not sure.
Yeah, they used to...
There used to be a bot.
And you could like control it.
Yeah, yeah.
What happened to that guy?
I guess they just got rid of it.
They're like, no.
I don't know.
And what happened to him?
Did he retire?
Did he graduate?
Yeah, the bot retired.
The bot graduated.
Oh my god.
We missed this graduation stream.
So sad.
Oh my god.
My Oshi.
Graduated.
In CS.
Oh.
He's right there.
I see him.
Is that goose?
Oh my god.
No.
Where am I?
If you don't have...
Oh.
He's close.
Oh my god.
He flashed.
Where's the bomb?
Oh, I have bomb.
I...
Oh.
They're both there.
Oh no.
The last two guys.
Yeah.
I didn't realize I had bomb.
I think I had it and then you stepped over and picked it up.
Oh.
After I died and dropped it.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
I was like, what the fuck?
Why do I have it?
Because I always check if I have bomb before I go anywhere.
Orange.
No.
Now you're gonna give him another op.
Oh no.
There's so many ops.
We have a lot of money.
That's true.
Oh, I can buy an op.
Let's...
That's right.
It's my turn.
Are you gonna peak suicide?
Yes.
We're having...
We're gonna have an op 1v1.
Okay, I'm gonna flash it first.
We'll have an op 1v1.
Hopefully I didn't flash it.
I think I might die first, though.
Oh.
No, we...
They pushed up.
Okay.
Yeah, I was gonna say, what the fuck?
I was not expecting that.
You...
You got the guy who pushed up?
Yeah, yeah.
There's no, no, no, no.
Not the guy mid.
Yeah.
Oh.
Nice.
Okay, they didn't.
Okay.
Okay, now we got both of them.
I feel like we should probably go...
I'm gonna go B.
Okay.
I'll still look at mid.
Making sure nobody cross.
Nobody's crossing.
I'm gonna get stabbed in the back, aren't I?
Okay.
Wait, where was he?
No!
Shoot, he had a P90.
Fuck.
Where was he?
Um, lower ten...
Or, upper tens.
Where's that?
The last guy's in the tunnels.
Like, to the left.
Um, it's where your teammate is right now.
Okay.
I dropped my AWP for this.
Oh, yay!
Oh, you got it!
Yay!
We did it!
Alright.
Back to the AWP.
This is our last round before we switch.
Oh my god.
I think there's a guy that's carrying us, but I'm not sure yet.
I think.
Wait, I think you're carrying yourself.
Let's go!
One of us will hit the shot.
Oh, shit.
Okay, that's way too many AWPs.
Alright, don't worry.
I'm right behind your AWP.
Where is he?
Oh, okay.
Let me get the bomb then.
Hold on.
Um...
I think there is one there, but he probably pushed up back towards site.
Cause he smoked off.
Oh, okay.
He killed our other AWPer.
Um, Pit is a good place to AWP.
Where's Pit?
Oh no.
So, you wanna come over here and then try to jump in.
Alright, I'm...
There's one on site.
Oh, I see him.
Wait, oh my...
Okay.
You got him, nice.
I did it.
Oh, there's another one there.
It's an AWPer.
Where, where, where, where, where?
Up top?
They're gonna be pushing up behind you.
Okay.
Yeah, he's on site.
Oh no!
He flashed me!
My weakness!
No!
Oh, I got him though!
I got him!
It's okay!
I took one...
Yeah, I took one down with me.
That's right.
Are you gonna get skins now that you've played?
Oh no, I...
Now that you're good at this game.
I never buy skins.
I had a really bad, like...
Wait, you could gamble.
Oh, and it's legal in Canada, too.
You know, like, people, like, move to Canada just to gamble.
What?
Really?
Yeah, you didn't know that?
No, it's true.
No, I didn't know that.
Yeah, legally.
So you see, like, gambling streams?
Like, that's because they're Canadian.
They're B.
Okay, I'm coming over.
Oh, they're coming!
There's another guy!
There's two!
There's two coming!
They're rushing you!
Oh, my God!
It was, like, three people rushing me.
I actually made some catching up.
Yeah.
Oh, I forgot!
There was, like...
You should've expected the B rush.
Yeah.
Rush B.
Oh, shit!
Wait, he got a kill!
Oh!
Oh, this guy!
Oh, wait, what was he doing?
Oh, hey!
Is he, like, inspecting his gun?
While shooting?
It's okay.
They're only winning...
This one might be gloss.
No...
I...
We got this...
We definitely got this...
You wanna rush...
You rush them?
Okay, yeah.
Follow you.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
The only...
Oh, God!
The only skins I actually buy with my own money is Fortnite skins.
Oh, what?
Oh!
Wait, Fortnite...
Yeah, well, Fortnite skins are...
To be fair...
Kind of an investment.
Yeah, yeah.
They disappear.
That's true.
And they're actually good.
Did you see all the...
The...
Father's Day...
Father's Day skins?
That they did?
With King of the Hill...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And Cleveland?
Yeah, I thought...
I thought they were gonna...
Put, like, more King of the Hill skins or something.
But I guess they're just doing it, like...
I think it's just...
I think it's, like, nice things.
Yeah, like at different shows.
Yeah.
I heard the reason why...
Homer...
Homer wasn't in it...
Was because they're planning on doing, like, a Simpsons themed...
Uh...
Fortnite event.
With, like...
Where you can, like...
Where you can, like, invade Springfield.
Oh, okay.
Oh, that was interesting.
I feel like there aren't that many playable...
Simpsons characters.
I...
I think you're just gonna play the family.
I assume you don't play...
I assume they won't add the children.
Cause then they'll be like...
The baby is the baby.
Yeah.
Cause you don't wanna shoot the kids.
Like...
Alright, don't worry.
Oh, yeah, that too.
Yeah, I was gonna say...
I don't think they wanna put children...
In Fortnite.
They're long, they're long, they're long.
Oh my god!
Too busy thinking about the Simpsons.
Ah!
I thought we voted to...
I voted to surrender.
Yeah, I voted too.
Someone...
Someone didn't wanna leave.
Who wants to...
Someone's trying to stat pat.
Oh, my Oshi.
Doki bird's in my lobby.
I don't wanna click the game yet.
Nyah!
Oh my god!
We're never gonna see her again!
We're never gonna see her!
Doki and Doobie!
D&D!
Hold on, I'm rubbing my eye.
I got really itchy all of a sudden.
Oh no.
Clutch or kick?
Okay.
Yes.
Who's voting?
No.
Oh, it's passed.
Nice.
Yay!
We're freed!
We're free!
Oh my god!
Clutch king!
Nice.
I don't know what I did.
But I got it.
Did I...
That's the 11%...
Did I say 11% accuracy?
Yeah.
Oh, I didn't see.
Oh.
Wait, what do I...
Oh, I got...
Oh, I'm gonna get a case.
I'll buy the case.
Whoa!
You can totally open it for $2.50!
Hey guys!
If only I had $2.50...
If only I had $2.50?
Okay.
Right now!
If only...
Aw, man!
If only Doobie and I both have $2.50 right now!
Oh, me too!
And then...
I only think it was a win!
If only the super chats were open!
If only...
Oh wait, how much are memberships again?
Someone...
Oh, so we're gonna play, um...
Oh, so we're gonna play wingman.
It's like 2v2.
Oh!
Okay, that sounds fun.
Someone gave me 2.49.
Oh, thank you guys!
For the super chats, guys!
What?!
Okay, I...
Maybe I should buy a key.
Wait, how do I buy keys?
Oh, if you do, just...
Just hide your screen.
Because it does like the Steam thing where it shows like your information.
Oh!
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't want that.
Identity theft is not a joke, guys.
I...
Wait, what the...
Is it the recoil case?
Unlock container.
Wait, it's 3...
Oh, wait.
3.39?
Oh, it's Canadian.
Okay.
I was gonna say...
Oh, yeah.
Sorry.
I was like, oh my god, I can't believe it.
It's okay.
It's Canadian.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
Got...
Wait, let me open my case first.
Alright.
Oh, okay.
Take your time.
Authorized.
I'm not gonna accept it so I can open my case.
Alright.
Uh...
Don't worry, guys.
Yeah, you just buy the key and then close it.
Uh-huh.
The screen and then...
I got it.
Then you can unlock after.
Yeah.
Okay.
Open to keep.
Wait, rent?
Oh, keep one weapon?
You know.
Okay.
Yeah.
Open to keep.
Alright, what do I get?
What did I get?
Oh.
Wow!
Oh, it's a blue.
Hello!
It's a FAMAS.
The Meow36.
It's...
Wow!
Is it a cat skin?
No.
Wait, no.
There's a fish on it.
Where the fuck is the cat part?
It just has a fish on it.
Maybe because you're the cat and you're holding the fish.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
Still kitty time.
Yeah, I was gonna say, where the fuck's the cat?
It's just...
Cats aren't green.
Doesn't that make you wanna open 50 more cases?
I'll open 50 if you open 50.
Maybe next time.
I opened a bunch of cases recently and I didn't get shit.
Wait, what was the best you got?
I think there was like an M4 skin.
What color was it?
Like purple?
Pink?
Red?
Blue?
Hold on, I gotta check.
It'll show up in my inventory.
Oh, I have the five-year veteran coin.
No, actually...
I just got a sawed-off shotgun skin.
Oh, yeah.
The stat track M4A4.
It was a purple.
Oh!
Oh, that's like almost a red.
Wait, I have the 10-year veteran coin.
Oh my God.
What?
Nice.
I literally played CSGO like one time ten years ago.
That's all it takes.
I got the 10-year coin.
Yeah.
And I got the Halo Master Chief Collection music kit, guys.
Alright.
I'm ready.
Oh, we're still searching.
I'm a 10-year vet.
Yeah, we had a game, but then...
Oh, the...
Yeah, and then somebody...
Not me.
Somebody.
Gambling.
Gambling legally.
There was a...
There was a streamer.
Yeah?
There was a streamer and they spent like a hundred thousand dollars in it.
Cases to...
What?
Open up like that amount worth of cases on stream.
Jesus Christ.
And they only made back like...
I think 10% of how much they spent.
What the fuck?
Because they got two knives.
Oh, two knives.
Yeah, I mean...
Yeah.
There's no way like...
I know like the most expensive knife isn't even close to 100k.
That's crazy.
I hear like knives are like...
Yeah.
I hear like knives are a good way to money launder too.
Wait, did you hear about that?
I...
But...
No.
But who's gonna buy the knives?
I don't like...
It's just like a way to launder money.
So like they...
They like sell the knife for really, really expensive.
It's like art galleries.
Sometimes people like do money launder.
Right.
Allegedly.
Sorry.
Allegedly in Minecraft.
Allegedly.
We don't know.
Yeah.
I read this off of Twitter.
So it can't be true, guys.
Uh...
Ow.
No way.
It's true, guys.
You can form your own opinions on whether or not that's true.
Alright.
First half.
Oh, we're terrorists.
Nice.
Alright, so...
This is pretty much what we were playing.
Yeah.
Okay.
This is a different map.
This is a classic.
Everybody loves this map.
Alright.
I got my Desert Eagle.
And uh...
There's only one site.
Oh no.
Okay.
Yeah, there's only one site.
But there's like multiple entry points.
Okay.
Let's hope they're bad.
There's...
Uh...
A door there.
There's a vent.
Here.
They can come out of.
Oh, there's so many places.
I'm a little scared.
Yeah.
But I...
I'll just follow you.
I actually don't know where they spawn here.
So I...
And so this is squeaky.
There it goes.
Oh.
Yeah, it goes squeak.
Squeak.
Squeaky.
Bye bye.
Oh, there's one.
I saw one guy.
Where was he?
Oh.
Um, so one is on site and one is like really close on site.
Wait, where am I going?
So if you go out that way, there's a window.
Go up the stairs and there's gonna be a glass window.
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
And he's like right outside the glass window.
That's where he was at least.
I didn't know where I am.
Hi.
No.
That's my...
Okay, there's a guy right here.
Right here.
Sorry.
I saw...
I didn't see your name.
I didn't see the name on top of your head.
I thought that was an enemy.
I...
That's why I said hi.
Who
could that be?
Hey, I hit you.
That was your name right there.
I hit you.
Yeah.
If only you were the enemy.
Got it.
There's a scale.
There's...
They're pushing.
Don't worry, I'm right here.
I'll try not to shoot you this time.
A lot of footsteps.
I think they're on the...
It's just really loud.
What the fuck?
I don't know where they like position and stuff.
It's so weird.
Yeah.
Me neither.
Cause usually on this...
On this map...
This is like underneath...
How do you open the door?
The main site.
Oh, E.
Oh, I see you.
There's one guy up here.
Like up in the...
I saw one guy up on that.
Oh.
Hey, he's lit up there.
Okay.
Nice.
I got Kevin.
Oh!
I didn't get him though.
How much did you hit him for?
19.
Alright, what's the 39?
Oh wait, no, 39.
Oh, that was so close.
I just need to hit one more shot.
Oh, I don't have...
How do I sell back?
I think I have an idea.
Okay.
Wait, actually...
Uh...
Oh, you can sell back stuff.
That's fine.
I'll spend everything I have.
You go to scout?
Yeah, it's time.
They might push if you wanna wait for them.
Okay.
Oh, look at this side.
I'm gonna make noise.
Like I'm pushing this way.
Alright.
I don't think they're...
I don't...
I think they're just playing the wait game.
Yeah.
Oh, look at this side.
Oh.
They opened the door.
They closed.
Oh, they closed it.
Oh, they opened the one they found.
Oh, shit!
Aww.
Oh, nice.
I must bait.
Let's go!
No, I didn't mean to.
Yay!
Did I even hit him?
I didn't even hit him.
Wait, actually, I don't know.
I'm surprised they pushed up.
Oh!
Goddamn Kevin!
No!
Oh, nice.
Okay.
That's not fair.
This side is hard to push.
Okay, I realize I'm not a scout person.
I'm just gonna do Desert Eagle.
Let's call my brother.
I should start saving my money.
Yeah, you're good with it.
I should start saving.
Alright.
I can't believe they used util.
Yeah.
Cheaters.
I used it.
A little bit.
I have not used util once.
He's gonna break the window for now.
I'll distract him over here.
Okay.
Oh!
One's, uh...
He's sitting on the ramp.
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
He grenaded me.
Oh my god.
Losers.
Alright, I'm gonna...
Okay.
I'm gonna flash that.
Alright.
You can do...
What the...
I hate this!
You can destroy the door!
Yeah, I forgot to tell you about that.
He destroyed the door!
Oh.
I think he's close.
I see.
Oh my god.
This is...
You only have like three entry points.
And they're all kind of at a weird...
It feels like...
I have a plan.
It feels like CT sided.
Not gonna lie.
Yeah.
Okay.
What's your plan?
Follow me.
Don't worry.
I gotta go near this side.
I'm gonna go to the double doors.
And I'm gonna...
Smoke outside.
And then...
We're gonna go left.
Wait.
Can you open...
Okay.
Hold on.
Just wait for that.
Okay.
I'm a little worried.
There's one guy that's gonna...
Wait.
I just saw him.
I'm gonna look back here.
Alright.
Open the...
Can you open the doors for me?
But don't peek it.
Okay.
I got you.
You should be able to like stand right there.
And press E on it.
Sorry.
I didn't give you a countdown.
I just went damn open.
Alright.
I'm gonna run out into the smoke.
Okay.
I'm going left.
Onto site.
I'm stuck against something.
Wait.
I know where I am.
Where are they?
I'm on the site.
There's a guy above me.
Aww.
I see him.
Yeah.
He's up in the...
Aww.
What?
Okay.
Wait.
Are they...
Is this...
Does this have SPMM?
Or is it like anything...
Anybody?
I'm just curious.
I don't know what that means.
Oh.
Is this like...
Is there like rank based matchmaking?
Like based off your skill level?
Or...
Or is it just like a free for all?
But not...
For this one?
Not in this mode.
Okay.
This mode I think it's like free for all.
Yeah.
These guys...
I feel like these guys know what they're doing.
For sure.
I was like...
What the fu...
Oh my...
He just walks up the door?
What?
I opened it and he just walked up.
Yeah.
I feel like that guy is screen sniping.
Cause he knew where I was.
I don't know.
Well, I did throw a nade.
I think they just...
They're very, very coordinated.
Yeah.
I also think if we started on CT, it would've been a lot easier.
That feels CT sided.
I'm gonna go to the other door.
Fuck these guys.
Okay.
These guys know what they're doing.
Alright.
One guy is like here on this short ramp.
Uh...
I don't even know if I hit Kevin.
Did I got you Kevin?
Okay.
That nade shoots shit.
Like...
That's...
They corey nade that shit.
They're like...
Three, two, one.
I nade you shoot.
There's no fucking way.
There's...
Oh, I did hit Kevin.
That's all I care about.
I...
Nice.
Alright, it's fine.
That's a victory there.
Alright, I have another plan.
Okay.
Follow me, follow me.
Alright, I follow.
We're gonna go...
Hold on.
I don't wanna say.
We could be anywhere.
Where could we be?
Let me see.
Bro, these fucking nades are crazy though.
Not gonna lie.
Oh.
I'm scared now.
If you go down there and peek that door, he's gonna be like directly straight from where you peek.
The orange one.
That's right!
Fuck you, Kevin!
Oh, that's not Kevin.
God damn it.
I wish that was Kevin.
He's up there and he could be walking up to the catwalk that's above you.
Where are you, Kevin?
Like, across.
Across.
Yeah, above.
Kevin, where are you?
I'm scared.
Where the fuck is he?
40 seconds.
Oh my god.
He's above you.
If you go out and turn left.
Where the fuck is he?
Bro, fuck.
He can be up there on a...
If you smoke.
Pull out your... nevermind.
Fuck you, Kevin!
Nice!
Fuck you!
We got one!
I did it!
That's right!
I got you, Kevin!
Nice.
Oh, so another strat people do is like, they'll throw their smoke onto the site and then just get the bomb down.
Oh.
Okay.
I don't know where the...
Yeah.
Oh wait.
Oh, we're defending now.
Nice.
And if you right click with smoke...
Where do we go?
Oh shit, where do we go?
I'm like, where am I?
They're already here!
Oh my god.
That's...
One squeaky, yeah.
Oh my god.
I was not ready for them to insta-push.
Yeah, same.
Oh, I almost got him!
How did they get where they were so fast?
I just need to hit one more shot.
Yeah, like, they knew instantly where to go.
They're cheating!
Uh-huh.
Oh my, how dare they know map knowledge?
How fucking dare they?
No!
Nice, we got him.
Wait, there's a guy behind me!
Oh, he was on the goddamn Kevin!
He was on the window.
I flashed myself!
I was like, wait a minute.
Oh, nice!
Yeah!
Nice!
It's alright.
We, we like, nerf ourselves because it was too easy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was just too easy.
It worked.
Okay.
Oh my god, these guys position, like, instantly.
I don't have a strat now.
Yeah.
I look at the window, I guess.
Okay, you watch window, I'll watch you.
I'm watching window, and I'm watching that door, and I'm watching- Oh, no!
They're on the right!
Oh my god.
Wait, how did he- Because I guess I- He just walked out.
That was a nice try.
Yeah.
The fearless that died 10 times.
Thanks, game.
Thank you.
Yeah, I should've been watching it from where I was.
Shoot.
Oh, does it tell them how- I wanna know their ranks.
Let me know your rank!
I wanna- Wait, what's that?
Oh wait.
Oh wait, their private rank?
Oh, Master Surgeon?
Is that a good rank?
Master Sergeant?
I think that's just, like, the- Like, your level.
Like, how much- Oh, is that your level?
Oh!
Yeah.
Oh, I see.
Yeah, I got confused.
I'm Corporal.
Aw.
Nice, let me go.
You know what?
Let's do it again.
Let's do another 2v2.
I believe.
Okay.
I believe in this.
Do you wanna do a different map?
Let's do Dust.
Wait, do they have Dust?
Oh, they don't have it for Wingman.
Aw.
Alright, your favorite one.
Yeah, 2v2, they don't have it.
Okay, I'll just do these.
Or...
Hold on, let me...
Let me hear me.
Oh.
Inferno?
Oh, that's chicken, right?
What?
You're watching!
No, my shirt!
Oh!
Oh, wait, oh.
Guys, no!
We're doing...
We're doing Inferno, guys!
Whoops!
It's okay.
We're doing Inferno, guys!
Don't look!
Close your eyes!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hold on.
Wait, I gotta get something.
I forgot I ordered something earlier.
Oh, alright.
I left it at the front door.
Yeah, no problem.
I'm like...
I'll be right back.
Alright.
Alright, guys.
I'm queuing up Inferno right now, guys.
Let's see who gets in first.
Let's see...
That's a chicken map, right?
The one where you stab chickens?
Yeah, pretend you don't see.
Close your eyes.
Queue up.
I'm queuing up right now, guys.
Totally queuing up Inferno.
Uh...
Oh!
You know what we should...
Wait.
Did they...
Did Doobie name the Doobirds yet?
Are you guys named yet?
Or are you guys still nameless?
I was gonna say...
Dragoons and the Doobirds should do a 2v2 and see who wins.
Who is the strongest?
Oh, you guys are still nameless?
You guys are still orphans?
I don't know.
Wait, Doobie!
You haven't named your Doobirds yet?
Yeah.
Did you just call them orphans?
Um...
Oh, yeah.
They don't have a name yet.
Yeah.
Mother...
I am...
I'm campaigning for Doobirds.
Minions?
The Minions?
Oh my god, they're Minions.
They can be like...
Doobirds too?
Like...
Yeah, I was gonna say banana!
Because it's yellow too!
They can be like...
Yeah.
They can carry like bananas around.
And then you can give them like the little overalls and stuff.
My outfit is...
Is like...
Kind of minion coated.
Yeah!
And then all...
All of them can like...
Wear the little like minion outfits.
And it's...
And you have the goggles too!
Yeah!
Yeah, I was gonna put them on.
That's why I'm still...
Here we go.
Alright.
Minion coated.
Take this again.
Uh-huh.
Oh!
Oh my god!
You're like a little minion!
She is a minion!
Don't do banana!
Alright, who is this?
Who are we fighting?
Oh my god!
It's them!
I think...
There's only two...
Four people queuing up.
No!
I'm pretty!
There's only four!
Why are we on T side again?
This is messed up!
Can we just leave?
Do we get penalty for leaving?
I mean...
Yeah, technically...
No, I don't...
I think it should be okay if you really want to.
We could try though.
Alright, let's try...
Against them.
Okay, I...
Where do we go?
How does this work?
Cause there's only...
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Well, obviously they just rush out.
There's A and B.
Wait, this map is so fucking big!
Okay, I think we should only go to A.
Wait, this map is huge!
Can we also go to B site?
Yeah!
Oh...
No, B site is...
It's closed off.
Oh...
Can't...
Oh!
Oh my god!
I don't know where I am.
I...
Were they close or were they far?
Oops.
That's...
They were there.
That's my dead body!
Oh, he's over there.
Oh, nice!
Nice shot!
Wait, what gun is that?
This is the USPS.
This is just the CT gun.
Oh!
Damn it!
That's okay, you killed Kevin.
That's all that matters.
I hate that name.
Yeah!
Fuck Kevin!
All you Kevins out there!
Fuck you!
Change your name legally now!
This guy ruined it for all of you!
Yeah!
He...
He ruined Kevin for all of you Kevins out there!
All my homies hate Kevin!
Legally change your name now!
Yeah!
Or maybe you can do a shortened version of Kevin or something.
Kev!
Kev, yeah!
Kevlar?
Oh, you're gonna go that way?
Yeah!
But I hear people up here.
Okay.
Because that can't be you.
You're here for me.
Yeah!
Oh!
JK!
I lied!
Okay, maybe not.
Kevin is a minion!
Oh!
Not anymore!
Kicking Kevin out.
He's getting fired tonight.
What the fuck?
I'm so confused with this map.
This is the map I see the least.
For sure.
Oh, that's my shadow.
Yeah, this one...
They're both sitting, like, further ahead.
What?!
No!
Oh, my God!
50?!
That was on his fucking chest!
I swear to God, I hid his intestines and he was gonna bleed out.
Yeah, but great armor!
Awww...
If you move forward a little bit, and you hit his head, that would've been good.
Um...
I just...
I just thought that, like, I'm gonna make sure he...
I'm gonna hit his kidney and he'll bleed out or some shit.
I don't know.
It takes a while, is all.
Alright, wait.
Walk, walk.
Okay.
What the fuck?
He's close, he's close.
What the fuck?!
Oh, my God!
He scared the shit out of me!
He heard us jump.
Alright, so the other guy should be pretty far, I think, for now.
Kind of...
I don't even know where they can come from.
Like, come from here.
Can he come from here?
Um...
He could, I guess.
Alright.
Can you cover this area and then I'll plant it?
Yeah, sure.
Are you watching it?
Maybe.
Oh, shit!
Where every...
He shot me from the back.
I...
I don't know where...
Wait, what?
The shotgun.
Where did he come from?
I'm so confused.
Um, I think he went all the way around.
So he must have pushed from, like, where we pushed the last time.
He teleported behind me.
Let's go that way.
Alright.
He started blasting.
So I thought in this map, um, a lot of people use it.
Because it's kind of good on this map.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, I can tell that.
Don't worry, I'll...
Oh, my God.
He's close!
Oh, nice!
We did it!
Oh, my God!
What the fuck?
Okay, let's...
You're just gonna rush that.
I feel like.
We could just wait for them, right?
Maybe they're watching the stream and they know which way we're going.
Cause...
I don't know.
Well, let's go again.
Yeah, maybe we can wait for them.
Yeah.
Let's try that.
Let's try it.
Now we'll know for sure if they're...
Yeah.
That's right.
Oh, they're coming.
There's just one, though.
Yeah, there's one on A and one here.
Yeah.
I looked down the stairs.
Just in case.
There's only four people playing wingman.
Isn't that sad?
Because you have to be queued up with a duo, so maybe...
Oh, really?
There aren't people trying to queue it, but...
I think so.
Oh, my God.
What's that sound?
I'm so paranoid.
Like, where could they come from?
I don't know.
This map is making me so paranoid.
He's super close right here.
I think... was that you jumping?
No, that was not me.
I didn't jump.
Okay, I'm gonna peek this.
This guy's close.
Alright, we have...
We don't have a lot of time, so I'm rushing.
Alright.
Oh, where was he?
Um...
They were both on A.
They were on A?
Which kind of makes sense that they would both sit there.
Because...
Yeah, that's the only...
Site we can play like that.
He just ran straight to me and I got...
I got exploded.
Alright, so we'll...
I guess...
We'll be more aggressive pushing them in this area.
Yeah, I guess so.
We just run?
Yeah.
No, there's one guy close.
Oh, I think they heard us for sure.
Here, here.
Alright, don't worry.
Stand on my head.
And you can look over the...
Okay.
He's right there!
Is he boosted?
I don't know!
Was he?
Oh, shit!
I don't know where I am!
No!
Aww!
That was close!
I hit him for 88.
Aww!
They did the same plan!
They had the same idea!
They actually...
Yeah, yeah!
Yeah!
Stop it!
Alright, let's...
Let's...
This is ramp over here.
Okay.
So we'll do a ramp rush.
It's like, wait a minute.
I was not expecting that.
They could come out here.
Oh, they smoked?
Watching that.
Oh!
Damn it!
Sorry.
Where is he?
He's on site.
They're both on site, I think.
They're gonna be pushing you to your right.
Yeah, like, right up there.
Aww!
Oh, nice try.
I was like, where's site again?
I was so...
I was like, where am I supposed to look?
I wasn't even sure where it was.
Sorry.
Bless you.
Thank you.
I just...
I'm drinking coffee, so...
Oh...
You're like, caffeinated.
Like a little...
Yeah!
Not yet.
It hasn't kicked in yet.
Yeah.
Think they know?
No way.
Slowly going up.
I may or may not die.
He's...
Aw!
Jesus Christ!
These guys are...
You guys are good.
Stream sniping.
No!
It's okay.
Now we're counter terrorists.
This is definitely CT sided.
Maybe we can just sit on site since, uh...
Yeah.
Okay.
So...
Somebody could watch here, and then somebody can watch, like...
To the left.
Okay.
Like, if you stand here, then you'll be able to see them coming from here.
And then I'll watch the other side.
Okay.
They might get there before me, though.
I don't know.
Wait.
Actually, I don't know where to watch.
I'm just...
Staying here.
Oh!
Is that you?
No.
There's two.
There's two there.
Oh, they're both there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're both there.
I'm...
Oh, nice!
Oh!
That's close!
I think...
Oh!
You just needed...
I think you hit...
Oh, wait, no.
I actually can't tell which one I killed.
Or which one I did damage to.
Oh, I killed Kevin.
Oh, you killed Kevin?
Oh, you just needed, like, one...
Yeah.
I killed 37 on him.
On the other guy.
Okay.
Are you...
You can keep watching here, or you can stand there, too.
Okay.
That might be good.
Yeah, I think I'll stand here.
I hear one pushing mid.
I can head over.
I think they always, like, do two at the same time.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I don't think they ever split.
And then they're gonna split now.
Yeah, that's what I was just thinking.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Watch them actually split.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
We're playing social.
I hear one here.
Can I come over?
Another one?
He's far.
Yeah, I'm here.
Pushed up.
I got him.
Yeah!
That's right, bitch!
That's right!
Fuck you, Kevin!
Okay, now he's definitely gonna hate me.
Now...
Now it's personal for him.
Of course, the person with two kills.
The person with two kills acting like this.
Oh, whoa.
Alright, we'll do the same thing.
Okay.
Oh yeah, there's one here.
They have to push up pretty far to get to site, so...
Yeah.
Oh, they're boosting.
That one's close.
He can come from here, so watch your...
Okay.
...that area.
Oh yeah, he did.
Aww, he did.
Nice, though.
The moment you said that you pushed up.
That was sneaky, sneaky.
Clutch your cake.
Oh!
Okay, that was good.
You got it!
You clutched!
I was gonna report you if you didn't.
Do you want this gun?
Oh yeah.
Or...
Yeah, yeah.
What is that?
The Galeel.
They are.
I don't think I'm getting enough gun here on this map.
It's kinda 30.
Yeah.
Alright.
I think I hear the mid.
Oh look, we're just a little longer.
Oh, I hear it.
Oh, they're not here.
I think they're boosting again.
And...
One of them is.
I'm scared that the other guy was...
Have you heard the other one?
I don't know.
Aww!
He was over there.
I don't know if I hit him.
I thought he was gonna go around.
Was he like, up there?
Oh.
Yeah, there he is.
I knew it.
Aww.
Nice!
Oh my god.
So dirty.
Wait, what gun is yours?
The shotgun on this map is infuriating.
That's crazy.
The XM.
The auto-shotting.
XM-10...
1014?
Alright, I'm trying it too.
Alright.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
They both move in so fast.
You might want to hold a little bit closer though.
Okay.
Oh, you can spam that shotgun.
It's nice.
You just hold it or do you click?
Uh, I click.
Oh yeah.
I'm not sure if you can hold it.
Chat.
You guys though.
There's one.
Over here.
Oh.
Aww.
I thought both of...
I peeked out.
Because I thought both of them went to you.
No.
I got timed.
Oh, nice!
Oh, yeah.
It hit 51.
So he was ready.
Yay!
Oh, nice.
Yeah, he was lit.
Nice.
Do you want an AK?
No, I'm gonna do what you do.
Oh, I think you did.
Okay.
I'm gonna abuse it too.
Alright.
Just go this way.
I think this is like one of the only maps where it really works.
That's right.
It's my turn to abuse this gun.
And still die.
This is so slow.
Yeah.
They're playing sneaky because we're kind of catching up.
My god.
Oh.
Well, yeah.
There's one on A.
Both on A.
Both there.
One A?
Okay.
Yeah.
It'll be to your left.
Aww.
Nice try, nice try.
Yeah.
F46 though.
It's always Kevin.
God.
Damn it.
I...
That's it.
I'm throwing grenades.
You'll probably do the same thing, I think.
I'll try to smoke him off on the ramp over here.
I fucked up.
Did you hurt yourself?
No, I did.
I didn't know how to name.
You want me to come over?
Fire in the hole.
Uh, nah.
I'm just spamming nades.
Throwing fire.
Oh!
They boosted.
It's two, it's two.
They boosted up there.
But I don't know if the other one will start flanking.
Oh!
That was good.
So close!
6-9!
That was close.
Yeah.
Nice.
The clickbait.
Oh my god.
Yeah, they boosted.
Yeah.
For that.
That's fun though.
That's fun.
Learning CS.
Yeah.
You wanna do Overwatch Stadium now?
Okay.
Yeah.
Do you think he would play?
I would, yeah.
Do you think he would play CS again?
I would play with people for sure.
I don't think I can do the solo.
I, I think I'd get too mad.
Yeah.
If I play CS solo.
I feel like, I need to play.
It is really infuriating.
Yeah.
As long as all I have to do is just shoot.
Then like, and never use my util, I'll be fine.
Alright.
I'll let other people.
It's just like, abilities.
How's that?
No, it's so different.
Alright.
I think it's the lineup.
Lining it up is like, weird.
I think.
I just don't like, it's just, I'm so bad with deaf perception.
Did you see this?
Okay.
So, I don't know if you saw.
I tweeted out, um, a video of me playing Jeff.
I don't know if you saw, but I have very, I have very bad deaf perception.
Did you jump off?
No.
The thing is.
I'll show you the clip.
I'll show my chat the clip too.
So, the thing is, is that, I literally saw Captain America made it.
So, I was like, clearly I can make it too.
Like...
I was like, I saw him, he walked over.
And then I was like, surely I can walk over that.
And then I just fell straight down.
I fell all the way down.
And then my team was like, what happened to Jeff?
He had four legs.
So, it's more difficult for him to, you know, jump like that.
Yeah, to be fair, I was just, I was waddling.
I was, I was just waddling up.
To the, to the hole, the big hole.
Do you play Jeff that often?
No, it was just, that, that was the one time I played Jeff too.
That one time I decided to play Jeff yesterday.
Oh, cause Captain America has like, the momentum from...
Yeah, I forgot he could run.
I forgot he could run.
Run, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, Jeff is just waddling.
Alright.
I think...
I'm gonna send you my, uh...
Oh yeah.
Tag.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No leaks, guys.
No leaks.
Oh my god.
Someone already made Hank Hill dance a Miku song.
Wait, it's like two days or...
I love, god, I love Fortnite.
I love Fortnite skins.
Alright, uh...
You don't even play it?
You just like...
Yeah, I literally, I just buy...
I just log into Fortnite, buy the skin, and then log off.
Like...
Wait, is that your name?
Is that...
Yes.
Okay.
Wait, does your...
I...
It's an old name.
Yeah.
Uh...
Like, I wanted to change it, but it costs like $10 to change your name, and...
I just...
I don't know.
It's a good name, though.
Do I really wanna give Blizzard $10?
That's true.
Thank you.
They don't need more of our money.
Alright, I added you.
Slash.
Okay.
Oh wait, hold on.
It says...
Overwatch has detected your computers using Intel 13th or 14th gen processor.
Oh.
Hmm...
I don't know if that's good or not.
It's fine if I do the Intel fine-tuning thing.
Hmm?
No, it's like that...
I have the...
The shoddy processor, the...
Oh, the one that's...
The 10th gen...
Yeah, the one that has...
Problems.
Or I-9.
Yeah.
Yeah, the problems.
But it's still launched, so I...
It's probably fine.
Okay, I'm gonna go...
I'll go...
Do you wanna play tank?
Cause there's a role queue for stadium.
Are you gonna go tank, damage, or support?
Uh...
Um...
Hold on...
Yeah, that's here.
Do you usually go tank?
No, I usually go support, but like...
I also am currently elite support, so maybe I should go...
Oh...
Yeah, I didn't play that much, but...
Uh...
No...
Question mark!
Question mark, I have no idea.
Well, is there...
Like, a matchmaking rank?
Apparently, any...
Anything in this?
Apparently, you can play...
No, like, it doesn't matter what your rank are.
Is...
You can grow up with anybody, and they'll just balance it out through it.
Oh...
But everybody...
It's like, you know how like...
In Rivals and Apex, there's no placements for your stadium?
So like, you start for all the way from bronze.
Yeah.
Oh...
Okay, gotcha.
So it's just grinding the game...
To get a higher rank.
And then they have like, win streaks and stuff, so you can...
Oh...
Get...
Get like, points easily.
So, I need to back you all right back!
Okay!
Now I will steal and take over Doki's chat.
Look at me!
I'm Doki now.
How do I get out of this?
Um...
Oh!
There's a new hero.
This hero looks...
There's like a character in Paladins that looks very similar to this.
I think her name's Cassie.
Or no, there's another one.
She has red hair.
And she has a crossbow.
No...
Uh...
Okay.
Oh, cute!
I haven't played Overwatch in so long.
I haven't launched this in like, two years or something.
It feels like.
Yes, my name... on this account... is, uh...
Don't worry about it.
Oh, yeah, don't worry about it.
I was thinking about making it Duba instead.
Yeah.
But I'm not gonna spend $10 to change one letter.
So true.
They already make enough money.
Alright.
Invite the group.
I invited you.
Alright.
Stadium.
Alright, I could do...
Is this six or... No, it's five people.
Okay.
I can do damage.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
I'll do... I'll just do all, so I'll just...
Oh, just flex?
Yeah.
Oh, you can fuck around with the builds and stuff, too.
What?
I'm gonna take us to deathmash.
Is it like if you pick one...
Is this Q support?
So if you get put into...
Or Q role?
So if you get put into support, like you're stuck in support?
It's a normal rank system.
Yeah.
I don't know the...
I don't know the DPS loadout, though.
Like the DPS stuff you can do for the builds.
And people already put out guides on like what build to do and stuff.
I heard...
Oh, okay.
Wait, so is this kind of new then?
Um, it came out...
Oh, my God.
I...
My aim is so bad right now.
What do you mean?
We won the boot counterstrike.
That's like the perfect aim.
No.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
My sense.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
I forgot my support sense is like customized.
And then...
Wait.
That's not my right sense?
Why is that...
Is it my right sense?
I don't remember.
Oh, it's a lot of movement stuff.
Guys, can someone check my VOD?
My Overwatch VODs?
And tell me what my sense is in Overwatch?
Cause I don't remember.
I...
I actually...
That sounds like a lot of work.
I don't remember.
I don't know if I like D...
If my sense is fucked up or not.
It's...
There's no way.
That timestamp stuff.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
They do.
No.
I just have it on my description.
Like what my sense is.
Oh, it is four.
No.
1.83 is my rival.
Okay.
It is four.
I'm just not used to first person anymore.
All right.
Oh, we're both DPS.
Okay.
Nice.
Uh...
I don't know what's meta.
It's...
Oh, do they rotate characters out for this?
No.
It's just...
It's always this.
Yeah.
I heard Freya.
Oh, Freya is really good right now.
Uh...
Okay.
I'll try.
Yeah.
She's like...
It's like a fast projectile.
You know what?
I'll play Call of Duty.
Um...
Oh, wait.
Is Cass meta?
I'm not gonna hit anything.
Wait, what's his name again?
I forgot.
Cassidy.
Cass...
Okay, yeah.
Okay.
Wait, is it not in first person?
Or is it still first person?
You can...
You can swap the third person for this one.
Oh.
So, that's what makes it unique.
So, now you can play as, uh...
You can be like first person or third person.
But I think it's weird for me to play third person on Overwatch.
Yeah.
Guys, what's the build for Cass?
Is it weapon power?
Yeah.
What do we do, guys?
What do we do?
Oh, yeah.
I assume weapon power.
Uh...
After using combat...
Guys, what the fuck do I...
What do I do?
Weapon power and max ammo?
Ooh.
Oh, there's so many.
So I only get to pick one?
Yeah.
For now.
Cause it's, uh...
Ammo and right click funsie?
But what's it called?
I don't know.
Wait, how do I switch into first person?
Do you know?
Yeah, there's just settings.
And then, uh...
Video...
I don't know.
It's like in...
I think it's video or gameplay.
Okay, I'll do...
Okay.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
Ugh.
I might have got something dumb.
I...
I just got flashbang power up.
I don't know.
I just clicked the first thing I saw.
Whoops.
I didn't have time to look.
This is fine.
Wait, I'm getting distracted by the mercy skin.
Oh.
Alright.
Oh no, don't damage boost me.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Don't do it.
Oh, nice.
Nice, our team's doing it.
Where are they?
Wait, they're taking high ground?
I don't know.
I'm just shooting.
Ah!
I forgot they put fall off damage.
Oh, really?
Yeah, for Cass, yeah.
Oh, I see.
I need to remember that I can...
I can crush this.
Slashbang!
Does respawn, like, normal?
Like, uh...
Yeah, yeah, it's normal.
Timer?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I hear you, soldier.
Come on.
Oh, he ran all the way back.
Yeah.
Wait, is this map new for this, uh, game mode?
Uh, yeah.
Just for this game mode.
I don't know where the fuck you position.
I'm always, like, support for this.
Oh!
Oh, he's so low.
I'm using it.
No!
He reflected it!
He's too smart!
Nice.
I'm standing below us.
He can't kill me.
I'm below him.
Yeah, me too.
Oh, never mind.
I'm asleep.
Where'd he go?
I don't know.
Oh, he's over here.
That's a good question.
Wait, what the fuck is he doing?
Nice.
He's dead.
He's dying is what he's doing.
That's right.
Get back here, Cassidy!
Get your ass back here!
Oh my god!
JK!
Oh no!
He flashbaked me!
He knew exactly what he was doing.
Okay, I'm gonna steal their Cass' build, cause I have no idea what to build.
Okay.
No, he was camping, he was playing CS, and I was playing actual Overwatch.
How dare he!
You can switch just like that.
I'm so lucky Cassidy has fall off now.
I don't know what my I need healing button is.
The findings for this is like, so different.
There we go.
I'm fine, but also not fine at the same time.
Alright.
We almost had the .2s.
Wait, is it this?
Just like King of the Hill, right?
I have no idea what my ult is.
I don't know either.
You don't know?
I don't know.
How do you play this game?
I don't play Freya enough.
Okay, that's fine.
We killed three.
What is he doing?
No!
Not the fan that happened!
He does this to fan that happened!
Okay, we won.
We won.
I got fan.
Alright.
Wait, why does this guy have his like name is highlighted?
Why is that?
Oh, it's the new thing they added.
It makes you...
It's so like...
The more games you play, the more...
You gain like XP or something to unlock these.
So it makes you look like cooler, I guess.
I don't know.
Oh...
Right, right, right, right.
So like be like, oh look at me.
I have this.
Weapon power.
Just do weapon power.
Wait, so can I buy items like in the middle of...
Yeah.
So you can sell them.
You can only buy it like now.
Oh, you can only buy it now.
You can only buy it now.
You can sell your items too.
It's like, oh, it's like a name.
You were saying it's like a name card thing.
Breach ammo.
Oh, that makes sense.
Oh no, only 20 seconds?
I'm just...
Oh, I don't know what I'm doing guys.
I'm so confused.
More ammo.
I just clicked some random stuff.
Me too, me too.
Alright, I'm gonna try and steal the enemy team's build.
Wait, just to confirm.
Even when you die, you can't buy stuff, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's only between rounds.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, this guy...
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
I see, I see, I see.
Okay, I'm gonna steal that power up.
If we make it that far.
Alright.
Figured it out.
Yeah, you can also...
Oh yeah, you can go to the practice stadium to like, see...
Like, experiment with builds.
So like, while we're like waiting, Q, we can experiment.
I know.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Kind of reminds me of deadlock a little bit, but more like paladins, I guess.
Yeah.
Oh, you can counter swap too.
That's the thing.
Go high ground.
Nice.
Oh my god, Ana's one.
Oh my god, you're still one!
Stop!
Oh my god, bitch.
Okay, I got it.
I got Rizze.
She was one, I couldn't get him.
Shoot, I died.
Oh, I got her.
That's right.
Oh, I got Rizze.
You don't wanna peek now!
Okay, I zoned him out.
Wait, chat, how do I change my POV?
Oh, yeah, I forgot about that!
Don't worry, we'll figure it out.
Oh, I think our Mora might be dead.
Yeah!
Oh.
That's you?
Okay, I got soldier.
Alright.
Oh, she's one, she's one.
Nice.
Oh.
I got Aversa!
Nice!
Where's the cast?
Alright, no, she's dead.
We did it.
I'm a flanking.
I'ma go flank.
You take the front line.
Don't worry, you're alive!
I do, like, toothpick damage.
Oh my god, why me?
Oh, I have an Arisa chasing me right now.
I had an Arisa chasing me, I'm okay.
Oh, never mind.
You guys are not okay.
It's okay, he doesn't know I'm here.
Okay, I'm thinking.
In the menu.
I'm gonna fix my thingy.
Video.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, I have my knees.
Okay, nice.
It's okay, we won.
Oh, nice, really?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, we did it, it's okay.
No, we didn't win yet, but, like, we won.
Okay, and now I think I can find it for you.
But after we win this.
Yeah!
Oh, okay.
Alright.
I think I got instructions in the chat.
I think I got it.
Oh, okay.
Maybe?
Woohoo!
The UI for this kind of reminds me of, um, Pokemon Unite.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah.
A little pen.
Now you mention it, I see it.
I like the announcer, kind of.
It's options...
Oh, I see.
Oh, it's options, control, stadium.
Oh... Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, now... Now I can steal their build.
Uh... One max ammo per... Okay.
So cooked.
Okay.
Am I cooked, chat?
No, we're doing so well.
I believe in us.
Let's see.
Ooh.
I want to get the reduction.
And then... I don't need more armor.
If I can survive without armor.
I don't know what some of the stuff I bought is, but I just bought it.
If it works, it works.
Okay.
I'm gonna get more weapon power.
Yeah!
Armor's for nerds.
If I kill them...
If I kill them in time, then, like, more damage is better.
Why put any defense if you may just die faster?
Mercy, what did they do to you?
What does she look like?
Oh, that's the Magical Girl weapon.
Or... It's like the... Heirloom.
She lost all her soul.
Oh, right.
Well, I mean, Magical Girl kind of is, like, you sign away your souls.
Yeah, exactly.
What the...
Where did he come from?
Oh, nice.
I don't know where the fuck that guy came from.
He literally just Mach 7 ran to me.
I was so confused.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Wait, you guys weren't supposed to die.
Wait a minute.
Nice.
It's fine.
Where are they?
Oh.
On point.
Wait.
Oh, the Moira is super low.
Yeah, yeah.
But our point is in the back now.
Where our point is at the back.
Oh, no.
This is our point.
Yeah, this is our point.
Cause they already capped.
In 10 seconds.
Ah.
Okay.
Oh, no.
He's here too.
He knows.
The Moira is so low.
No.
I whiffed.
Whiffed.
No.
It's okay.
I believe in you.
It's a Moira.
I got very greedy.
You're distracting them, right?
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, yeah.
I was baiting them.
Yeah, I'm always... baiting them.
Oh my god, your stupid strafe pattern.
Oh my god, stop looking at me.
Yeah, you can strafe here.
Oh, I'm not looking at that.
Oh, I got the cast.
Oh, man.
I got two, I got two.
No.
Oh, I got rezzed.
Thank you.
He's huge.
I'm still alive.
Alright, we both clutched when we needed to.
Oh, wait.
I have a right-click with that.
Five.
I'm still alive.
Nice, we did it.
Oh my god, I'm still alive.
Oh.
That was scary.
So how many points do we need to win?
We need to win four rounds.
It's four rounds.
Oh, okay.
Just one more round.
Oh, GG.
They already gave up.
Alright, I'm gonna steal.
So it goes to a bunch of different maps, huh?
Yeah.
Yeah, so like it gives you different options.
Alright, what did they use?
Attack speed.
Oh my god, it's just all ammo.
This guy...
It's like this guy knows how to play Cassidy.
Wait, how can you see their stuff?
Uh, you go...
You press tab, and then you look at enemy builds.
So you can steal their builds.
But you don't know what to do.
That's what I'm doing.
I don't know what I'm...
I don't know what I'm doing.
So I'm just stealing their builds.
And it's safe to say, the teams are in the zone.
Alright.
I see.
It's okay, we are a four stack, and we also want to say GG.
Oh, wait, they're a four stack?
Sad.
What's your build?
Um, I don't know.
Don't look.
I'm looking.
I've never played the Freya before.
Oh, I see.
I was looking at my build.
It's kind of fun, I guess.
Yeah.
We don't have enough time.
Yeah, it's weird.
Freya's thing is weird.
It's not hitscan, I feel like, right?
No, it's very fast projectile.
That's Freya's.
So it feels a little off, you know?
When you're trying to...
You have to lead your shot just a little bit.
Yeah.
That's right, Cass.
I see you.
Oh my god.
Running away, huh?
That's right.
No running away here.
Oh my god, he's so low.
Nice.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
They're both over there though.
DPS on the right there.
That's fine.
You don't have heals.
We got him.
That's fucking right.
Nice.
Teamwork.
You're freaking carrying this team.
It's too easy for you.
Oh no, no.
I'm whiffing so...
No, I'm whiffing so hard.
I...
It's like bronze right now.
It's okay.
You carried me on TS.
That's why it's easy.
I carry you on Overwatch.
I don't know about that.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Actually, flatbang.
Whoops.
That's awkward.
He has ult.
Oh, he doesn't have ult.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Heal your team.
Heal your team, Mora!
Oh, oh.
Nice, nice.
Are Mora...
No, no, no.
They're Mora.
They're Mora let me kill the cast.
Wait, where am I?
It's okay.
They're mad.
Because they're bad.
I'm outta here.
Yeah, you should leave.
I saw the nano boost.
I don't even know what my ultimate is.
Is it a bomb?
I don't know either.
That's a good question.
Wait, take your cell?
Guys, what is...
Yay!
A pulling bomb.
Oh.
Okay.
It's like a mini-grab.
It's like a grab.
Yay.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
Makes sense.
Nice.
Okay, I figured it out.
I figured out how to aim again.
Oh, easy.
What did I do?
Wow, let's see.
Let's see.
What did I...
What is this?
Oh.
That's not...
Oh, yeah.
Okay, now I see.
Whoa!
Huge!
Look at that play!
Whoa!
Oh, wait.
I'll do tank and DPS too.
I thought it was good.
Oh, man.
Yeah.
I gotta re-queue again.
Oh, okay.
I changed the tank and...
I changed my rolls too.
My point and click adventure.
Okay.
It's just like...
Hold on.
Alright.
Oh, here.
You can do...
I'll do practice range so you can look at the different builds you can do.
Okay.
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
I guess we'll figure it out here.
This guy wouldn't absorb anything anyways.
Exactly.
Okay.
Uh...
I'll do...
Call of Duty for real.
Kinda like playing this chick.
I'll play again.
Yeah.
Yeah, just figure out the...
I'm curious to see the baby bob.
Oh, the baby bob?
That's on Ash.
Yeah, I wanna...
Okay, I'll try.
Yeah, it's really...
It's really cute.
It's like a little baby.
It's an actual, like, little tiny baby.
He's like...
He's like the size...
Like, he's basically half the size of us.
And he's better, apparently.
How do...
Is it like a boost?
Or power-up or something?
Yeah, it's like one of the power.
Yeah.
Like how...
Look for it.
Regina George.
Oh, me.
And...
Yeah.
I can find it.
Example build.
You're using activate tactical visor?
Oh my god.
I have like a mini tactical visor.
Chat, where's the baby bob?
Wait, I see it.
Bob jr. Wait, that's what's called?
Bob jr. Yeah.
Aw, that's cute.
I assume this is also weapon power and...
Ability power?
What is a good one for a soldier, guys?
Like, skills damage.
Chat, what's good?
Homing rockets?
What about a mini-tack?
Okay, I'll do homing rockets.
Alright.
Full weapon power.
Okay.
Contrabability speed.
Okay, I need to like...
I need to remember how...
I need to remember the crouch spam for a soldier.
Oh my god.
It's so...
Is that...
Is that like counter-strike?
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, I think over overwatch everybody just like crouch spams too.
And then...
You know like the soldier players where they just like...
Run in the circle like...
Like that.
So they can't get hit.
Like the classic movement.
I'm gonna go on high ground.
Wait.
Somebody's going here too.
I hear them.
Wait.
Oh my god!
Somebody save our ride!
How do I do this?
Oh!
Oh, you got... you got...
Junker is meta.
Junker is so scary.
Yeah.
She's so scary.
Okay, to be fair, our entire team was like super split up.
A big woman.
Yeah!
Strong.
Big woman.
The entire team was like mega split up there.
I was like, where did everybody go?
For some reason, everyone followed me.
And I don't know why.
I say...
Oh.
It's cause you're...
You seem like you know what you're doing.
I don't.
I usually...
Oh!
That sucks.
We have a ride and they have a maid too.
Oh no.
I die so fast.
It feels so squishy.
Oh no.
I'm so scared.
Should I play Ashe?
It's like more mid range, right?
Like long range kind of?
Uh...
She's like...
I think she's any range to be fair.
Oh, okay.
That's...
But to be fair, I don't play Ashe often.
I think Ashe is actually my worst DPS.
I think I'm just...
This sucks.
I'm just doing like...
Whoa!
Oh, I killed myself.
I hit the wall.
Oh!
What happened?
I killed...
Okay, I strafed.
And then I wasn't thinking about my strafe pattern.
I...
I was starting to jiggle peek their mate.
And it wasn't working.
My jiggle peek wasn't working.
Trying to use pro strats, huh?
And then I hit the wall.
I right clicked into the wall when I was jiggle peeking.
Oh...
Oh, you like exploded yourself with the rockets?
Yeah.
I exploded myself.
Shit.
Yeah.
Okay.
Soldier is not...
I just realized...
Soldier is not that good.
He seems pretty...
I don't know.
Kind of...
I think like...
Vanilla, I guess.
He is that type of character.
He's like the easiest character to play.
For DPS.
But like, I feel like his damage is like...
Not as good.
Cassidy was doing...
I think because I was mostly hitting headshot for Cass.
That like, it was easier.
But like, I forgot how like...
It's like shooting like...
Fucking toothpicks at people.
Oh, wait.
That's not a door.
Wait, is that a door?
Wait, that is a door.
This is not...
Oh.
No, I was like...
Wait, is this a door?
Oh yeah, it is, it is, it is.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was like, wait a minute.
Why isn't it opening?
Oh, what up there?
I was like, why is that door not opening?
Oh, it's this map.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
But it's like a miniature version.
Oh my god.
Oh, my little toothpick.
He's just using cover!
That's illegal!
Wait, you guys are dead.
Wait a minute.
Wait, wait.
I'm alive.
I'm here.
Oh wait, the rest of our team is dead.
Where did they go?
Oh no, you're dead for real.
I need healing.
Don't kill me.
Oh no!
She's fucking...
She's using her fucking...
I was on my heal pad and she like rolled me out of my heal pad.
It's not...
I don't think it's us though.
Never blame ourselves.
It's not us.
Yeah, it's our teammates.
Yeah, exactly.
Our Mercy isn't healing us.
It's their fault.
Mercy's won.
Fucking stop.
Oh my god.
No!
This guy actually knows how to play tank.
That's why his name is I know.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, I know.
I know.
What is that?
There's a big meatball.
I saw a big red meatball.
Oh yeah, that's me.
Yeah, that's...
Oh, oops.
Okay.
The...
This isn't fair!
He's actually getting in!
I finally have my Bob Jr. Send him out!
Send him out!
Oh no.
The meatball.
Okay.
I'm gonna wait a little.
Until we're all here.
Okay.
Alright.
I've got you in my sights.
Wait, what?
Where is...
Why are they all the way there?
Excuse me?
I didn't even get to see my little Bob.
Why were they here?
Oh my god.
These supports are like taking...
They're peeling for each other.
It's not us.
Don't worry, Doobie.
Okay, if you say so.
It's never the DPS fault.
Their tank is sweaty.
Yeah.
You know what?
You're right.
How dare they try.
Isn't this like cook play?
Technically, yeah.
They don't have an actual ring for it.
Oh my god.
I finally got a kill.
Finally.
Oh my god.
I got it.
Stop.
Leave me alone.
No!
I killed three!
Uh oh.
No!
Shoot.
I can't believe it.
We can tie?
Can you tie in this?
Uh, not tie, but you can...
We can turn it around.
Because every...
We're getting points, right?
We can easily change our builds.
Ah, okay.
Yeah.
Alright.
Oh, I can have another power.
Uh...
Shooting and...
Oh.
Wait, wouldn't this be good?
Chain gun?
I'm gonna go with this one.
And I'm gonna do chain gun.
And then...
Maybe more ability power?
Yeah, I'm just gonna stack up on ability power.
Oh, Zarya...
Um...
Some tanks have some crazy fucking builds, too.
That you can do.
I'm surprised we're getting DPS.
We're getting DPS for this.
Because you assume that a lot of people want to play DPS in Overwatch.
Yeah.
Zarya is like...
I think like...
Tanks, you can do some really fucking crazy builds in tanks.
From what I've seen.
Hmm...
I want to try bling tank, too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You should try tank next round.
Uh...
Zarya...
Does like...
So much damage that you can play...
Uh...
If you build her really well.
Oh, she's in this game mode, too?
Yeah, yeah.
Zarya and Junker are like really, really good for this mode.
Okay.
I like playing Orisa.
Orisa.
Oh, Orisa's good, too.
Yeah.
Honestly, all the tanks have good builds for this.
I think.
I was playing with one of my tank friends for this mode.
And like, he was basically like a raid boss.
With his build.
So it's like crazy what you can do with it.
Oh my god.
I'm leaving this area.
I don't want to be on that side.
The side looks very scary.
This guy is lit over here.
Oh my...
They're all lit.
Nice, nice, nice.
I say all of them were lit, too.
Nice.
Oh, I have to reload.
No, not the ice cube.
What is that?
It's just the Mei...
The Mei freeze, but...
Oh my god.
She's so...
No!
I have to reload.
He got armor!
Juno!
Minicob!
Where is he?
Look at him!
He's so tiny!
Look at how tiny he is!
Oh!
What the?
Oh yeah, I know.
Juno...
Juno's build...
Her E can become like really fucking strong.
Where he can like one shot.
Like that's her special builds.
Okay, I got Mercy.
Oh my god.
Oh!
That's a...
That's a Junker!
No!
Aw, so close to ult, too.
Mora has ult, but she's dead.
She did.
Shoot, everybody's dead.
We have to defend the third...
Second point.
Ouch!
Live!
Live, Doobie!
Oh, goodbye, Doobie.
I defend this.
Oh my god.
These guys are so sweaty!
Yeah.
They're playing...
Well, it's mostly meta, except for the Mei.
But this guy's actually pretty decent at Mei.
I will ult you.
I know!
They're doing so much!
What is there?
Oh my god.
They have so much heals.
There's a lady behind.
No!
Not the woman!
It's okay.
I believe.
Towering...
Woman.
That's...
Big woman!
Oh my god.
The Mercy was so low, too.
That Juno has so much shield!
Somebody, please!
I swear to god.
Nice.
Oh no, we lost both supports though.
And they have both their supports.
Dammit.
Oh my god!
No!
Our two supports got frozen!
Yeah!
I think it's over.
It's not...
At least we know it's not us.
It might.
No, we're running so low!
Oh, it's over.
Now it's over.
Now it might be over.
Frick!
Okay.
Well, look.
It's not...
At least it went by fast.
Oh no, we have one more round.
Wait.
Did they win it, Foley?
Or do we have one more round?
Oh...
Cause like, if they...
Oh no, they won it.
Yeah, they got it.
It makes sense if you win three out of four.
That you just don't have a chance, right?
Probably would have won if you're right.
I said last time, T-back.
Oh yeah, it's this.
Yeah, they...
The maze successfully ulted our...
Our support.
That was unlucky.
Um...
Was our team T-bagging?
Yeah, Ryan wasn't protecting us.
He was just T-bagging.
Alright, now we can...
Oh...
Look like...
Now we can look at the builds.
Oh...
Okay.
Wait, what's your rank in this?
Um...
For support, I'm in the lead right now.
But we all start in bronze.
Oh...
Nevermind, we got a game.
Nevermind.
It's okay.
I...
I'm getting the hang of it.
Oh, I'm tank!
This is kind of whiplash from CS though, I'm not gonna lie.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, nice!
I'm tank.
Alright, I'm Zarya.
All the healing and...
I'm Zarya now.
Um...
I forgot the Zarya build.
I forgot if I focused on ability power or...
Weapon power.
Chat, do you guys remember?
I don't remember.
Woo!
Full weapon power?
Okay.
I remember I made like an insane Zarya build.
Damn.
Mm.
I made an insane Zarya build last time I played.
And it was like...
I literally was just doing like 80...
80% plus damage.
But I don't remember what I did.
Oh!
Oh.
See, in Paladins, I think you can save like your...
Like your load.
Also in Deadlock too.
I hope they do that.
Did you do something like that for this?
Yeah.
Oh, true!
Everyone could use a little help.
I heard they're planning on adding like, uh...
A...
A top 500 for this too.
Cause everyone's been enjoying it a lot.
Oh!
I mean, it's pretty...
I like it.
That'd be a good way to get more people to play.
Yeah.
You must choose carefully.
Yeah, they're saying that Zarya being built would be for next season.
I don't...
What's the meatball?
Where's the meatball?
Oh, this is...
Oh.
Where is the...
Mini, uh...
Bear, Nox, Indyla...
Uh...
I have their various cast.
Oh, there's one.
Yeah, this is what I wanted.
I can do this, and then...
There we go.
That's good.
I'm glad they're...
Okay.
Planning on saving...
Stuff next to me.
Alright, I got bubble just...
Just for you.
Yes.
I got bubble.
So you can take as much damage as you want.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll bubble you.
I need you to farm...
Give me damage.
Okay.
I believe.
Go in there.
Can you bubble my meatball?
Yeah, I think...
I'm pretty sure I can.
You just roll in.
I wonder...
While I roll around.
Yeah.
Okay.
Try it.
Yeah, I don't know how to do it though.
Is that my ult?
I know.
That's your...
That's your ice cube.
Yeah.
Oh.
Yeah, so instead of like...
Stationary.
You...
Uh...
You just go up.
You just roll over.
Okay.
Wait.
I'm immune in my meatball form anyways.
Yeah, but...
Then I get her...
Damage buildup, right?
Yeah.
Okay, never mind.
Use it.
I...
I have one though.
What the fuck was our Kiriko doing?
Yeah.
Oh, no.
That's...
It's okay.
Oh, it's not okay.
It's not okay.
But it's okay.
We have a hundred damage.
Nice.
Who's this?
Who's that?
Oh, where are you?
Oh, this is the healer.
Okay.
I'm just looking at...
That's right.
Get over here, Mercy.
Heroes because of their skin.
No!
Mercy flew away!
Oh my god!
Okay, it's fire.
Plan.
Definitely plan.
Alright.
I'm...
I'm pushing the payload, so you guys...
Yep, yep.
Got it.
Oh!
Never mind.
I exploded.
Oh shit!
I may or may not have exploded.
I think...
I should not have pushed up there.
So yeah, I'm coming back.
I don't know that...
I don't...
Okay, wait.
I'm gonna wait for you to...
Ice Cube and then I'll...
I'll bubble you.
Cuz I don't know that I actually...
Okay, I'll let you know.
I'm behind you.
Okay.
Cuz I'm saving it.
Alright, uh...
Oh yes, I can!
I can!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it does work.
Oh my god.
Me too.
There's so much.
There's so much damage.
Holy shit!
I...
I don't know how I live that long.
Ah!
There you guys too!
Roll away!
Roll away down to me!
He almost rolled away!
It was so close.
I can't accidentally roll off the edge, can I?
You can!
Absolutely can!
No!
Okay.
Nice.
I won't come in though.
Yeah.
That's so silly.
That would be so silly if you do.
Right!
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm so low.
I'm so...
It's okay.
I just...
It's overtime, right?
Oh no.
We didn't have anyone touching it.
Oh no, overtime.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's okay.
We just need...
I have more points to build.
More damage.
And then I'll live forever.
Yeah.
Oh shit, my damage is so low.
You were just rolling around.
You're too busy rolling.
No, I wasn't.
I was...
I need more power.
I need more ability.
I'm gonna see it.
Do I have enough?
Oh, five.
Okay.
Oh, I need the cooldown.
Cooldown reduction.
Uh...
I'll get that.
Oh yeah, I remember.
It was cooldown reduction.
And...
Weapon power.
Just lock in.
Just that easy.
I believe, BB.
I believe.
Okay.
Oop!
Boop!
Rolling, rolling.
Hey!
Check this out.
Woah.
Oh my God.
Look at you roll.
Oh wait, you can use that...
You...
You know you can use that to boot people as well.
Oh, really?
Like...
Push them off the map?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, if you're next to it.
Wait, no.
You're just trying to trick me, aren't you?
No, no.
I would never.
I would never do such a thing.
Doobie, do you trust me?
Yeah, I'll try it.
Well, I don't know if this map is anywhere to push people.
I have no idea what this map is.
I've never seen it before.
Okay, I got a lot of energy to go.
Okay.
Nice.
I have a hundred.
I'm gonna... Oh, wait.
It killed our Mercy.
Oh, no.
No!
Our entire team's dead!
It's not our fault.
It's not us.
Our Mercy died first, so it can't be us.
Yeah, true.
Okay, well, how did they die?
I think that Ryan just walked up to her.
I... I have... Literally just W, Keeter.
I'll stay near the first knee.
I'll try to help her.
Literally just W, Keeter.
I should, like, actually maybe use my...
...my shield to help my team instead of to work for myself.
I'm a little selfish with my abilities.
Ow!
Oh, my God.
I can't... I can't push up.
I'm so low.
Oh, you're so low.
Please help me.
Oh, I couldn't.
I... Oh, he was one.
I was just about to shield it.
I knew he got shattered, too.
If it was one second faster.
Do I just, like, bounce one as Mei?
I didn't know.
I think maybe?
I just freeze only, pretty much.
Oh, her freeze is a slow, though.
Her freeze is just a slow.
Oh, no, there's a bomb.
It doesn't do damage?
It does, but, like, it doesn't freeze anymore.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
All right.
Can anybody touch?
Oh...
It's okay.
This is where we turn it around.
This is where...
Yeah!
Yeah, right here.
This is our chance.
We turn it around right here.
Doki on tank.
Is she okay?
Zarya is, like, not really a tank, though.
She's, like, she's an off tank, so...
It's, like, more, uh...
Damage?
More damage, yeah.
She doesn't feel like a tank.
That's why I like playing her.
Okay.
I don't remember what this... What do I do for this?
King, weapon, lifesteal, ability?
Oh!
Wait, is lifesteal good?
That's what do I do?
At chat.
At chat's my grok now.
At chat, what do I do?
Uh...
Do I do weapon, lifesteal, or...?
Pierce.
I'll do lifesteal.
I'm ready.
I got it.
I'm ready, too.
Alright.
I'm ready.
We got this.
Pierce.
Yeah!
I haven't played this game mode.
Okay, I'm just gonna use my bubbles for my...
Oh my god!
R&T fucking died so fast.
That's crazy.
Well, she shouldn't be out there like that, right?
Yeah, like...
That...
That was sad.
Okay, I have a hundred, but like, I'm a little worried though.
Okay, we got him.
That's...
JK, I'm not worried anymore.
Okay.
We got it, we got it.
We got it, yeah.
I think we needed those...
The second ability power-ups for some of our team.
Yeah.
Yeah, we definitely did.
Also, I just realized our Kyoko is mostly DPSing, so...
Ohhhh, that explains a lot.
Yeah.
Yeah, I just see her like, literally just there.
DPSing a lot.
Oh, nobody's shooting me.
I like that.
Oh, he's so low.
What the fuck?
Did they die?
Oh yeah, they did.
Nice.
Where is everybody?
There's somebody here.
Where?
Oh, never mind.
Wait.
Where's here?
I got confused.
Oh, nice.
Nice shield.
Or nice wall.
Wait, where did I shot?
That's right.
Fuck you.
Oh, nice.
I got him.
I got him before...
Oh, nice.
I got a rise, too.
Oh.
You won't!
Stop the risk!
Okay, that was funny, though.
Wait, what?
I thought she was on the other side.
No, you walled it, so the wall made her go up, so then it was out of range for the rest.
That was funny.
I saw it live, too.
You didn't know.
Oh my god, mercy, please!
What is this?
I'm so resable!
Yeah, I like the meatball roll from Doobie too.
It's so silly.
Yeah, I like pushing people.
It's fun.
Yeah, it's so silly.
It's such a silly ability.
Alright, I'm gonna back out.
I don't wanna get involved with that.
Not gonna lie.
Okay, I have shield.
Alright, go meatball, go!
No, this is calculated.
I'm holding them off.
Yeah.
Okay, I knew he was gonna do that.
Oh my god.
Please, please.
No!
Oh, we won it!
Oh, they got us!
They see that!
Let's go!
I pushed them!
Yay!
I saw the C9.
Woohoo!
They all like ran to me and you walled them off.
Oh my god.
Yes, guys.
Look at that.
See?
Wait, so that's good?
Yeah, that's good.
Good wall?
Yeah, that was a good wall.
They all like ran to me and they couldn't get back to the actual...
actual point.
Okay, weapon power.
Okay.
What would my ability power do?
I should get like cooldown reduction actually.
No, I'll just go all in.
Weapon power.
Alright.
Look at this.
D&D on top.
Wait.
Wait, which one is...
Oh, I can get more meatball.
Oh, that's true.
You can do like cooldown reduction so you can meatball all the time.
Yeah.
Shoot.
Unlimited.
I don't think I have that one.
Unlimited meatballs.
Wait, where's cooldown reduction?
Let me see.
There should be an ability power and weapon power.
It's called...
It's in the rare.
Um, the rare one is multi-tool.
Oh.
And, uh, icy coolant.
Second row blue for weapon and ability.
Okay.
Oh, I see.
Three.
Two.
One.
Zero.
Okay.
Alright, we got this.
I believe.
Unlimited meatballs.
Yeah.
I believe.
Meatballed.
Alright.
I'm moving up.
Wee.
My god, soldier.
You're gonna fucking insta-die if you run like that.
In three.
Two.
Oh.
I can't go!
Why?!
You're...
Which...
Rated.
Oh, nice.
That's such a good.
Aw.
Nice.
I got him.
B buff.
That's right.
Mercy.
I got her.
Oh no, Murky.
Murky.
Murky, Murky, Murky, Murky, please.
Please heal our Kiriko dead.
Please, hit me.
Hit me.
Nice.
Oh, I got him, I got him.
Nice teamwork.
Nice.
Come on.
Is this a real?
Are you real?
Yeah, you're real.
So, Kiriko has a build where she can send to a clone of her.
I didn't know which one was the real one.
Oh, okay.
That's why I always see Kiriko dying.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Does her clone show up in the feed?
Yeah, her clone shows up too.
Oh, wait, yes!
You blocked him!
We both body blocked him.
This is it.
Okay, let's go.
Good job, Melon Make Milkers.
Um, it's best of four.
We go to four rounds.
Like, whoever wins four rounds, basically.
It's not best of four.
I don't know numbers.
Oh, now we can do more builds.
There's a cast.
One additional ally.
Oh!
Yeah!
I want over healthy.
Oh yeah, we have Melon Milkers and Booba.
You're right, chat.
Perfect.
Yeah.
Of course, Mercy's the...
Melon Milkers.
I want to do...
I want to do it so, like, we have double shields.
Oh!
We got this.
See, the more points we build...
The more points we have, the more we can build better stuff.
And it can change the game.
Yay!
We got this, I believe.
Oh, okay.
I believe in us, doobie.
Wait, my chat is telling me to buy...
I don't know how to do this.
So much information.
Fuck!
No!
Did you get it?
I don't know.
Shit, I don't know.
Sorry.
Uh, yeah.
Yeah, we totally got it.
I think it's fine.
Yeah, yeah, we're so...
We're healthy.
Oh...
Oh my god.
I have 70% ability power.
So, I should sell my green ones to buy purple ones.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
I wasn't looking.
You have no tank.
No tanks, by the way.
Oh.
That's awkward.
Oh, we lost our Mercy.
Yeah, we sort of heavily...
Oh, we lost everybody?
Hey, don't...
Oh!
Oh my god!
That's what a ride was!
Goodbye!
I got you, I got you!
I got you again!
I don't got you again!
Bro, that guy chased you everywhere!
I was scared of jumping off.
But maybe I should've jumped.
Oh my...
Bro, that guy followed you.
They hate me.
My meatball.
They really didn't like your meatball though.
Oh my god.
I'm alive somehow.
I don't know how.
I'm alive.
Okay.
Nice.
I'm pushing up.
Ha, ha, ha.
Ha, ha.
Oh my god.
There's so many things.
Okay, I'm capping point though.
That's right.
Give me my energy!
Okay.
The healers are back here, distracted.
Yeah, that's good.
Are they still distracted?
Cold.
Uh, yeah.
I walled off kind of.
Free.
Oh, yes.
Poop him!
He hates us!
Ha, ha, ha!
Woohoo!
We're doing it!
Okay.
I have so much energy right now.
It's actually crazy.
Are you okay over there?
Oh, we lost.
Yeah, we lost him.
Why was he over there though?
Uh...
What the fuck is he doing?
Oh my god!
What the...
Oh.
I think he was trying to kill Svolger.
Okay, I have...
Oh, nice.
That's a good freeze.
Nice.
That's a fucking...
Did I kill him with my meatball?
I think I might have.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
You're walled up.
Sorry.
No, it's fine.
I'm okay.
Oh my god.
We're figuring it out.
We know how to play our comp now.
What the fuck are these guys doing?
Yeah.
Come on.
I know you have a...
Oh, wait.
Okay.
He's just dead.
I...
Honestly, I thought he would...
Oh, no!
It's fine.
I have...
Nice.
Oh, you pooped him up!
Woohoo!
Yeah.
I can't.
Was there Ryan?
That's a good...
I don't know what the Ryan was doing.
The Ryan was trying to have fun.
Yeah, I need more ability power.
He was 1v1-ing me.
Yeah, I saw he was running...
He was chasing you everywhere.
I was like, what the fuck is he doing?
Hey, he's like, get away!
Leave us alone!
He loves my meat.
Yeah, he wants your meat!
Alright, 15...
Oh, 20%.
Alright, I'm gonna take that.
More weapon...
Look at my weapon power.
How do I...
Oh.
And press tab.
And then...
You can see it.
And left click.
Oh, yeah, I see.
Yeah.
Eighty-five percent.
Yeah, I'm super fucking tanky right now.
I know I get...
I'm not tanky.
I'm super fucking strong.
Y'all just won your meatball.
Oh, shoot.
I gotta pick my thing.
Oh, no.
You have 14 seconds.
Okay.
Hey, guys.
Just buy that.
Stadium mode is really fun, guys.
Compared to normal Overwatch chat.
It's just more so, like...
The games are a lot faster.
And...
You're not held hostage.
Huh.
That's my favorite part.
And you can change your builds pretty quickly, right?
Yeah.
Like, if you sell stuff, you can just change it out for something else?
Yeah, if you think, like, something's not working, you can just change your build.
In between rounds.
Which is something I like.
Thank you.
Oh, he's using lava now.
There you go.
Roll, meatball.
Roll.
Roll, my meatball.
Oh, my God.
I'm dead.
Oh, no.
That's what...
A lot of damage.
Yeah, that was alive.
Oh, we got it, though.
We're getting it, right?
Oh, no.
No.
Oh, my God.
I'm still alive.
Somehow.
I'm alive.
I don't know how.
Where's that mercy?
I'm just gonna push for it.
Oh, what?
Oh, we lost the...
That's fine.
It's fine.
Don't look at him.
Yeah.
It's fine.
Ouch!
It's okay.
We're still healthy.
Oh, my God.
I almost died.
It's okay.
I don't know where the fuck the Ryan is.
That's like the...
Oh, there he is.
He's showing...
Oh, my God.
What?
He did so much damage to me.
That's actually crazy.
Oh, you're gonna rez.
Yeah.
But the damage was insane.
Wait, where did he go?
Where did the Ryan go?
Oh, no!
I did not.
Oh, I died.
I was about to wall off his...
Oh, my God.
What?
I did not realize he was...
He was close to shatter.
I did not save my barrier for that.
Have you ever been...
Have you ever been sponsored to play Overwatch?
Oh, yeah.
I have.
That's how I found out about the stadium.
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
Ah.
Yeah, that's why I was like...
Oh!
Stadium mode.
Oh, no.
Not...
Okay.
I might be dead here.
Because there's this little mini Bob that's trying...
Yes!
Ah!
It's the mini Bob.
I didn't know where to go.
Oops.
I booped her out of the thing.
Oh, no.
I was dead already.
That's fine.
I was already dead.
Oh.
That's okay.
Oh, no.
Everybody die!
No!
Oh, this is a close game.
Are the...
Are the abilities...
Is it a full refund if you sell?
I think so, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
For sure.
It is.
Okay.
I'm on the point.
Okay, I got the...
I got the Kiriko.
I got two!
I got three!
Oh, nice!
Oh!
Oh, huge!
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
Why the fuck did you give the...
Okay.
I have ult for this.
I have ult.
I'm gonna push up a little.
I don't know how the fuck I killed two people there.
I don't know what the fuck they were doing.
Nice.
He gave me energy.
That's what I like to see.
Oh my god, nice!
Stop
it!
I like the...
The grab...
And then you just rolled in around them.
Yeah, there's like an upgrade you can get where the meatball explodes.
Oh!
That's what you did!
The ball of doom.
Yeah.
What the fuck did this...
Oh wait, I forgot they did...
Had one punch man.
Crossover.
What the fuck did he do?
Yeah.
I was like, that's bad skin.
Oh my god, yeah, he killed Kiriko twice.
Oh, okay, that was good.
That was a good shot.
You probably had a better play than that.
When you had three kills...
That's true.
When you clutched it, I mean...
Yeah, that's true.
I guess because we won, they don't want to give you another win.
Mm-hmm.
We were just too good, you know?
They're like, we gotta give them something.
Yeah.
Ours was an actual combo.
We had like...
We had like teamwork and everything.
We were like working together.
There?
Okay, now you can experiment with those.
Maybe that's why they resist.
Yeah.
Okay, now you can.
What?
Let's see.
I like mage, pretty fun.
Oh yeah, I like the...
Oh, Reaper has a really funny one.
Where he...
Every time he TP's...
Oh.
We get games so fast.
But Reaper has a thing where everything he...
Every time he TP's, he does like a death blossom.
Like a mini death blossom.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, it's...
Pretty funny.
That...
Sounds...
Annoying to go again.
Yeah, yeah!
Oh, we're both DPS.
Oh.
You don't play Reaper?
Uh...
I feel like we need range though.
I can try Reaper.
True.
Okay.
I'll try it.
It's probably fine.
Yeah, it'll be fine.
Maybe.
We'll be okay.
Is that like the ability you can get early on with the...
Yeah, it's one of the powers.
Or later game.
It's powers.
So like...
Um...
It's always there.
Oh yeah.
I love Soldier 24 skin.
Cause I can actually see his face.
these.
All right.
Oh my god.
They're full range.
Okay.
I might just have to bully their right.
They're watching the stream, they countered us!
They countered us!
Oh dear, they...
I have more lifestyle.
And then...
Maybe more weapon power...
Or attack speed.
No fun for Rhyne, exactly.
You're just the nearest ally.
Guys, what should I do?
Chat.
Renewal is safe?
Okay.
Where the fuck is Renewal?
Oh.
10% of your life.
Oh, okay.
When I Rafe, I get my HP back.
Alright, I'm ready.
I'm almost ready.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I believe.
We got this.
That's great.
I'd assume more people would play DPS.
We got...
You've always been DPS in all the rounds.
Oh, somebody says in chat...
Oh, wait, I see.
Hold on.
Is there a D.Va in the tanks?
I don't know, actually.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Okay, goodbye.
Ryan is so low though.
We got him.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god.
You're all so far away.
How am I supposed to...
I just have a shotgun.
What am I supposed to do?
You're all too far away.
Goodbye.
What?
You know what?
I'll fucking go after a ride.
Oh.
Whoa!
Never mind.
You can stay there.
Oh, wait, wait.
Weeeee.
I'll just die, die, die.
Oh.
Wait.
Kind of for them.
Yeah, I don't think you're having fun.
Wait, what the fuck?
What are you doing here?
Wait, both supports were up here.
Oh.
Maybe they're throwing.
Goodbye.
My Oshidoki bird is on the other team.
I must help her.
We gotta throw.
We gotta raise her win rate.
Oh.
Okay.
No!
You're la- Don't worry, I believe!
There's us.
You're gonna get rezzed!
Oh, fuck!
It's okay.
It's not gonna hit- I got hit.
Oh, he shattered us.
Are you still alive?
I have so many ultimates.
They used everything.
No, I just rezzed.
I mean, I just respawned.
It's okay.
We have your ult.
Yeah.
I'll wait.
It's not fair.
Yeah.
They all- They all just like walk away from me.
It's not fair.
What do I do when they just walk backwards?
How am I- What am I supposed to do that?
Oh, yeah.
All I have is my shotgun.
Oh, now we can get closer.
It's okay.
I got your revenge.
Wait, they just walked away from you.
That's awkward.
Where did he go?
What's this beam?
Oh, it's the Juno ult.
Oh.
It's okay.
No!
I didn't see the Juno!
Juno is behind me!
Ah!
What?
No!
Wait, I feel like we got so many kills, but we still lost it.
I know!
I didn't see the Juno beside- behind me, because I was trying to kill their cast.
Oh, it had ult too!
I should've just ulted.
Steam!
Okay, I can ult on point and then die with my ult.
Oh no, I don't think I can touch point.
Oh, I just got on point!
What?
No!
I tried!
I should've gone faster too.
Yeah, I just got there.
Oh damn!
Sad.
I feel like you consistently get the MVP card.
Yeah, I'm farming damage.
Sounds like you're a pro or something!
I'm just farming damage.
Alright, I need more weapon power, I'm pretty sure.
Can I have fort?
Oh, I can.
I'll just take away...
I'll get the cooldown too.
Okay.
It's just not- it just has two ranged characters, so all I can do is just slowly go up to them.
As I shotgun- do firing shotgun.
Yeah.
I think it kind of works if I'm walling them off and then you're able to get closer.
Oh, that's true.
Otherwise they're able to just kick us off.
We can try doing that to the Rhine.
We can both just walk up- walk up to the Rhine and try that.
Let's just make sure the Rhine doesn't have a good time.
Okay, I'll try to wall them off.
Yeah.
I've been flanking so I'll just do front line instead.
Wait, what do you mean?
Okay.
Like, can you remember when I was- Do you wall off the Rhine?
Do I like- Yeah.
Remember when I was Zarya?
Like, section him off from his team?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So when I was Zarya, you kept walling him away from his team and then I just killed him.
I can do that, but as we're free too.
Alright, let's go.
We'll just do front line either.
I'll stop nanking.
Okay.
That's why we're strategizing now.
Oh, nice!
Okay.
Oh my god.
This Rhine is actually just walking.
He's so scared.
Oh my god.
Nice, nice block.
There we go.
Oh!
It worked!
It's working!
Okay, I'm backing away.
It can have that.
Hello.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my god.
I didn't expect it either.
That's a good wall.
He's low.
He's so low!
Oh, nice!
Nice meatball!
Oh my god.
I'm so scared though.
No!
I got charged!
He charged me!
No, really!
No!
I got charged!
It's only you.
It's only you and the Mercy.
I got pinned!
My beautiful urge!
Heals to me!
They know.
You're our power strat.
Power card.
Oh my god.
I'm so fucking...
Just a little baby.
Not fair.
Oh my god.
I'm literally like a miniature tank right now.
Oh, I knew it.
I knew he was gonna do that too.
Oh my god.
Oh, he's frozen.
No!
It's okay.
Amura got...
I didn't think...
Oh okay.
Nice.
The castle was so large.
I wasn't expecting how large the castle was.
Where the fuck is the run?
I'm a little scared, because I'm like, oh, there he is.
Oh my god, he's so fat.
Oh my god!
Okay, I'm feeding now.
I'm feeding.
I believe in you, Doobie.
Carry this.
I'm just feeding.
Oh, okay.
I'm inting.
Reaper's not the pick.
He is absolutely not the pick, guys.
It does seem like you need more ranged characters for this.
Yeah.
100%.
He got shatter, too.
I knew it.
I knew he had shatter.
Reload.
I got the ride.
Oh my god, I'm dead blossom.
I'm gonna stay on point.
I don't trust our team.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh.
That was scary.
I have ult here.
Alright, we got it.
I hope we don't see nine.
Okay.
They almost got the lead.
I have ult.
No.
Why would we do that?
Yeah.
That would be so awkward if that happens, guys.
That's it.
I don't care.
As long as the Rhyme dies, that's all that matters.
It was worth it.
I got the Rhyme.
It was so worth it.
Please.
It's just Soldier and Mercy.
And Mora and...
Okay.
Maybe it wasn't worth it.
Oh, it was!
Nice trade.
Nice.
Nice, nice.
It was worth it.
I knew it.
It's kind of stressful.
Too much stuff happening.
It's so intense.
All the abilities.
Oh my god.
What do we do?
Okay.
Attack power.
Always weapon power.
Maybe cooldown?
Okay.
Guys.
What do I do for power?
Double my lifesteal for three seconds?
I don't use Shadow Step, though.
Maybe...
Grant's attack speed for one second.
Cooldown?
I don't have time.
Guys, I don't have time.
There's no cooldown!
It's Mike getting that.
I don't know what to get.
I couldn't get the thing I wanted to.
Okay.
It's okay.
We have the next round.
Yeah.
Oh, do people still play?
People still play like normal ranked mode in this game, right?
Yeah, they still play, yeah.
Like a regular or what?
Yeah, but it's dive meta.
Do you?
Do you play?
No, I just play stadium.
It's just...
It's cause it's dive meta right now, so like...
I ain't about that.
No!
Okay, to be fair...
To be fair, like...
I like...
I was just letting it happen.
I was walking up there and be like, You're not gonna...
You're not gonna fucking charge me.
I'm just a guy.
Oh wait, we got a res.
I'm just...
Yeah, just a little reaper.
I'm just a little reaper.
Nice.
Aw, they capped though.
This reaper...
This Ryan is so annoying.
No!
Again?
I didn't think he...
I didn't think he had charge.
I...
I raped in front of him.
Cause I was like, I'll be fine.
It's like one of those things where...
Yeah.
Oh my god.
The abilities have like the less cooldown.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure he has cooldown reduction there.
No, this is a good Ryan though.
This Ryan is really good.
And very annoying.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
And then there's the fucking Juno.
that I have to worry about too.
I wish I had range right now.
I hate this non-range hit.
What?
All I can do is just shoot his shield.
If we go right side, maybe...
I think I have to flank.
I have to flank and try and get a pick, I think.
Yeah.
Like, I can't just shoot the shield.
I can't just shoot the shield.
Oh, we couldn't get it.
Ah.
Unlucky.
That round was so fast.
I know.
Ah.
I wish...
I wish I could do more.
Next up...
I have to flank.
I can't fight this Ryan.
He has too much resources.
The teams are gearing up.
Okay.
I can do another weapon power.
Oh, if we can upgrade something.
Yeah.
We can try and...
fix this.
We need to fix this.
Uh...
Wait.
Do I have a...
No.
Okay.
I...
This.
And then...
A 55% weapon power now.
Can we fix it?
Nice.
Alright.
I'm gonna go flank.
We don't need armor.
Armor is for pussies, guys.
Yeah.
We just need a kill.
It's all about kills.
I can do this.
I'll just flank.
You...
Your mission is to survive.
My mission is to flank.
Amazing.
Yeah.
Wait, what?
I love that voice line.
Survive.
Yeah, survive.
Doobie, survive.
Amazing.
Alright.
Yeah, I have to like...
Run away from their Ryan.
Their Ryan is actually just fucking...
Hunting me down.
Uh-huh.
I'll try to distract him in the front.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna go on the side.
Oh, he saw me.
Oh.
Oh my god.
He's one!
No!
Their soldier was one!
Ah!
But he had like...
Oh.
He had to double.
He double helixed me.
You guys got this!
I just...
Yes!
I'm coming back.
Don't worry.
Now that the Ryan is dead.
The Rape...
Oh.
We are.
Our Junker is dead.
No.
Wait, it's fine.
Nice.
Nice wall.
Wait, what you got, Rose?
Yeah.
They have vaults.
Right?
No.
No, no, no.
He shouldn't.
Not that.
No.
I'm sorry.
The soldier looked like he was getting ready to maybe try.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's fine.
I don't want to deal with the...
With the Rai.
You guys can deal with him.
Ah!
Are you serious?
Oh my god, the cast is one.
Nice.
Whaaat?
So much damage.
Oh!
Please let me...
Die, die him.
Nice.
Nice, I got the soldier.
No!
Oh my god, he almost charged me.
I got him.
What?
No!
That's why I killed him.
Are you gonna rest?
Nice.
Oh, thank god.
That scared me.
Oh, we got this.
Yeah, we got it.
I'll stay on the point.
So we can cap.
Nice.
Don't let him get near.
Don't let the Rai touch.
Please.
Anything but the Rai.
Get out of here, Juno.
We got him.
Oh, thank god.
Oh, wow.
Our Junker Queen did so much.
She did 6k damage.
That's great.
Wait, what the fuck?
What was she shooting?
Oh, nice.
The Rai is actually solo carrying the team though.
Like, 46k points.
That's...
That's so much.
Alright.
More...
More weapon power.
Um...
I could do cooldown reduction.
So I can Wraith more.
And then...
Weapon power.
Uh...
Um...
Ability power.
Not...
I'm gonna...
Mm...
I feel like...
The death step...
The mini Death Blossom might not be that good.
If I'm...
Trying to use it to flank.
I don't care about my team enough to heal my teammates.
I'm just not close enough to you guys!
You guys are not close to me to get healed.
Someone in the chat says, Overwatch has a buy menu now.
This is the new mode.
Yeah, it's the future.
Stadium.
The future of Overwatch.
Yeah.
Next genre.
I think it's more than ever be like a pro type of...
Pro stadium?
...level, like a casting.
You can all get casted or like a tournament or something.
I think they put more resources into it.
It's fun though.
I think stadium is like more fun in general.
But it could be like super messy.
It would be like so fast though.
Like these games are super fast compared to like the real game.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
Yeah, because I feel like the games go by a lot faster in general.
Oh my god, not the ride.
Don't let me get near the ride.
Please.
Can't flank.
They won't let me flank.
Nice.
I saw the Mora.
There she is.
Oh my god.
I'm still alive somehow.
Oh my god, let me come out.
Ah!
Oh.
It's OK.
I'm leaving.
I'm not looking at the ride.
Support, stop peeling!
Stop!
No!
Not the ride!
I went down!
No, Ryan is just following us.
Hey, doobie.
I like how we both just like ran away.
Nice.
Okay.
No!
Stupid Ryan!
Ryan fucked up my... Oh, okay.
And then he just did that.
He just killed everybody.
Aww, I had such a good ult!
I'm so sad.
I'm just playing hide and seek with him.
We'll get it back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I believe.
I'm just gonna flank here.
I don't wanna get near him.
I've been trying to distract him.
It was easier on the first area, but... Yeah.
Oh, our... No, our tank.
I can't pull DPS!
Don't let him get near me!
Alright, dead.
Okay, I got... I got two.
I got three.
Oh my god, there we go.
Nice!
That's right.
We have one.
Can't run away from me!
Oh my god, there he is.
Oh my god, there's...
I got one!
He doesn't know I'm here.
Oh my god, he does!
Oh, I got him!
I got Cas.
Nice!
Oh, I got...
Not nice.
Not!
No!
Oh my god, I got him!
Oh my god, I'm downloading Reaper.
I've downloaded him.
I don't know how I'm living.
It just took a while.
Yeah, it just took a while.
I figured it out.
My algorithm only gets stronger.
With more new data.
I'm just like Grok.
The Doki AI.
The Doki AI, yeah.
I'm locked in now.
Overwatch does look different now.
Like, the abilities are different.
I don't know if that's because I haven't played too much Overwatch 2, or if it just looks different in this game mode.
I think, like, it's like less cluttered too, I feel like, in general.
Let's see.
I don't need advanced.
Wait, what's that?
Okay, we need more weapon power.
We always need more weapon power.
Okay, now I should be unstoppable.
What is everybody else's build?
Jesus Christ.
Their soldier is so ta- Um...
The soldier in Mora has, like, insane ability power.
Aw.
Like, the soldier in Helix Rocket does so much damage because of it.
Yeah, yeah.
Reinhardt's, um, his little- What is that?
The strike?
Yeah.
There's so much damage.
It's scary.
It's so, like, he can, like, basically one-shot with it too.
That's why it's so fucking scary.
Yeah, that's- That's how I died.
That's why- Yeah, that's why I stopped fighting him.
I was like, you can- You can deal with Reinhardt.
I'm just gonna go in the backline.
I'm just gonna fly away now.
Hey, don't worry.
You have your meatball.
You'll be safe in that.
You'll be safe in your meatball.
Don't worry.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm a little tankier, so...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I believe.
I'll take it.
I believe in you.
Oh, I should've kept my- I should've kept my- Oh my god!
The Rein is purposely- He's coming for me.
He's actually coming for me.
He's dead.
Oh, nice.
No more fear.
No fear now.
Oh, sorry.
I pushed him away.
My bad.
Oh, it's fine.
I pushed one away.
Wait, no one's capping.
No one's capping.
Oh my god, it's fine.
We got one.
I think it's got it.
Is that English?
Okay, I'm going behind them.
We got it.
Are you guys okay?
Oh.
You guys might not be okay.
No!
You got killed, you fucking cheater!
What's that like?
Oh my god, they're all playing together now.
So it's harder.
Oh!
Fucking speed away!
I didn't have to push him back!
Teleport away!
I am so far!
I'm so far!
I'm so far from this!
How did that hit me?
That's fine.
Oh!
I'm getting red.
It's okay.
Hello.
Welcome back.
I...
They all ran away from my ult.
That's okay.
Oh my god.
I'm okay.
I'm still vaguely okay.
I don't know.
Wow.
We got 1099.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's all that matters.
I am still alive somehow.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Stop healing him!
Is everybody okay?
I don't know what this is.
I'm so dead.
I'm so dead here.
I'm so dead!
I'm so alive!
I just noticed this Ryan's name.
Wait, what is this Ryan?
Oh my god.
I'm so dead.
I am not gonna live here.
I'm actually not gonna live.
Thank you.
JK.
We're almost there.
I don't understand.
They won't let me get close.
Where is the...
Oh, there is one.
Oh my god.
Please.
Nice!
No!
I got two!
You guys got this!
Oh my god!
Nice bunny hop!
No!
Oh!
He's low!
No!
I got him!
I'm a hero!
What?
He's living forever!
There's one chick left, right?
I...
I got him!
Oh, you guys got it, yeah.
Moira's back!
I got him too!
Jesus Christ!
Okay!
We did it!
Oh, easy!
Okay, that's good!
We did it!
Yeah!
Oh!
I don't know!
I lived for so long!
Like, I literally was just playing, like, mouse and cat, like, everywhere!
You should see my P.O.P.
I was literally running around the map!
I don't know how I lived!
Oh, the Ryan got to play in the game!
Okay, no, he deserved it!
That guy was fucking crazy!
Like, like, like, I- Look how far away it was!
I was literally- Sweating!
All the way on the- At the edge!
At the end of that ult!
Yeah, like, all the- That's crazy how far it went!
Yeah, that was a fucking crazy range!
Holy sh- Oh my god!
We've been playing for four hours!
Yeah!
Fuck!
That was fun though!
Cause we're flying so fast!
You wanna do LG?
You should try tank!
For LG!
What's that?
Oh, last game!
What's LG?
Oh, that means last game!
You should try tank!
Cause you didn't get a chance to do tank!
I'll play!
Alright!
I'll do support and- If I get support and then the range is like crazy, that'd be good!
Actually, no, I shouldn't do that to you!
Alright!
I'll QS and DAT- I'll Q DPS!
Okay!
Alright!
Let's go LG!
Oh, I got my- My rank and DPS!
Oh!
What's your rank?
They're ranked up, I think!
Oh!
Yeah, you start from bronze, right?
Yeah, yeah!
Oh, you ranked up!
I think it went up once!
Oh!
Nice!
I think so!
Alright!
Maybe!
I'm still not sure how it works!
I believe you!
I believe in you!
Alright, I'll do CAS again!
What are you gonna do?
Orisa?
I don't know...
I kinda wanna play Orisa or D.Va.
I'm not sure...
Is there D.Va?
Oh, the D.Va is in there!
Yeah!
I'll let chat pick!
Yeah, chat!
Yeah!
Pick for Doobie!
No, they're gonna pick a D.Va.
Cause...
Of all the, you know...
Oh!
Your little minions!
What do they want?
Minion sounds like a nickname for them.
Like, it's not like their actual name.
How about...
What do you think of that chat?
Alright, minions!
Minbies!
So it's like min...
Let's game minions!
Let's game my minions!
I'm gonna read all these abilities.
Alright.
I don't even remember what was good.
Attack speed...
Ability?
Power?
Is it Deadman Walking?
Yeah.
Min birds?
Mini Ds?
God!
Mini Ds!
I feel like it's too many syllables.
That's true.
It's like...
I don't know, it sounds...
Hello, D.Vs.
It sounds like a...
Offensive or something.
The D.Vs!
What does it sound like to you?!
Well, growing up, my brother used to be like...
I don't know, I don't even know what I'm saying.
What do we say?
I'm calling me, kind of.
It's like... you make a noise and it implies something like...
It's messed up!
Wait, I forgot to buy something.
Oh no, it's too late.
You're gonna go in, go in, take.
Go in raw.
Alright, I believe in you.
Wait, I am tank, I forgot.
Okay.
Oh, they went D.Va.
They're like...
Oh, I got their cast.
Haha!
Oh, they got rezzed.
No more, haha.
Oh my god, he has the power up where there's like million names.
Namura!
I'm just damage farming.
Oh, the castle so... No!
Yeah!
There's our healer.
I don't know!
Where did she go?
I don't even know where she went.
Nice Genji skin.
I feel like when they got rid of loot boxes, the skins like...
got upgraded so much.
To be fair, you need to pay real money for them.
Yeah.
They have to look really good so people will actually spend money.
Of course they go D.Va when I'm fucking hit skin.
Have you bought a skin?
Nah.
I haven't bought skins other than Fortnite skins.
Because it's like...
I had a problem.
I actually...
Oh my god.
Fucking D.Va.
Stupid mech.
Now I know why people hate D.Va as a hit scan.
But I had an actual problem with spending money when it comes to cosmetics.
Yeah.
And then I spent so much on Overwatch loot boxes.
Uh...
Wow.
And like...
Where I would spend like...
Maybe like...
A hundred dollars.
Per like...
Yeah.
Per event or some shit.
And it was so...
It was so bad.
Um...
And then...
You know...
Overwatch started dying.
And I realized like...
Wait.
That was such a waste of money.
So I...
I managed to stop spending...
I like...
Made myself stop spending money for cosmetics.
Other than...
Other than Fortnite.
Because Fortnite is actually...
Pretty silly.
I like the Fortnite skins more.
Yeah.
Fortnite's all about the skins.
I felt like that too.
Like Fortnite's all about like the memes and stuff.
And like the dances and emotes.
And Overwatch is like...
I don't really...
Especially Overwatch because it's like first person.
So I don't see the skins too.
A lot.
Unless you play third person.
But...
That doesn't count.
Yeah, that's true.
Yeah, that's a good point.
With Fortnite, you can see your skin.
Like at all times.
That's...
Oh my god.
I whiffed.
Oh, the Cassidy's so low.
I know.
I got the 1hp.
And then I whiffed.
I whiffed.
The moment.
The most important moment.
Wait, that's a...
Oh.
Nevermind.
We lost both our supports.
Yeah, we went.
I was gonna say.
If you tied the bomb, you're fat.
And then both our supports die.
Holy shit.
That's unlucky.
Quick, someone...
Maybe because I didn't...
I didn't back up.
So maybe they didn't back up.
I don't know.
Quick, someone swapped to Strange.
Swapped to Strange at TPS.
Yes.
Do they...
There's nobody in this game that has like portal abilities.
Are there?
No.
Symmetra.
And me?
Yeah.
But do people really play her?
No.
I wish I could play Symmetra right now.
God, I can't believe it.
Why didn't you go diva?
I can't have fun!
No, we're gonna upgrade our stuff.
And we're gonna get them.
Yeah.
Yeah, we're gonna fucking get them.
Yeah, I'll do lifesteal here.
Oh, ammo.
I almost forgot ammo was important here.
Uh, what?
Guys, where is ammo in?
Is ammo in...
Is it a weapon?
Oh, there it is.
Uh...
I'll get more ammo.
The arena is ready and waiting.
20 seconds to go.
Uh...
I don't even remember what OG Symmetra was like.
Me neither.
Yeah!
Does she still have the little turret things?
Her kid...
I don't remember.
No, I...
Don't remember.
She...
I remember her kid...
Her kid changed like four different times.
Yeah.
I don't remember.
It's been so long.
What was she like before?
A microwave...
Oh, yeah!
Her...
Left leg used to follow you.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it was like a...
Uh...
Microwave.
Hurts at one HP.
Did it really?
Oh, my God.
That sounds terrible.
It sounds like a...
This Cassidy is so lucky he doesn't have a fucking D.Va on his ass.
I wish that were me.
Oh, my God.
Stupid.
I see you, Mercy.
Oh, nice.
We got the Mercy.
Get that stupid baby D.Va.
Alright, we got him.
Yeah.
Okay, it's just...
That D.Va being a problem.
Oh, that thingy over there.
That D.Va...
He's blocking all my shots.
Yeah, but I feel...
I feel like my upgrades help with...
Against her.
Yeah, it does.
I'm not going back up there.
There's like five people there.
I'm like...
Holy shit.
That's not fair.
They're playing together like a team or something.
It's not fair.
Okay, nice.
What the fuck?
There was that Mercy over there too.
Oh, my God.
They're not letting me push up.
Wait.
If you guys can...
Goddammit.
Defense make tricks.
Ooh.
Oh, no!
Damage out of nowhere.
No!
Mercy!
Get out of here.
Oh, my God, no.
Oh, no.
No, I died.
Stop getting it.
She got Battle Mercy.
No!
And then she rezzed.
Oh, my God.
I worked so hard for that kill.
I...
I found the hammer and everything.
What the fuck?
Oh, my...
That's unlucky.
This is not fair.
Oh, my God, please!
I just...
Respond!
Stupid defense matrix shit.
I can't push that.
I'm just a little guy.
I'm here.
I can't push it.
Where the fuck is our Genji blade?
Serious?
Where's the ship?
Damnit!
Nobody's here.
Okay.
Okay, I got it.
I get...
Here we go.
Get out of here.
Get out of here!
Alright.
Nice.
Oh, wait.
There's someone on point.
Huh?
We got it.
Nice.
And we got Jared in overtime.
Yeah!
We win that round!
Oh, thank God.
Thank fucking God.
I got scared there.
We gotta win our last one!
Yes.
We gotta win our LG.
Oh, my God.
Our D.Va is so free, too.
Because of our...
Alright.
I mean, that's...
I guess, like...
Yeah, it's all about strategizing, because we can't counterpick, so we have to fucking figure out our builds in general.
After using combat...
I can imagine for, like, higher level stuff, it gets crazy.
Yeah.
Guys, what do I do?
I don't know.
At...
At Grok, what do I do?
Do I have nothing?
No.
I need weapons.
Oh...
It's a fierce competition.
Who will cave to the pressure?
And who will come out on top?
Okay.
Win.
Haha.
Guys.
Oh.
There's armor pierce?
Easy clap.
Just win.
Doki.
Okay.
But what do I do for a power, guys?
Action begins.
Commander click.
The fuck is that?
Guys, that's nothing in here.
Okay.
Uh...
Oh, shoot.
I'm gonna do auto-aim.
I don't have to think about aiming now.
Oh, damn it.
Haha, you couldn't figure out two.
Pick the one that let you win.
I was gonna buy, like, one more thing, but then it's fine.
It's fine.
It's okay.
Just like a small item thingy.
Yeah, we don't need it.
We're too good for it.
I don't even remember what ability power-up thingy I picked.
It's okay.
We'll read it next round, you know?
We'll just read it next round.
I'm still...
It's hard...
It's a lot to absorb.
Playing this game mode for the first time.
What the hell?
Oh my god!
They all came back?!
No!
No, it's okay!
I deserved that!
No, I deserved it!
I didn't...
I...
I don't know.
I thought they would stop giving a fuck about the Ash, but...
I...
They...
Rez the Ash and their entire team came back to protect the Rez.
Check.
Ah...
Like...
It's like they're, like, calming or some shit.
I bet you the Ash was screaming and the microphone be like...
They're like, he's...
Kill him!
He's right there!
There's no way!
Fuck you!
Six...
Six players not in voice comps!
It's insane that shit!
There's no way an entire team just looked at it.
Yeah, but maybe they're also, like, uh...
Maybe stacking.
Isn't the Q in this game, it's like, if you're in a stack, you go against...
Ah, sometimes.
I'm like, getting away from these people.
It's a lot of damage.
Not always.
And then Rez.
I'm dying so fast!
Oh!
Fucking knew.
I fucking knew you were gonna Rez.
I...
Knew it.
Oh my god.
All they do is Rez.
No!
Oh my god.
They are...
Stop protecting them!
We both got killed by mercy!
It's okay.
I believe in our team.
I feel like, as a tank, I'm not doing that good.
Sorry.
No, you're doing fine.
It's...
It's hard to stay alive.
Oh.
What?
Oh my god.
How?
What?
Where...
Seven...
I was...
Okay.
My...
What?
I like, actually disappeared for some reason.
I...
That's...
Okay.
I wish you saw what happened to me.
It was actually crazy.
It was crazy.
Okay.
I killed...
I sacrificed myself for this.
So like...
This might...
We might win this one area.
I...
Okay.
Wait.
I wish you saw what I saw with the D.Va bomb.
It was actually bullshit.
Oh.
I like, disappeared from existence.
Alright.
It's not over yet.
I hear no bell.
Yep.
Yeah.
I hear no bell.
Fucking clear side D.Va's here.
Is that Mercy?
Like...
Yeah.
I was gonna say.
There you go.
She's low, she's low.
I got her.
Oh my god.
No!
I almost killed the cat.
It lasted for so long.
I know!
What the hell?
I almost killed the cat too.
And then...
And then the ash booped me into him.
I'm so sad.
I got booped into it.
I'm coming back now.
It's winnable.
I'm behind ya.
Nevermind.
Um...
It might not be winnable.
I'm pretty squishy too.
Shoot.
Oh my god.
I'm so sad.
I almost killed that cat.
We'll get it.
It's okay.
Next round.
It's close.
It's a close game.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
I wish I had a mercy pocket.
I thought this would be better for us.
I got stupid cats with a mercy pocket.
I'm gonna do more...
I'm gonna do more weapon power.
Yeah.
Same.
Yeah, that's the...
One thing that's good.
And then more...
There's so many...
There's so many different things to buy.
Yeah.
It's like...
There's like...
A lot.
Oh...
Armor pierce.
There's an armor pierce?
Armory damage.
No armor pierce?
What the fuck is it?
Oh my god.
Chat's so right.
Pocket Mercy.
Pocket Diva.
Like, are you fucking...
That cat says everything!
Yeah.
Where's my pocket Mercy?
And pocket Diva?
Are our healers dying?
They're...
Dying pretty often?
Yeah.
I'll just stay next to our healers, actually.
I'll stop flanking.
That Diva is like...
Just perma...
On me.
Whenever I try to flank.
It's like...
I can't really do much.
I'll just play in the back line, I guess.
All I can do is just farm the Diva Mech then.
I...
He's already dead.
Alright.
I don't know how.
I'm just staying on point, bros.
Oh no!
No!
I feel like I wasn't even that far up, but...
Okay, well...
At least...
So much damage.
Yeah.
Heal me!
Our board just watched me!
Oh my god.
I swear to god.
I swear...
You think that they have...
Because they have a Mercy and we don't?
Yeah.
No, our...
Our Mora is DPSing.
She...
I was literally next to her, and then she just looked at me.
Oh.
I...
I'm just like, are you serious?
I'm...
Oh no.
Our...
Our Juno isn't healing either.
She has 200 fucking heals.
That's crazy.
That's...
I...
Our Juno has 200 heals!
I feel like I'm not...
I'm not getting any healing, right?
Yeah.
No, no.
Press stab and see how much heals our Juno has done.
It's...
It's actually no heals.
Oh.
Oh my god.
How do...
How have I done more healing?
I know, right?
No!
Of course it's Diva's here!
He doesn't...
No!
He saw me!
What?
400?!
How is this Juno with 400 heals?!
I got her said!
I tried to touch point, but yeah, I can't even get close.
Yeah.
I think it's just unfortunate teammates.
Right!
We just don't have good...
We don't have people as teammates.
We have AI.
I can't believe it.
Now we have four AI's.
Is that a thing that Overwatch does?
No.
Quick play, yeah.
Apparently there's like, bots in quick play.
Hey!
We have four AI's.
Ah.
Hey!
It's okay.
But we're the ones that...
We're the good AI's.
We're not the cheap ones.
We actually learn.
Okay.
We're the one...
We're the learning AI.
Oh my god.
I don't know what to do with art...
Art...
Art supports.
Look at this.
I'll just do more weapon power.
Honestly.
Oh no.
I feel like I can't do anything with D.Va and Mercy Pocket.
You mean when I play in the backline?
Some...
Some, uh...
When I play in the backline, I'm not getting healed either.
Yeah.
Do you have like, life steal?
I could get life steal, yeah.
Maybe I'll get that.
Uh...
Well, I'll get this out then.
Or I saw that there's some where like, when you get a kill...
But then again...
Yeah, I'm just gonna go...
I'm just gonna go with life steal.
Yeah, like, it's hard to get kills.
Like, oh my god.
The fucking Ashe has 80% damage in ability.
But it's hard to do, um...
Uh...
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Kills, because like, they're Mercy and...
Their supports are actually healing each other.
Or like, healing their team.
Our support is like...
Yeah.
I don't know.
They're...
They're taking a vacation right now.
It's their break.
Three...
Two...
One...
Right.
Well, I mean, school is out for the summer, so...
That's true.
It's summer vacation for our supports.
All I can do is just shoot D.Va.
I want a flank, but I can't.
Must be nice.
Oh my god, you're so low!
You're already so low!
It's crazy!
I got some heals.
Oh my god!
Yeah.
It's actually crazy how low you were.
Jesus.
I got Cass, at least.
Yeah, I got a survival thing that's like...
20%...
I don't know if it's 20% or 10% less damage on critical hits.
Which is headshots, right?
Oh my god.
I think our supports are healing us now.
Oh my god!
What?!
Maybe Chao was right in that making you...
Maybe you should pick D.Va.
That could've been you.
Yeah.
That could've been you on the D.Va buff.
He gets that so often, doesn't she?
I think it's just her...
Her ultimate.
She's probably buying stuff.
I know.
To be fair, she's getting heavily pocketed.
Like, I can't even kill her.
I've been shooting her all day.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh my god.
She's D.Va matricing their fucking cast too!
Oh my god!
What is that like?!
How...
What is it like to have that much fucking protection?
Oh shit!
Oh!
It sucks!
Oh, she has a quick explosion perk.
So, her explosion goes...
Goes for...
Like...
Explodes faster.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
I'm jealous.
Watch this, they're gonna res her.
Oh my god.
OK, the Cassidy's dead.
I didn't even know where the fuck it is!
Oh my god!
Goodbye!
Raid boss down!
Oh my god, doesn't matter!
She gets healed!
It's okay, I got the... Oh my god, look at all the resources they're putting on the baby diva!
Please, actually let the baby die!
Let her die!
Oh my god, please.
Please.
That can't be our LG.
Do we do another?
Ah, we can only one more.
All right.
LG, LG.
Yeah, can't end on a loss.
Exactly.
Whoa, that's a cool Cassidy skin though.
Which one?
Oh, the one I have?
He's like invisible.
Oh, oh, the invisible man one.
Yeah, I didn't know that was a skin.
Oh yeah, that was like... I don't remember.
That was like a special... a Halloween one.
All right.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now I'm angry.
Wait, I re... I... you can re-pick.
I wanna... I'll try playing support since I haven't played support yet.
Oh, that's true.
Oh wait, let me... Oh, let me re-pick then.
I'll do the tank and... tank and damage.
Okay.
Oh, wait, what's your favorite support?
Oh, the diva bomb.
Yeah, the stupid diva bomb.
Oh, you gotta pick support again.
I like Lucio.
Oh, Lucio has a really good... has like a mega boop... ability.
I haven't seen a lot of Lucio to be fair.
when I was playing stadium.
Oh, you can play him in this game mode?
Yeah.
Yeah, I haven't seen him at all.
Um, the meta is Juno and Mercy.
Is he good to play?
Can I... should I try?
Um, he's not meta, but you'll see more Juno, Mercy, and Mora.
Because Juno, her E ability, you know, the one where she sends those like little missiles.
Um, you can... you can max it out so much that... um, on a squishy, it does like 80% damage on a squishy.
So they're literally almost one shot.
Oh.
That's how fucking scary it is.
I never played her before though.
I've never... this would be my first time.
Yeah, but uh, Mora is also really strong too.
I kinda wanna try Lucio though.
Yeah, you try Lucio.
Okay.
Try Lucio.
I know that some people can make it work on Lucio.
Alright.
Oh my god, thank god.
Okay, now we have a D.Va.
Okay, our D.Va better.
I hope our D.Va lives.
Like, mystery man.
And D.Va felt kind of OP in the last game.
Yeah.
Sure.
Like, she couldn't die.
I literally, like, their Kiriko and Mercy just fucking pumped every resource into that D.Va.
I was like... Is this gonna be good?
Like, these heals?
Is it gonna be no?
Uh, it should be fine.
I'm pretty sure you can have... if you have ability power.
Ability power makes more heals.
Okay.
And stronger boops.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Gotcha.
I'm pretty sure it's ability.
Oh, they went meta.
Meta heals.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Uh...
What?
Okay.
These are example builds.
Picked by the pros to start our competitors off on the right.
I'm just gonna do this.
And then...
Back speed.
Alright.
I'm ready.
I'm so ready.
I'm locked in now, for real.
Wait, I should... I'm gonna grab water real quick.
Up or back.
Okay.
Chat, which one do I pick?
There's this one, which says it increases 80% projectile size, which sounds cool.
No, no, I'll do this one.
I'll do this one later.
Uh, yeah, I'll go with this, uh, mixtape, I think.
Bottom left one is good.
Beat drop?
20%.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, that is good.
True, true, true.
Okay.
I'll get this one now, and then I'll get this one later, and then I'll get this one later.
That sounds like fun.
Um...
Ability.
Get back in time!
Yeah!
All right, I'm ready.
Oh, frick.
What happened?
Now I was gonna buy something else, but it's fine.
I don't need it.
Probably.
Yeah, you can do it next round.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's just like a test run.
Might not have been good anyway.
Oh my god!
Okay.
Okay, I'm healed.
I was gonna say, I hope I get healed.
That'll be pretty cool.
I'm healing, I'm healing.
Oh my god!
Our D.Va?
Bashku's still low!
Oh my god!
I believe in our team.
That's crazy.
Ow.
Thank you.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Oh my god, they're so fast.
Whoops!
I stood in lava.
Oh, was their tank AFK?
I don't remember seeing their tank at all.
No, they died really fast.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I'm so fast!
I'm so fast!
Oh!
I feel so fast.
I'm not used to it.
It's been so long.
No, I'm healing.
I'm not speed boosting.
I'm healing.
I feel so fast.
No, I think it was the Juno.
It was the...
Oh my god!
Now the Juno sped me.
I was like disoriented.
Nice.
You did it.
Wait, does Juno also have like a speed boost?
Yeah, she sends out a ring where if you go through it, um, you go like, it gives you a mini speed boost.
Oh, yeah.
So like, it like fucked me up because I was like, I can't aim for that.
I was like, where am I aiming?
Yeah, that makes sense.
He's gonna charge.
I'm gonna try and break it though.
Wait, is that Reaper?
Oh, nice up.
I'm scared now.
Nice.
You're serious.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, everybody's flying too much.
No!
Yeah, I...
It's okay.
I believe I, I, uh, stopped her Juno.
I believe.
Just start, just start wall riding.
Okay.
Just start running around the walls.
I'm coming back.
Oh, wait, this is 9.
Yay.
Oh, right.
He was on.
Yay.
Nice.
He got distracted, yeah.
Oh, we're doing it.
Let's competition this round.
Oh, nice.
Oh!
Oh, I thought, uh, I was like, Winston!
So, when did we get our monkey?
I don't think I've seen Winston.
Winston in this game mode, I feel like, would be cool.
Isn't Winston in this game?
I'm pretty sure.
Uh, I don't think so.
Oh.
Yeah, I don't think so.
Let's see.
Armor.
No, I'll do attack speed.
Wait, not yet?
Oh, I thought I saw Winton on here.
Winton.
I'm pretty sure they're adding Winton next patch.
Or in 10 days, because season two.
For Stadium.
Oh!
That's great.
Overwatch is in...
So they're just gonna add more people?
Yeah.
They're not gonna switch people out or anything?
I think so.
I don't know, honestly.
That makes sense.
They have to decide, like, all the abilities and stuff.
Apparently, Sigma, Zen, and some EPS are gonna be in there.
Oh, they're swapping Sigma in.
Oh.
That's interesting.
I heard that, uh...
I heard, like...
You know how, like, Overwatch 2 was supposed to be PvE, um...
PvE?
I heard that...
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I heard that...
Oh, I should've been high ground.
That it was, like...
They basically took, like, the stuff that was supposed to be in PvE section, and then made it turn into, uh, Stadium.
Which I thought was funny.
Yeah.
It makes sense, though.
Like, the fact that...
They got, like, the stuff that they want to do.
But...
But where are they?
This works out, then, kind of?
Yeah.
You know, at least...
At least there's...
That's where the Q comes from.
Crew?
What the fuck?
Oh my...
I don't...
Okay.
I don't know how the fuck I got the Reaper kill.
Oh.
Ow.
All right.
Oh, nice.
Like, when...
You know, like...
Okay, so Cassidy has an ability, uh, where, like, it gives me more ammo.
Uh-huh.
But, like, fucks with me so much, because I'm like, Oh, I should reload right now.
Because I can reload.
Yeah.
I'm like, wait a minute.
No, I have enough ammo.
Oh.
God, I have so much fucking ammo.
It's actually crazy.
Oh.
Oh my god, soldier!
What are you doing here?
Oh my god, and you get a pocket?
Nice.
I had to ult or else I'd die.
That's good.
It was worth it.
That's fucking right.
No risk.
Okay, that run.
Oh, nice.
I was gonna say, that run has ult.
We did it!
He's getting melted.
Oh my god.
Yeah, that team died so fast.
Yeah, I kind of feel bad for that.
No, what do you do?
They have the, uh, little placards.
They play a lot, right?
Yeah, they do.
That means they play a lot.
Oh, they got the bottom.
I love the bottom 500 tag.
Apparently, it was an April Fool's shit.
Let's see.
What?
The bottom 500.
Let's see.
I still don't know, like, what...
Oh, not...
Fuck it.
I want auto-aim bot.
And...
Cool down reduction.
More weapon power.
Always weapon power.
Let's see.
That's 4,000.
5,000.
Actually, do I have enough?
No, I don't.
Oh, what did I buy?
Attack speed.
There's attack speed.
Or was it life steal?
Attack speed.
I don't know.
I should do a life steal or attack speed.
And that was it.
Yeah.
I couldn't math.
I thought, like, I mapped correctly for a purple upgrade.
It's the hardest part.
It's just like CS.
It's good for your brain.
It's exercise.
No.
I don't want to exercise.
For your brain.
Just put my Twitter brain right.
At Croc, is this real?
Oh my god.
He's so low.
I got her.
Oh my god.
They're dying so fast.
It's actually crazy.
I'm just gonna cap it.
Maybe they're...
I was gonna say no.
I was gonna say maybe they're new to this game.
No.
There's no way.
There's like...
There's like 10 days left till the end of the season.
We'll be up here.
Hey.
Oh.
Hi.
Guys.
Yo.
I'm okay now.
I'm okay.
I hear a soldier.
Where is this soldier?
Oh my god.
Bye.
Why are they following me?
Because you're killing them.
You're dangerous.
Barely.
They want to get rid of you.
They don't even like...
They're not even going forward.
Where are they going?
They're not even walking forward.
They're walking backwards.
I'm so confused.
Okay.
Now they're walking forward.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
I got mercy.
I'll save you.
Oh, thank you.
My hero.
Oh damn.
Oh my...
I don't know how I got that mercy.
That Ryan is scary.
Oh my god.
I'm so fucking glad that shit's over.
Okay.
Wait.
I think this was just the play right now.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, do me here.
Before...
You have to...
Yeah.
You have to look at replay and then look where I was before you ulted me.
You have to see it.
No, I was watching you.
He was like backing you into a corner, right?
Yeah, yeah.
But you see me get randomly got the mercy kill.
While I was running around.
I didn't see it.
No, you have to see that.
That was actually crazy.
I don't know how I fucking live there.
Wait a second.
Game reports.
All right chat.
I'll show it to you guys.
You were like my actual hero there.
I was like...
I thought I was...
I'm gonna play your stream on my screen.
Okay.
I'll show you.
Where is this?
I'll show it.
Okay.
Let me know when...
Let me know when you're here.
Well then I gotta...
Then I gotta put something on really quick.
My hero.
I was like...
If I'm going to die, I'll bring someone down with me.
Yeah.
Let me know...
When I can play.
All right.
I'm in.
Okay.
Watch this.
You see...
We see the ride.
And I was like...
Oh, fuck.
There's the mercy.
I was like...
If I'm gonna die...
I am gonna bring her down with me.
I have to drive by.
You fucked that man.
You got him.
Yeah.
That's what you get, Ryan.
You led me straight to your mercy.
That's fun.
Easy.
Easy clap.
I probably would never have tried that game mode on my own, but I'm glad you introduced me to it.
Because at first, I was like...
My brain was being overloaded.
Yeah.
With too much stuff happening.
Since I haven't played Overwatch in a long time.
Yeah.
But it was fun.
I think the more you understand, the more fun it is when you're doing these insane builds that you can play around with.
Because you're like, oh, I should do this now, and I should sell that.
That's the best part about the stadium.
Because you're always trying...
Instead of counterpicking, you're just redoing your build and stuff.
So it's like Paladin slash Deadlock.
I wonder if Deadlock is still alive.
I feel like...
I think, yeah, it is.
Is it?
I know some people that still play actively, yeah.
I feel like ever since Marvel Rivals released, Deadlock felt kind of dead.
That's true.
Because Marvel Rivals came out not too long after Deadlock started getting popular.
Yeah, it started getting traction.
And then everybody just went straight to Marvel Rivals after that.
To be fair, it's still in beta.
So I feel like...
And it's Valve, you know?
Valve won't let that game die.
It's like their first game in how many years?
Like 10 plus years since they made a fucking game.
They have that good old Steam money.
And also, I think the competitive for it is still not actually out.
So they have a false competitive type of thing going on right now.
They don't have an official thing.
It's their...
Yeah.
And I feel like, you know, they have Steam money.
So, like, they're just going to pump so much money into it until it lives.
I have all the CS cases, all the money from that.
Yeah, yeah, it's true.
All the CS cases and stuff.
Wait, Artifact is from Valve?
I didn't know that.
I'd like...
To be fair, I forgot Artifact existed, to be fair.
Wait, what's from Valve?
Artifact?
Yeah, no, that's a good...
That's a...
I don't even know.
I see Evolve, because they also made Evolve.
Evolve was fun.
That one died pretty quickly.
I think Evolve was fun, though.
It's just like...
Yeah, it was cool.
I just...
It was just...
I think there was just not enough content.
But it felt like once you played it a few times, you've already experienced it.
Yeah, there was just not enough content for Evolve.
And then, after they realized that, they just...
Oh, they should have done a collab with like, Godzilla.
Yeah.
It's all... They should have collab skins like Fortnite.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, Evolve is 2K?
Oh, okay.
So, chat, we got one guy.
Oh, really?
I thought... Why did I think it was...
Yeah, I definitely... I read that from chat and...
Yeah, we got one guy.
I didn't misremember it all.
That was chat's fault.
Yeah, this is chat's fault, not our fault.
We don't think for ourselves.
That's why we're streaming.
We just do it at chat.
Is this real?
True.
Yeah, when I turn off the stream, I don't even have any thoughts in my head.
It's true.
Because chat's not going.
I know.
I'm like, how am I supposed to think for myself if I'm not fed my information?
I do, like, if there's an important decision...
Well, kind of an important decision, I'm always like, fuck, I wish I could ask the chat right now.
It's so true.
I wish I could ask them, like, what they think I should do.
Yeah, like, you know, you're like, oh, which one looks better?
And then you don't have...
I know, we like to keep things a surprise.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
Yeah.
But GG's.
That was fun.
I learned so much in CS.
I actually found CS quite fun.
GG's.
Yeah.
I think, like, especially the fact that we didn't get any hackers.
Yeah, we should play again.
Oh, I would love to.
Yeah.
If you ever want another person to play CS...
I'm glad we didn't bump into any hackers.
That was... I think, like, the very first time I played CS GO...
Two times I played CS GO...
I had a hacker.
Twice.
Twice in a row.
And then every time I got a hacker...
The obvious one, yeah.
Yeah.
The one were the ones that, like, wallhack and everything.
And they were also from Europe.
So...
They were also from Europe.
And was, like...
Swearing at me in Europe.
Like, I think they were swearing at me in Russian.
Oh.
Classic...
Counter-Strike experience.
Yeah.
And then...
And then I...
That's why I didn't touch CS GO for a long, long time.
And I tried to touch it again.
And then I also got into another hacker.
And then I was like, you know what?
Maybe CS is just not for me.
But...
I saw...
I had a lot of fun, though.
You do have to get Prime, I think.
Yeah.
Yeah!
Oh, we had to do this again.
And, like, you can teach me more CS.
And then...
And then you'll have more CS buddies to play with.
Yay!
Yeah, you gotta learn all the other maps.
No!
There's more maps to learn.
You don't call out.
Yeah!
Why learn more maps when I can just do Dust2?
Isn't Dust2 the most important map?
No!
You'll get bored.
Oh!
How can I get bored when it's Dust2?
Yeah!
Dust2 forever!
I'm...
I'm sick of Dust2!
How can you be sick of Dust2?
It's the CS map!
Well, once you play on it, like, three or four times...
It's...
No, it's...
You get tired of it.
What are your favorite maps, then?
Um...
I kind of like Duke right now, and I don't mind Mirage, and...
There's just one that everybody really likes, but it's coming back soon, because they recently purchased it.
Um, from, like, the original creators.
It's called Cache.
Cache?
Wait, what's the Cache map?
Sounds good.
Yeah.
What does that one look like?
Um...
It's, like, gray, and it's got some moss and stuff, and...
It's got a checker floor room.
What?
It's got, like, all these things that are cool.
Holy shit!
I don't even think I remember what Cache looks like.
Yeah.
The only one I remember was the one with the...
With the little, like, sewer area...
At the bottom.
And then...
Oh, oh, oh, overpass.
Yeah, I know that map.
I know...
Everybody knows Dust2.
And then...
Um...
And then the trains.
The mini trains.
Oh, train map?
Yeah, the train map.
That's the only three maps that I remember.
And then...
I know, like, surfing.
Oh!
I tried surfing the other day, like, yesterday.
Yeah?
And I was like, I can't fucking do this.
I'm stuck at it.
I suck.
I think, like...
I'd done surfing, like, once, and I was like...
I was just like, alright.
I'm good.
I am not.
I don't think I can...
Yeah.
Do these sick-ass...
You know, like, those, like, surf montages they do in the past.
Like...
Oh.
In the YouTube drama videos.
Where it's like...
Yeah.
Drama alert!
And then it's just commentary over CSGO surf.
Yeah.
No, nowadays...
Nowadays, there's Minecraft parkour.
That's true!
Yeah, now there's Minecraft parkour.
It's been replaced.
Yeah, it's so true.
Oh my...
Minecraft parkour is, like, brainwashing for me.
I can sit there and watch it for hours.
That's so true.
Yeah.
Have you tried the...
There's, like, the...
You know, like, the...
The beef and chicken?
They actually made a real Minecraft server for that.
Oh.
I...
I gave up.
Honestly, I don't even know what that really is.
Beef or chicken?
You don't know when you...
When you jump for the...
Okay.
I kind of get the idea of it, yeah.
I would say...
Oh, parkour civilization.
Okay, so it's basically...
Okay, it's like a fucking...
I only watched, like, ten minutes of that video.
Because it's apparently, like, a eight-hour series.
Like, the whole series is, like...
Yeah.
Eight plus hours.
And then...
But you get all the information you need in ten minutes.
Because it's, like, will you jump for the chicken or beef?
Oh.
And then after that, it's, like...
It's, like...
It's only, like, four hours.
Yes, but, like, four hours in the internet is, like, eight hours in real life to me.
Um...
Yeah.
I need a...
I gotta ask, like, ChatGPT to summarize, like, newer memes or something.
Yeah.
At Chat, what is the Rizzler?
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
GGs.
Doobie.
Okay, I know that one at least.
Yeah.
I was gonna say.
Oh, my.
It's been...
It's been five hours.
Yeah.
GGs.
Doobie.
I had a great time.
I hope you and...
I hope you and the minions...
Me too.
Have a...
The good rest of your stream.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Were you, like, lagging in real life?
That's what we're gonna go by.
I was like, Doobie, are you okay?
Yeah.
Are you, like, lagging?
I think there's, like, a delay right now between...
No, there's...
There's a delay between our voice chats.
I think.
For some reason.
Wait, really?
There's no delay for me.
Right?
Chat, you guys noticed it.
What is there?
No.
Maybe it's on my side.
I don't know.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
There is no delay for me.
Okay, when I say...
When I say...
Banana...
Banana.
You say Doki.
Doki.
No.
Okay, okay.
Say it one more time.
Banana.
Doki.
What?
How long is this delay?
Banana.
Doki.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Maybe we should just say bot.
Oh my god.
It's really bad.
How does it...
Oh my god.
Like...
How is it lagging on your side?
I'm getting the...
I don't know.
There's...
No way.
Wait.
Is it on her stream lagging as well?
Or...
Or it's just like...
Her.
It's just Doki.
I have no idea.
Banana.
Doki.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Okay.
Oh my god.
No, okay.
I like...
There's some...
I think it's Discord.
I...
Tab to Discord.
And then the MS was at 300 MS.
Oh.
Yeah.
You were like cutting in and out for me for some reason.
Oh my...
Wait.
Was I cutting in and out?
Sometimes.
The whole entire time?
Or like just recently?
No.
Just sometimes.
Just like maybe...
I changed the server.
Just what?
Maybe that fixed it.
Just...
No, don't...
Don't worry about it.
I think you're really out of sync, so...
Oh my...
Yeah, but on my end it was fine.
It was...
That's weird.
Oh.
That is weird.
Yeah.
The chat was saying that you were cutting in and out.
But like...
I...
It wasn't like super noticeable for me.
Yeah.
Same.
That's so weird.
I mean Discord has been like really fucking weird lately.
Same with Twitch.
I think like people...
Yeah.
I think like internet security is just weird in general.
Well, I think more people...
They're trying to get more money for...
That's true.
Server costs.
Yeah.
Which is probably not what the money is going towards.
I heard that...
They're just finding ways to cut back.
Hmm.
I heard like when...
You know Discord got...
Like the CEO...
You heard like the CEO like...
Dropped...
Um...
Step down.
And then they hired a new CEO.
Yeah.
And then like...
The first thing they were...
They were planning on doing like...
They were trying to do like...
Um...
Ads or something.
Did you hear that?
I was like how the fuck do you put ads in Discord?
Like...
With like...
Before you get into this call...
Do you want to watch this video?
Oh...
I was thinking of it.
I'm so sick of the internet right now.
The way it is.
It's just like...
You need...
Like I want to watch...
I pay...
I have Amazon Prime.
Yeah.
So I want to watch like...
A Prime show or something.
And it's like...
You need to pay $2.99 to watch this without ads.
It's like...
What the fuck?
It was so annoying.
I think I was watching...
Invincible or something.
And then like...
Yes!
The moment...
You know like...
The crucial moment...
It was like...
Here's like...
30 seconds of ads.
I'm like...
What?
Wait...
What am I paying for?
Like what?
Don't I pay for this already?
Yeah.
And then it's like...
No, you have to buy like...
The Amazon Prime Privilege Pack.
Yeah.
And then...
And then the same thing with Twitter.
It's like...
Oh, you don't want to see ads?
Even though you already pay for...
Twitter...
Yeah!
So dumb.
That's so dumb.
Yeah, they're just like...
Yeah, cause like...
Nobody watches TV anymore.
So they're like...
The ad companies are like...
We gotta put it somewhere.
Yeah.
I guess.
I had to...
I had to buy a YouTube...
What is it called?
The...
Um...
The YouTube equivalent.
The subscription base now.
Uh...
I don't remember what it was called.
But...
Oh, yeah.
Premium.
Yeah.
I had to get the YouTube premium.
Because I was...
I was so tired of...
You know how they recently patched like...
Plugins?
Yeah.
Plugins, yeah.
The buy premium.
Cause I was like...
I just wanna watch my silly YouTube videos.
I don't even remember what YouTube video pushed me over the edge.
I told chat what it was.
And my chat was like...
I can't believe this...
This was the...
Video that caused you to buy YouTube premium.
But you know...
They're changing YouTube premium too.
Now you have to get like...
A smaller premium.
Yeah.
To avoid ads.
Oh, I remember.
Yeah.
I was watching Ink Master.
I was like...
And I was like...
I'm tired of these ads.
I'm trying to watch Ink Master.
I wanna know how they fuck up these tattoos.
At least it wasn't the beef or chicken like parkour so...
Oh, that's so true.
Like eight hours.
Yeah.
Thank God I wasn't that brain-rotted.
But yeah.
GG's Doobie.
GG's.
I hope...
You'll rest well.
I had a great time playing with you.
Me too.
You can talk to my Drag Orange now.
And you can talk to your little minions.
Your little...
Double...
Mini D's.
Oh.
Cute.
Mini D's.
Your Dubert's.
Your Orphans.
Whatever they are.
Oh, okay.
Whatever.
The Dubes.
Oh my God.
That's cute.
The Dubes.
Yeah.
That is cute.
The Dublings.
Oh my God.
Dublings.
One day.
One day you'll be named.
Well, I...
It's in the works.
You'll see.
Oh, there's Orbeez.
Or...
Ordeez.
Ordeez?
Or...
Ordeez Nuts.
Yeah.
Doobie and the Dubes.
But...
Alright.
Scooby Doobies.
Oh, I like that.
The Scooby Doobies.
But there's like a...
It's copyright.
Well, I guess it's fine.
Probably.
One day.
I'm...
I'm looking forward to...
To the naming ceremony.
Whenever that day is.
Yeah.
I'll hold a big celebration stream.
A big...
It's like a huge...
Big announcement.
Yeah.
We're gonna go to Chuck E.
Cheese and everything.
Yeah.
And then we'll have like a whole day dedicated to the naming ceremony.
Okay.
I'll do it.
Oh my god.
It'll be a such...
It'll be a celebration.
It'll be like an anniversary or something too.
Like your...
Yeah.
Your five year anniversary.
And then you're like, it's time to...
Five?
I don't know.
You'll be named.
Maybe I'll do it this year.
This year.
This one year anniversary.
This year?
Oh my god.
Lil Doobs.
You'll be named soon.
Yeah.
Oh wait.
Speaking of special events.
Do you have...
Yeah.
Do you have any special events?
Don't you have some special events coming up soon?
So we can...
Oh.
Oh tomorrow.
There's a special stream tomorrow.
There's an announcement stream for something.
Really?
Yeah.
And then...
And then next month...
Uh...
There's an anime expo concert.
Birthday concert.
And then also...
Doobie also has a concert next month too!
Yeah!
Yeah.
A lot of exciting stuff happens at Anime Expo.
There's so many things going on.
To be honest, it's like the biggest anime convention too, so it makes sense.
Yeah.
Yeah, there's so many people there.
Oh, are you excited for your concert?
Yeah, I'm so excited for everybody to see the hard work everybody's putting in.
Yeah, I'm excited to see you dance again.
Oh, thank you.
I wish I could see your concert too, but it's like, you have to be there in person, right?
Yeah, yeah, so like...
Well, mine's a day...
I'll watch a video afterwards.
I think mine's like two days before yours, right?
Yours is on the 5th, right?
Yeah, it's on the 5th.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So...
I think...
Yeah.
I can catch your concert and you can catch my concert, I think.
Yeah, it's not overlapping at least.
That's good.
So like, for those who are going to Anime Expo, you can actually watch both our concerts at the...
Not same time, but like, you know.
If you're there, you might as well catch both of us, you know?
The D&Ds.
Yeah.
If you can't go for my concert, there are streaming tickets online.
Yeah, there's no streaming tickets for mine, but like, it'll be uploaded later.
Yes.
Like, the Blu-ray edition.
On Twitter.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Well, like, yeah, I'm planning on uploading my concert on YouTube, like, fully.
Later.
Yeah.
Nice.
Yippee!
And then I hope the copyright law, like, copyright lawyers don't get me.
Oh.
Yeah.
Well, as long as you don't monetize it.
Like, I put copyright stuff all the time, but...
Yeah, as long as...
Yeah, they can take the money.
It's alright.
They need more...
Yeah.
They need more money anyway.
Do they?
Do they really?
Hi, me.
The millionaires need more money.
Yeah.
I'll see you later, Doobie.
Thank you for inviting me to play.
Yeah.
Hope you have a nice night.
Me too.
I hope you rest well, because I know you might be crashing from caffeine.
Probably.
Yeah.
Alright.
GG's.
Bye-bye.
Wow!
That was fun.
I had a great time with Doobie.
I can't believe we were on streaming for, like, five plus hours.
I am...
I think she's tired.
I'm tired.
I'm...
Like, you know, like, the...
What's the word?
You know, like, um, after a while, like, the...
The adrenaline...
The adrenaline dies down.
Yeah, my adrenaline's gone now.
How does he know?
I don't know how dad knows every time.
He knows exactly when I'm about to end stream.
It's crazy.
I guess it's like my tone of voice or some shit.
But I had a great time.
I had a great time playing with Doobie.
Um, it was fun learning CS.
I think, uh, um, I learned a lot playing CS, uh, with her.
She's a good teacher.
Um, and I had a fun time.
I'm repeating a lot because I'm tired.
I had a walk dad as soon as stream ends.
Uh, cause it's walkies time.
I also need to give his medicine.
But thank you, everybody, for coming.
I'm gonna head off now.
I didn't think we were streaming so long, but I had so much fun.
I had so much fun playing over.
But thank you everyone for coming.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture-checked.
Get everyone around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys!
Bye!